majority or various other things so I
read the script all right give me just a
moment to set everything up for you
representative Pearson I'll be right
there
all right go right ahead
as chairman of the house Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order
number 12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee meeting of the
health human services and elderly
Affairs Committee of the New Hampshire
House of Representatives
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
listen contemporaneously and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
unnecessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and RSA 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public as a whole is
unable to access this meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled Christina dayak committee
researcher will be the staff assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
his or her presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting and this is
required under the right to know law
representative Marsh will be joining us
he is testifying elsewhere and
representative Folsom will be joining us
soon after she finishes a doctor's
appointment will the acting clerk please
call the roll
thank you Mr chairman I may be going in
a different order so be prepared
representative Marsh representative
Folsom representative McMahon a present
I'm alone in my office in Windham
representative Nelson president
president yeah present in his home in
Brookfield sorry
representative Acton I'm present alone
in my kitchen in Fremont
representative gay
representative Cushman
hi I'm president
um in my home and where and my husband
and children are in the house but not in
the room
representative Kelsey
I'm present at my home in Bedford I'm in
the room alone but my daughter is in the
house representative King
present um in my kitchen alone my son is
upstairs and uh doing College studies
representative colfault
uh present I am in my home office in
Wilton there are other people in the
house not currently in the room though I
was saying the weather
I am at home in Walpole and I am alone
representative McKay
representative McKay you need to unmute
you can see him representative letter
I can see him yes I can see him too all
right he's here representative snow
here in my home in in Manchester in my
apartment my wife is present elsewhere
in the apartment representative
here in my study in Freedom my wife is
elsewhere in the house representative
salloway present uh at my home office
and alone in Lee New Hampshire
representative Cannon
I'm present I'm home alone in my home in
Somerset New Hampshire
representative natarappan I'm here in
Nashua alone in this room but another
family member is in the house
representative Shapiro
I'm home alone in my office in my home
in Keene my wife
sorry representative Woods
uh yes president I'm here in my study in
Beau and in the house by myself
representative Merchant here I'm in my
home in Claremont New Hampshire my wife
is somewhere in the house
representative Pearson here I am I say
presently uh in my house in Hampstead no
one's in the house with me we have a
quorum sir thank you
representative is unmuted
this is Betty gay and I am here
finally
with great difficulty
glad you're here
where is here
oh in in our office and John is in the
house okay good thank you
all right with that
um I am going to at the request of the
sponsor of House Bill 582 take this one
out of order uh representative Mary Beth
Waltz needs to be in a um an exec
session when her bill was originally
scheduled so with that
I call to order a hearing on House Bill
582 relative to prescriptions for the
treatment of attention deficit disorder
or attention deficit disorder with
hyperactivity and the chair calls on
representative walls to present her bill
I
don't oh here she is okay sorry about
that go ahead
okay I'm here so you guys don't do video
it looks like
we do
I'm on video if you want to turn it on
we're running with a new but quite able
technician who is learning the ropes
and I'm not sure that webinar supports
video for the participants rather than
the attend
for the attendees rather than the
participants at least I couldn't figure
out how
to go
wonderful
so I've done this this is like the third
or fourth committee I've been before so
I know it can be done
um so first of all I want to thank the
chair for rescheduling this I do have an
exact session at 10 and I'm very
appreciative of him choosing to take
this bill first and with that I'd like
to introduce myself to you I am
representative Mary Beth walls I
represent Merrimack District number 23
which is the towns of Beau and Dunbarton
along with representative Woods we share
a district
um so this bill came from a constituent
request and as you all know we kind of
all live in small town America and as it
worked out when I was campaigning last
fall I first spoke with the patients
family and then with the patient's
doctor
and they all asked for the same thing so
I said sure I can put a bill on on this
and that's the bill that you have before
you and you will later hear from both
the patient's family
um Mrs Fortier and the Doctor Who is
named Dr call both of whom should be in
the waiting room on this to testify as
well but with that let me introduce the
bill and tell you a little bit about it
what this bill does is it extends the
length of time for a renewal on a
prescriptions for add from 60 days to 90
days
um and what that means for the patients
and for the doctors is that it goes from
six co-pays a year to four co-pays a
year
now it turns out that uh health
insurance companies don't prorate
co-pays
so let's say your copay is a hundred
dollars if you've got a 60-day
prescription you pay the hundred dollars
if you've got a 90-day prescription you
pay the hundred dollars so you're going
from uh by going from six co-pays to
four co-pays you're saving at least out
of pocket a third of the cost of the
drugs for the patients
in addition
um I'm sure you all know there is a
shortage of psychiatrists in this state
and there's an especially acute shortage
of child psychiatrists and Dr call is
just that a child's psychiatrist and for
them to have to write that many more
prescriptions is really onerous and in
some cases they have to patients have to
physically pick up the prescriptions so
they have to coordinate with the doctor
to actually physically receive the
prescription
I know that this rule is inconsistent
with all the other drugs that patients
are taking the other drugs that they
take are on 90 day renewals including
things like Xanax which is even far more
dangerous than these kinds of drugs that
you are on for ADD
um it's kind of ironic because it's
particularly difficult for this illness
patients who have ADD have difficulties
with executive functioning which means
prescription renewal they're often not
organized enough to repeatedly order
refills on time so they don't run out
this extends the time between refills it
gives them better options to doing that
and it requires fewer refills so there's
less times less opportunities they have
to miss getting a refill
I'm not really sure why this drug was
changed from 90 days to 60 days but I
have a suspicion that had to do with the
opioid crisis but you will hear from Dr
call that really whether somebody has a
60-day supply or a 90-day Supply does
not influence whether or not somebody's
likely to try and sell these to their
friends
um and so that extending this to 90 days
is unlikely to have any effect on
whether the patient tries tries to do
something illegal with them
um drugs are expensive and refills are
frankly we all know a pain in the neck
I'm asking with this legislation that
you please support these patients help
these patients and pass this Bill
thank you any questions from the
committee for representative walls
I'm going to need to be told who has
hands up because I don't I see any
and that's probably because she did such
a good job
we have
a state representative Chris Schultz
ready to speak as well I I have the list
of people who wish to speak thank you uh
because I don't usually but thank you
for that rep I do see a hand
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking this question
can you explain
um why there's a distinction made
um for
describing the same kinds of medication
for narcolepsy as opposed to attention
deficit disorder
well the law
only was for ADHD subsequently I was
talking to Dr Collins she looked at the
bill and looked at the law and said oh I
should have asked you to do it for
narcolepsy too and she said the same
issues apply but given that the request
to me was only for add that was all I
changed in the law
thank you
um I want to follow that up myself and
ask representative Waltz if someone from
our committee brought forth an amendment
to ask narcolepsy would you uh be okay
with that I'd be completely supportive
of it all right
who would like to do that
representative Shapiro thank you so much
therefore we will hold the bill for
executing when we get to the end of this
so that can be brought forth perhaps by
next week anyone else on the committee
with a hand up
seeing none thank you representative and
have a good exact session thank you
you're welcome chair now calls
um
representative Schultz who has signed up
to speak
can you hear me we can oh great thank
you Mr chair and to the committee I'll
be very brief uh I also heard from
constituents who were very excited about
this bill
um they are two adults that are a couple
and uh has they've said almost verbatim
What representative Waltz said that it's
a cruel irony that there are extra Hoops
put up for people who have ADHD that
affects executive functioning uh because
the very medication that helps you with
executive functioning and the ability to
pick up the medication more frequently
is exactly the hoop that you're jumping
through so
um I am here on their behalf I don't
know that I can answer any of your
questions other than uh I know that one
of the the the female of this couple has
been taking Adderall for 14 years
and has shown consistency in her
prescription and except for the times
when it's been difficult to pick it up
because of the hoops and to have this
made available like the rest of her
prescriptions for a 90-day Supply would
enable her to only have those sorts of
Hoops uh you know this at the same rate
she has her other medication so this
would be very helpful to many people who
suffer from an affect disorder that
affects executive functioning thank you
and thank you representative Schultz
we'll be seeing you this afternoon with
your own bill at one o'clock looking
forward to it all right
the chair would now like to call Dr
Linda call
hi can you hear me okay
yes we can all right perfect so I am Dr
Dr Linda Carl I'm a board certified
Child and Adolescent psychiatrist as
well as a board certified in adult uh
General Psychiatry
um absolutely I think um
um representative walls really she
really nailed to the heart of what this
is all about and that is making sure
that that we have
um Equitable
um treatment for this medication that
has been absolutely life-changing for a
number of folks who are struggling with
ADHD
ADHD is one of those
um those what can be a very debilitating
and can lead to all sorts of if
untreated all sorts of risks to academic
social emotional problems self-esteem
um you know seeing um folks seeing
themselves as being lazy uh not able to
get tasks done untreated it certainly
can lead to more more job performance
for issues for adults marital and family
issues we know that the um the
likelihood of having a negative effect
it goes up it's at least twice for those
who are untreated for for things like
likelihood to use substances to try to
self-treat
um this is this is for folks who are not
treated the folks who are treated
um
are much more likely to to be right
online with with their peers who do not
have ADHD so when treated these meds are
extremely beneficial social to to even
the playing field in terms of some of
the risks in my experience I have not
seen any downside to having a 90-day
scripts which I prior to being in New
Hampshire
um was you know was the case where it
was a federal law I've not seen you know
I'm very careful about diagnosing and
prescribing and I've seen the just the
the the benefits of um
of this these medications for treating
ADHD and the frustrations to both the
prescribers the and most of all the
patients when
um you know when the the meds are not in
line you know both the cost
um of paying for a a 90-day script but
getting a 60 or having to go to the
local pharmacy and paying the higher
co-pay every 30 days most of the
insurance companies are not rec they're
not recognizing a 60-day script they
either want the 90 for chronic mids or
30. you know so it becomes this this
whole enormous difficulty to
um to overcome
um I am thrilled to be
to be here and I thank you for your all
of your time
um and understanding about that
um
what I find is that when when patients
are on these medications and stabilized
that there's not you know that they they
do well this there is
um huge positive benefit and there is no
negative to receiving a 90-day
um Beyond 60. I also appreciate that um
the bringing up of the the neurology I
since I don't prescribe as a
psychiatrist I don't prescribe for
narcolepsy I refer I'm in the same board
but that's not that's not my area
um it it just didn't dawn on me when
when um Mary Beth walls and I were
speaking but um but I absolutely agree
that you know anything we can do to to
make this um better a better experience
for those of our fellow New Hampshire
residents I think would be fantastic
will you take questions absolutely Dr
Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Dr
Paul
um
is it true that there are some people
who are treated for attention deficit
disorder with non-stimulant medications
and if so if so is that an issue
um for them in terms of the length of
prescription no there's um they are
allowed so some of the non-non stimulant
medications are meds like intuitive
which is in the blood pressure class
it's long-acting guanfacine meds like
Strattera those meds are 90-day scripts
and they actually are allowed refills
the stimulants were currently limited to
60 days and there are no refills allowed
follow-up yes sir
um I can assume this from your comments
but I probably should have asked before
I offered to write an amendment
um
do I take it that you don't see any
contraindications or dangers for making
the same change for narcolepsy
absolutely I think there would be no
contraindications and I think this would
be it enormously helpful for narcolepsy
as well
um to have to have scripts aligned with
the other medications which is very
often 90 day scripts at this point
uh I have a question for the doctor uh
where is your practice based so I'm in
Concord I live in BO I'm in Concord I'm
at Concord Behavioral Health okay I'm 89
North State Street thank you I asked
that because I'm looking for
um a child and for an adult psychiatrist
to refer some of our patients to and as
has been testified you're very thin on
the ground
and absolutely true my so just a very
brief background I started off teaching
math I taught everything from seventh
grade through calculus
um I loved it I absolutely loved what I
what I did
um but I also saw the effects of not
treating
um in childhood for a number of
different reasons whether it's anxiety
ADHD you know or a number of other
factors trauma
um and so so I went to med school
um and because I I finally I reached the
point where I said you know there's I
have I'm a parent and a grandparent
there's there's no place for these kids
to go and there there's just such a huge
shortage I either have to
you know to to knowing that I could do
it I needed to do it
um well I wasn't sure I could do it but
I did
um and um because there is such a huge
shortage and I do my very best to
um to try to keep the door open as much
as I can so that new patients aren't
left without a place to go
thank you so much for your service thank
you
is there anyone else uh who wishes to
testify that is not on my list they
would have come on in the last hour
Mr chairman this is representative walls
hi you have Joanne Fortier there
somewhere or yes yes I'm looking right
at her name and totally not
comprehending um I should not say this
in this company uh
are you several scripts will be written
and sent in I'm sorry Joanne 48 please
you're the mom
foreign
can you hear me yes we can thank you for
coming to testify wonderful I appreciate
you taking the time to hear what I have
to say my teenage son has ADHD
he's been on medication for seven years
it is tremendously helpful in managing
his schoolwork and his Focus his ability
to stay on task
the change in the law would simply
enable us to get prescriptions less
frequently and it's not just the co-pays
but the time it takes to manage getting
the prescription at the appropriate time
not too early so as it can't be refilled
but not too late so that he runs out so
I greatly appreciate your your
willingness to consider this bill
we're happy to help any questions for
the mom
seeing none I thank you for coming and
thank the representative for this bill
and representative Shapiro for going to
get an amendment and
seeing no one else
wanting to testify
then I will bring this hearing to a
close on Bill 582. we will hope to
execute next week
I now open the hearing on House Bill one
four three
representative our own representative
Merchant and would you introduce your
bill please and I believe an amendment
as well
that's true Mr chairman
I come before the committee of Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
and colleagues public members my name is
Gary Merchant representative from
Sullivan County District 4.
Claremont Ward 2. before you today is
House Bill 143 there are three distinct
sections to the bill
the first one regards to e-prescribing
what they call electronic prescribing
the middle one is dealing with a
provision in the Consumer Protection Law
dealing with software vendors that have
a tendency to violate their
um what they're doing within the
software functionality used by
prescribers or by clinicians and also a
requirement for the data
that's supplied by the pharmacy that the
data also includes a data element to
help monitor
electronic prescribing so let me do the
first one with e-prescribing
e-prescribing is now required will be
required in January 2022 by the federal
government unfortunately the federal
government only deals with
prescriptions paid by Medicaid I've been
sorry Medicare Part D
so to address all prescriptions the law
the intent of it is to fill in the Gap
so it includes all prescriptions
regardless of the payment Source whether
it's Medicaid or commercial payer or
cash
and many times when you're looking at
diversion
it's the cash paying customers that
create a lot of the problem with
diversion so by asking them to
electronically prescribe it does a
couple of things one is there's a better
data transmission between
the prescriber and the dispenser
going back to what we saw before
that we talked about with 582
with prescriptions one of the
requirements is including
a diagnosis whether it's narcolepsy or
attention deficit disorder
that may have to be written on the
prescription if it's electronically
prescribed it could be placed in a note
field and sent from the prescriber to
the dispenser to use to ensure they have
compliance with the law
secondly when you look at paper
prescriptions today
many times it's a source of diversion a
paper lends itself easily to be
manipulated
you can take something that has a five
and put a one in front of it to make 15
or take a number 50 make it a six and
make it 60. so by having something
electronically prescribed the ability to
divert or to
change and manipulate written
description becomes less
of an issue and that's probably
primarily the reason why the federal
government through the sports Act
decided to have electronic prescribing
for Medicare Part D plans in the first
place
26 states in the country
um deal with this
and we're on the
I would say at this point in time is
probably another 10 in the in the fold
that will probably become
within the next year or so but one of
the things I want to also point out
besides electronic prescribing in the
bill is the issue of something that came
to the attention in Vermont it was
practice fusion uh what practice fusion
did in their software this is before all
scripts bought them all scripts when
they bought them the lawsuit was filed
it was determined that built into the
algorithm used by clinicians
to assess patients was a functionality
to assess pain and if you had a certain
threshold it automatically
without any reason for the provider it
just generated what they call an opium
treatment plan
and in the open treatment plan happened
by
was a drug
for controls
and one of the
manufacturers of that drug was also
providing a stipend to practice fusion
and what happened to the whole thing was
that the FDA I'm sorry the Department of
Justice of the Beaumont chapter did some
research and determined that the
software in fact was
steering providers in a direction
towards a product by the manufacturer so
what this law basically does is try to
allow in our state law in the consumer
protection act language to help prevent
that or at least if it happens we have
some language to go back and saying it
shouldn't have happened we can find him
take action against them
the third part in the law deals with
electronic prescription monitoring and
basically
if the pharmacy
sends to the prescription drug
monitoring program
the type of prescription used by the
prescriber whether it be e-prescribed
whether it be faxed
whether it be written or oral because
there are exceptions in the rule to
accommodate that
that the
database in the prescription drug
monitoring program
can then run reports for the licensing
board
there is no penalty in this if we're
non-compliance but we're trying to allow
the licensing boards to look at where
they may have to spend some time
educationally to help prescribers
with e-rescribing and try to determine
what the barriers are to not doing the
e-prescribing
and lastly in the amendment what came
before was the issue of the veterinarian
community and talking with
Dr Stephen Crawford and Dr Jane Roy
Barlow it came to my attention that
there is not really widely available if
any at all software for a veterinarian
to e-prescribe so to ask the
veterinarians to e-prescribe when the
software the tools that are necessary to
do that didn't make sense so I wrote an
amendment to then exempt the
veterinarians and the way it's written
was modeled after the Arizona law
and in the Arizona law what they
basically said was it's up to the
veterinarians themselves the board of
veterinary medicine to determine on an
annual basis
when the software becomes widely
available so the veterinarians are total
control over when to enact that
provision within the law
also it'll be prescribing a part of it
there are times in which if you look at
the exceptions
when the internet goes down
when a person's not able to get to the
internet you're on a phone call with a
provider the last thing you want to do
is delay therapy for a patient
flying therapy for a patient is not
healthy to them we're trying to find a
way to get a patient taken care of in a
timely prompt manner so by allowing
exceptions in
the bill in the law
it does allow for those things to occur
sometimes it could be a simple thing
where you don't have access to the
internet not because it's not
functioning it's just wherever you're at
it there are parts of this world believe
it or not that you just cannot get
broadband internet it's amazing it does
happen
so this does allow for that flexibility
please
to to allow the prescriber to have some
options to opt out of it and because of
that we don't want to again delay the
patient getting treatment we don't want
the pharmacist in a position to try to
determine whether they have met the
exception or not so we exempt the farm
system trying to verify the use of an
exception
and take the honor of the person who's
doing the prescribing they use the
exception appropriately
so that's the intent of the laws is to
try to fill in the Gap around
CMS so it covers all providers
we did build in to the law into the bill
exceptions to deal with things that do
happen there's also a waiver requirement
so if a provider is a small provider in
office and does 50 prescriptions like a
pathologist radiologist they don't have
to comply they can get away from the
licensing board we did deal with the
issue of practice infusion software
vendors that abuse their
their privileges or their software
functionality
um not to the benefit of the patient but
to the benefit of themselves we also
built in there a way to monitor keep
prescribing through the data collection
with the prescription drug money program
to help the licensing boards identify
where they have to spend additional
resources whether it be educational or
whether it be Financial to help the
prescribers comply with e-prescribing
and that's the end of my testimony
thank you very much to and any members
of the committee have a question
well until others do I have a couple uh
your excuse me Mr chair we uh Gary uh
representative Woods I believe raised
his hand okay I will get to him in a
minute I didn't I I've been scrolling
back and forth but I'll get to him next
and uh my my two questions uh I'm going
to assume the amendment which says
veterinarians don't have to do it if
they can't do it and the board of
veterinary medicine shall make the
determination I assume you've had good
conversations representative Merchant
with the veterinarians I've had
conversations with the veterinarians and
I talked to Dr Crawford he was going to
bring it to the veterinarian board which
I believe is tomorrow so I have not
heard back from the veterinarian board I
think in general the veterans likely to
be excluded completely
um and I think that's a wise thing for
us to do and that's why the amendment
was written the way it was is for the
Vets themselves to determine when they
should have the availability of the
tools if you will to do the job I must
confess that I skimmed too fast because
I saw that the part that said until they
can but the last line says they decide
yes the board of veterinary medicine
shall decide yeah I miss that okay thank
you and then the second question and
again I think I know the answer but I'd
rather have you tell me and and that is
the information set from the pharmacies
to the feds it's simply a percentage of
how many electronic prescriptions versus
not per provider or does it get into a
little bit more detail about what those
scripts are for
no it does not get into details of why
the prescription is written it's only
the format of the prescription that's it
so nobody could guess that Dr so and so
prescribes such and such for a certain
patient
correct the intent is that in the
database
that to be a report going to the
respective board and say Dr Pearson
has an 85 percent electronic fill rate
or Dr Woods only has 25. it goes to the
respective board whether it be a Board
of Medicine the board of dentistry the
Board of Nursing to help them understand
where they may have to
um engage with the conversation try to
determine how to get the percentage up
or maybe the person needs a waiver and
offer the waiver to them thank you very
much representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
representative Merchant for taking my
question uh on page one line 21
um it's the references uh uh the the
board
um is is is that meant to be the
respective Board of a nurse practitioner
is prescribing that would be referred to
the nursing board if it's a physician
would be
um and I was just wondering I I we I
think back way back away from this you
first brought this out I think we
brought that up did that need to be
clarified as to what board that is
representative Woods um yes I remember
that conversation and I did not correct
it in the amendment I think it's the the
intent is it goes to the respective
licensing board but to add another word
in there saying to that effect I have no
issues whatsoever I think it just
clarifies the language in the bill
any other question
or representative Merchant from our
committee
I see none thank you very much
representative for presenting your bill
um the chair now calls
Paula minnehan who is testifying in
support
welcome back
thank you representative Pearson and
members of the committee can you hear me
very well great thank you good morning
um for the record I'm Paula minahan
Senior vice president for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
representing all our hospitals in the
state we are supportive of HB 143 and um
this is a very similar bill that was
passed out of your committee last year
which was House Bill 1332 but did not
make it over to the Senate due to the
covid-19 pandemic
I want to make clear to this committee
that the hospitals in New Hampshire are
supportive of requiring electronic
prescribing for controlled substances
and the reasons for moving to electronic
are compelling I have submitted
testimony so I won't read
all of our reasons but just to um
highlight enhance the safety and quality
of the prescribing process reduces
errors and supports clinical decision
making along with um reducing theft and
increased security and um I think
representative Merchant did a great job
outlining the rest of the bill we're
really focused on the e-prescribing
piece and in fact many hospitals have
already implemented electronic
prescribing for Controlled Substances
several others are in the midst of doing
so as representative Merchant mentioned
it is a requirement of the federal
government for Medicare in about a year
less than a year so they're in the midst
of implementing that so we um we are
totally supportive of that provision and
we um thank you for the opportunity to
testify in support of HB 143.
any questions from Miss minahan
I see none thank you for your testimony
thank you the chair now recognizes Jane
Barlow Roy from the New Hampshire
veterinarians and would we bring up
Miss Roy
I had to find her in the list here
there's about 34 people so if people can
raise their hands that would make it a
bit easier
there we go
all set
thank you
hi my name is Dr Jane Barlow Roy I am
the representative to the New Hampshire
Veterinary Medical Association I thank
you very much for letting me testify in
front of you guys today
um we are opposed to the bill as written
but we have been talking to
representative Merchant about the
amendment
um I will make my testimony short
because representative Merchant has kind
of brought up all of our
um issues with the bill as far as there
is no software available
um currently
um widespread in the veterinary
Community
um uh the top kind of I would say five
Veterinary softwares out there do not
have any sort of e-prescribing
capabilities Technologies however you
want to call it
um so we don't have the capabilities of
of implementing
um you know such such a bill
um so we are willing to you know keep
updated on when such a uh software will
become available
um I have talked to
um our software provider named avamark
they're one of the top software
Veterinary softwares out there and they
actually said that they have no desire
to actually create
um you know this this e-prescribing
software at the current moment
um they did not give me any timeline as
far as whether or not they will be
forced um you know on the federal level
to create something uh you know should
should it become more widespread
um but currently 13 other states do
exempt veterinarians
um I know that our language is and the
amendment was
modeled after uh in other states
um exemption but that's basically the
the juxt of my
um testimony today is is we do need some
sort of exemption um as veterinarians
because our software just does not exist
will the doctor take questions certainly
representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and and thank you Dr
Roy for taking my question
um I just want to be very clear uh have
you have you read the amendment that was
submitted and is it acceptable uh as as
it would apply to the veterinary
community
um I can't speak on behalf of the um
Amendment
um in regards to the board of veterinary
medicine
um I do not represent the board of
veterinary medicine I don't sit on the
board of veterinary medicine
um that is something that representative
Merchant has been speaking with um Dr
Crawford about
um and I know that they are meeting
tomorrow and they will speak to it
um we are very happy that the um you
know the amendment does include us with
the exemption
um but like I said any you know any
language that pertains to what goes on
after that and how it involves the board
of veterinary medicine
um I cannot speak to thank you and thank
you very much appreciate any other
questions
thank you doctor and thank you for
coming oh I do see a hand representative
Nelson
yes uh what happens with the 13 states
who said do exempt it how about all the
other states what do they do
um I'm I'm not aware of what the other
currently doing
we you know it are in New Hampshire
um you know with our prescribing things
um we do tend to make calls into
pharmacies as far as those prescribing
those
um and faxing and prescriptions
um the only times we really write a
written prescription
um in our practice at least is for those
scheduled
um controlled substances that require
um by DEA rules to have a written
prescription
um but to your question about
what the other states that don't accept
veterinarians I'm not sure what they do
and I apologize for that
thank you
seeing no further questions again doctor
thank you for your testimony thank you
the chair now calls Gina balkus who
signed up in support of this bill
and if you could wave your hand from my
studio technician
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
again thank you
good morning Mr chairman of members of
the committee I'm Gina balkus and I'm
the CEO of the Granite State home health
and hospice Association which Advocates
on behalf of Home Care hospice and
palliative care providers in New
Hampshire and the people they serve
House Bill 143 was reviewed by our
legislative committee and several
hospice medical directors in our
association and we support House Bill
143 as a way to enhance patient safety
and reduce the potential for drug
diversion however however we would ask
the committee to consider some
clarifications
first we believe House Bill 143 should
include an exception for electronic
prescribing of compounded medications
with Controlled Substances this is a
significant concern for hospices as
compounded medications are used
frequently in hospice care and generally
cannot be ordered via e-prescribed
platforms
and it's really not clear if line 17
through 19 of the bill would cover uh
that scenario
and while lines 27 through 30 would
still allow pharmacists to dispense
medications that are otherwise badly
validly written oral or faxed
a specific exception for compounded
medications would provide more clarity
in this bill
secondly we want to be sure that this
bill does not impact the timely
prescribing of controlled medications
for dying patients
it's not unusual for a hospice nurse
who's visiting a patient at home to
contact the hospice medical director
after hours when the physician might not
have access to their e-prescribed
platform
and this happens when a hospice has a
new patient admitted who's actively
dying or when a patient runs out of
medication unexpectedly due to a dosage
change or when there's a delay in
delivery from a mail order pharmacy
so I would suggest amending lines 11 to
and 12 to include the words or other
circumstances when the prescriber cannot
access electronic prescribing
another option would be to specifically
exempt hospice prescribers from uh the
statute that would be another option
so I I also just wanted to share that
the hospice medical directors who
reviewed House Bill 143 were surprised
by the sections in the bill that deal
with clinical decision support alerts in
e-prescribing programs none of them were
aware of any alerts that were designed
to increase prescriptions for controlled
medications
their experience was that e-prescribing
has no impact on doses or amounts of
medications prescribed in one physician
stated that the alerts generally Tamp
down prescription patterns rather than
seek to increase it
um you know I did hear representative
Merchant talk about the situation with
all scripts in Vermont
um the experience that our hospice
providers they are not experiencing that
type of situation
uh so I just wanted to share that with
the committee lastly I would recommend a
committee check the citation on lines 25
to 26.
I looked up this RSA RSA 318 B2 Romans 6
a
and
um
there
is not one it just goes to Romans six
and I wonder if the proper references
318 B1 not B2
um so I just urge the committee to to
check that
um it wasn't clear to me what that um it
says in circumstances where electronic
prescribing is not available
so I'm happy to work with the sponsor
and the committee on the language to
address our concerns you know most
importantly for us is the compounding
issue and the issue of access to the
platform uh after hours uh to an
e-prescribing platform after ours so um
those are my comments and I'm happy to
answer questions and thank you for the
opportunity to speak
any questions from the committee
there's a little button you can push to
representative Canucks
it waves at me
you see it may I
well yeah but it's more a clarification
for the person testifying because I've
been caught the same way I think that
and and because I thought representative
Merchant might be to this but that's
because 6A doesn't exist yet in statute
it was it gets created on page two lines
two to six though again I don't
understand the referencing but that's
where that appears to come in place I
just want to clarify that as best I can
for everybody if I have it correct it's
just not in statute yet it would be
created by this Bill thank you ah thank
you so much representative
wow
anyone else with or without yellow hand
up
representative gay thank you for putting
your own hand and the yellow hand up
both
now all you need to do is unmute and
you've got the trifecta thank you
thank you for taking my question
um so I'm all your points seem very
valid so I'm just hoping that the method
to add the write and add the Amendments
can be done
efficiently
in our current method of communication
representative gay um
in response to your comment like I said
I'm happy to work with representative
Merchant or members of the committee to
um
to discuss language
um that uh that might be uh that might
add clarity
and I will reach out to representative
Merchant directly after this uh hearing
well he's got another hearing and then
one after that but but I know what you
mean thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
Miss bocus and now the chair recognizes
Neil Kirk representative of many years
now in retirement representative Kirk
good morning Mr chairman can you hear me
I can
uh good morning to you sir and to
members of the committee for the record
I'm Neil Kirk I live in Ware and I'm
testifying as a member of the public
you back again
I opposed
um the this bill with respect to its
limitations on a patient's right to have
a paper prescription to a certain extent
um the purpose of the paper prescription
in uh the pdmp and a whole variety of
other legislation
is to is twofold first to allow the
patient to shop around for the best
price
when you have a paper prescription you
can take it to a pharmacy and find out
what they charge if you don't have a
paper prescription generally the
pharmacy will not give you the answer
because the the estimate because they
don't have enough information to do so
even if you have the exact information
to give them orally
also
um there are many people who buy their
prescriptions online and
um having a paper prescription allows
them to search out the best price there
whether it's in the United States or
abroad
uh the second reason for the paper
prescription has to do with privacy
um if you have a paper prescription it's
not in the prescription drug database
frankly I wonder whether it's in the
state's business to know where a person
buys his drugs whether it's the local
pharmacy or Walmart out of state or
online
and is it really the state's business to
know what kind of medication I'm buying
um an ED drug an HIV drug a cancer drug
all of these are controlled substances
and they're all covered by the pdmp
through electronic prescription
I'd remind folks that over 80 percent of
the voters supported the recent
constitutional informational privacy
Amendment and I really wonder whether
um
this bill and indeed existing law is
consistent with that amendment I hope
the committee will consider that issue
um here are the specific problems with
House Bill 143
first and I apologize Mr chairman I
can't cite page and line numbers because
my copy of the bill does not have them
but uh Roman 1 Pharmacists and
pharmacies probably lined three or four
on the bill or when the bills the text
of the amend Bill starts
um has an exception for paper
prescriptions with respect to controlled
drugs in other words
you can get a paper prescription except
for controlled drugs is defined in RSA
18b
1 Roman six
now
I'm not sure I understand that but I
think that refers to opioids and opioid
uh copies
if that's what it does I think that's
not bad that's reasonable we have an
opioid crisis and there is a legitimate
interest in the state to get that
information
but if it covers something beyond that
then I would ask you to consider
limiting it to the opioid type
prescriptions
um
secondly
Roman 2 3 a
couple of lines down probably on the
first page two
it says notwithstanding any provision of
law to the contrary which means
it ignores and overrides what we just
discussed on
um about a paper prescription
no person shall issue a prescription for
a controlled drug unless it's made by
electronic prescription
Etc
in this case controlled drug is not
defined not limited in the same way it
is in the 1B
and so I wonder if there's not a
conflict here
again if the words control drug in 3A
had the same limitation as defined in
RSA
318b16 then I think we would be avoiding
a conflict and still allowing paper
prescriptions for all controlled drugs
except opioids
um
I think regardless of what the
committee's decision is on the issues
that I'm raising I think it's very
important to deal with the consistency
issue I don't think in the same statute
we should use controlled drugs in
different manners unless that's
intentional
but the idea that in the same uh that
that the legislature giveth in section
one and taketh away in section two
strikes me as somewhat strange I don't
think that was intentional but I think
that's what's Happening Here
um
that completes my testimony Mr chairman
I'd be pleased to answer any questions
if the committee has them
anyone with a question for
representative Kirk
saying none thank you representative for
your testimony thank you Mr chairman
this exhausts my list as printed out at
about quarter of nine has anyone else
signed up that
um representative Acton can see on his
screen
I think that's it
that's it yeah
well then before we end the hearing
um what is your pleasure representative
Merchant
would you like us to move to exec this
right now or would you like to give it a
week and wait for the veterinarian board
to speak and perhaps you to speak with
um uh doctor whoever it was uh no uh
Gina balkus or others and come back with
an amendment if you wish and we can
execute next week what is your pleasure
I would prefer to work on an amendment I
need to address a couple of issues I
think are raised by this committee by
some of the people testifying before the
committee I'm looking at with the
doctors representative Woods about the
clarification on which board provides
the waiver I think it needs to be
addressed I think also I need to look at
the federal law and how it deals with
compounded medications if they do or do
not because in hospice a lot of is paid
for by the Medicare program so therefore
even though we may exempt it for
compounded medications if the Federal
Law requires it then we can't exempt the
federal law so I need to work with uh
Mrs falcus about that to get that
clarified and also wait for the
veterinarian board if the amendment is
approved by them so if it's okay with
the chair I'd like to hold this not
exact on it and work on an amendment to
work with the parties to make the
amendment work for everyone as much as
we possible that's our way here is to
make good things better so yes come back
I'd like to execute next week we have
until March 11 to get everything done so
we're going to be moving a little more
quickly but thank you so much and with
that I uh recognize representative Marsh
who just beat my gavel to the wooden
desk thank you everyone I just want to
be compliant with 91a and tell everyone
that I am here present and I'm at home
alone in Brookfield and there's nobody
in the room with me
with that we closed the hearing on House
Bill 143
and we
now open the hearing
on House Bill 572
relative to pharmacist administration of
vaccines and allowing a licensed
Advanced pharmacy technician to
administer vaccines and before I ask
representative Merchant to
bring forth his presentation on his bill
I'm going to ask my vice chair if he
would to
um text me and as we've been doing
the people who are signed up to testify
because I don't have that information
we're breaking in a new printer and it's
doing everything except printing so if
you would do just one thing that's all
all the lights and bells are great thank
you for that and representative Merchant
please present your bill
well thank you Mr chairman
um I'm still representative Merchant
from Claremont New Hampshire Sullivan
County District 4 and also I wanted to
recognize the committee and also the
public it may be listening in
today I bring to you is House Bill 572
and what we're trying to do with House
Bill 572 is two fundamental things one
is to align the vaccines that can be
given by a pharmacist and a pharmacy to
what the CDC guidelines
um have provided they're uh approved by
the FDA which is something we need to
add an amendment
the reason for it being is that as we
look at vaccinations we recognize as a
society that vaccines are cost effective
they're helpful in trying to prevent a
lot of disease and the cost of the
disease not just financially but the
cost of the patient for getting the
vaccine to prevent it in the first place
today 34 of proximated vaccines given in
the state of New Hampshire are given by
a pharmacist in a pharmacy which is a
tremendous stride in the direction of
trying to increase access to vaccines so
patients can get a vaccine at their
convenience in a location that's close
to their home
um but the challenge we're running into
in the pharmacy world
is also the question about
having Personnel that's been shown in
the in the covet situation enough
Personnel in the pharmacy to get the
vaccines and to do in such a way that it
can be done safely
they've been done cost effectively and
done in a timely manner
most of the reasons why patients go to a
pharmacy in the first place is because
of convenience they do it on their time
off we don't delay them they come in at
that point in time they have ready
access to it it doesn't require an
appointment
um vaccines have been shown to be
extremely safe
and effective and so forth so therefore
we're trying to just expand the vaccines
but not so much to expand it but to
align it with the CDC
guidelines for immunizations for adults
so if the CDC determines that another
vaccine should be given in the adult
profile we don't have to go back to the
state law to add it to the list it
automatically becomes part of it
the other part is on the licensed
technician we've seen also with covid
that personnel and having people trained
to give a vaccine comparable to what we
do in a medical office The Physician per
se does not give the vaccine but they're
the ones that have to be approving the
vaccine they did the ones that screen
the patient for it
Etc so just as a physician's office you
have a medical assistant that actually
administer the vaccines they can't
approve it but they can administer the
vaccine and I also work with
representative Woods initially we talked
about supervision and instead of having
just general supervision we had to be
sure that the pharmacist is on site and
the reason for that being is that if
something goes wrong they're the ones
trained to address the issue
um it's one of the things to give the
vaccine but if something heaven forbid
happens the person on site the
professional is the pharmacist to deal
with that situation
and fundamentally what we're trying to
do is make this as easy as possible for
patients to get vaccines
um and trying to minimize the barriers
either financially or time for them to
obtain it what's nice about today with
the Affordable Care Act most vaccines
are paid for there's no co-pays no
deductibles so the financial burden has
been lifted on most of the patients the
challenge now is getting the convenience
so that people can actually get to the
vaccines in their own time and their own
schedule
so the intent of this is to expand the
ability to give as many vaccines as we
possibly can in society in a location
it's very convenient at the same time
not delay the patient from getting the
therapy they need one of the things that
we talked about before when we had to
have a prescription for a patient the
delay
for the patient can be
sometimes a day or two trying to reach a
provider today in an office is very
difficult very challenging we see that
happening a lot of times with prior
approvals patients can weigh up to two
or three days for a medication before
the insurance company will pay for it so
we're trying to again minimize that
inconvenience that is created by going
through a another safety check if you
will when probably it's not required at
all
so looking at it that way this again
goes back to my original comment we need
to find a way to align the CDC
guidelines
for adult immunizations and number two
we need to try to make it as convenient
as possible for the patient and allow
for personnel to administer the vaccine
in a way that helps the patient obtain
it Timely
easily and conveniently and this is
really what the goal of the whole bill
is to allow for licensed technicians we
two years ago approved for them to be
licensed they're not somebody that's a
they go through two thousand hours with
the training courses and so forth so
it's Personnel that are highly trained
as technicians to uh to do work and
we're just adding another task or
function to that functionality in Esco
for practice
with that I'll take questions
questions
I have one I think I know again I think
I know the answer to it but I'd like to
hear it from you if one of my medical
assistants gives an injection to a
patient
and something goes seriously wrong there
is a physician or occasionally just a
nurse practitioner on site that can step
in with whatever went wrong would you
consider a pharmacist to be the
equivalent level of backup
it they're trained to deal with those
situations as part of the training they
go through it's a 20 20 hour program on
top of what they do through school
itself so yes it's not so much their
equivalent in their training and what
they're doing diagnostically but they're
trained to deal with the issue that may
arise
um how to use an EpiPen how to help the
patient out
um so yes in that capacity they're equal
but I don't want to confuse people in
thinking that a pharmacist is training
like a physician because they're not but
they are trying to deal with the
situation that may arise within the
pharmacy
thank you representative
Ashwin
thank you Mr chairman
um representative I'm just wondering
does the on-site I see that you you said
that sorry you said that
um having the on-site
um word added to the bill creates more
oversight but I you strike out the word
Direct
so can you just speak to that a little
bit because I'm a little confused the
word direct is the same with a
inside of a physician's office the
medical assistant doesn't have direct
supervision by the provider the provider
could be in the area so the medical
assistance is giving the vaccine if you
will in a room but the provider may not
be in the room to provide direct but
they are on site so that was one of the
concerns we had before is to ensure that
in fact the LPN I mean the lapt
cannot work independent if you will from
the pharmacist they have to be there
physically to deal with the issues that
could could arise
okay thank you and follow-up follow-up
um does the notification piece
um that you hadn't struck out
um does that require
the PCP to be notified and respond
um respond to that notification prior to
the administration of the vaccine
no it's the
allow for the PCP a lot of times just to
be clear about this in the world of
Pharmacy Many Many I mean many patients
don't have a PCB there are a lot of
patients out there that don't have a
primary care doc
um
so therefore that's one of the issues
run into but the goal here was to get
the information back into the medical
record of the primary care doctor the
doc or the provider overseeing them so
what we basically at that point in time
want to be sure we have as much as
possible a comprehensive record with the
provider so if a pharmacist does get the
vaccine it's given by them that that is
reported back to the primary care
physician so it could be part of the
medical record of the patient
can I have one more follow-up oh one
more
um
I I just I see that that line is struck
in your bill for the covid-19 vaccine so
they it doesn't require notification
that was the reason that's why it was
there first I'm sorry about that
representative Cushman what we now have
as a registry and I'll speak that as
well the communication back to the
provider if we have the registry in
place the provider can have access to
the medication or to the vaccine and the
information there well we did do within
the law if you look at the line as
required by state law so if the law does
not require the pharmacist to put it in
the registry if the patient wants to opt
out or opt-in that's another discussion
it depends upon what the law requires
the pharmacist will then have to comply
with what the law is
but we're trying to look for a
communication tool between the
pharmacist and the provider before the
register we had no other way to do that
we only could do it verbally or through
a fax to get it back to the provider
because there's no other communication
tool by using the registry there is a
communication tool between the provider
and the pharmacist
however if the patient opts out then
it's up to the patient to notify the
provider that they want it in their
record
representative soloway you had your own
hand up
uh thank you Mr chairman uh and thank
you representative for taking my
question so this the data on
immunization does get into the registry
what about unanticipated uh Adverse
Events
that that would be
um if they had an event I would expect
the pharmacist is not required to make a
communication back to the primary care
physician if they have one to notify
them of a situation that may have
occurred
um it's back to the healthcare team in
which the pharmacist is a part of is
somehow getting it back to the provider
if it was and actually a adverse effect
the bill does not address it represent a
solid it doesn't require the pharmacist
to give it back but it they wanted to
add that in there if the person had an
adverse event I mean we could do that
but I'm not it's not there
uh thank you for taking my question
representative Woods
uh thank you Mr chair I just I would
like to offer a little bit of perhaps
further clarification about striking the
direct that was something we had a
discussion about and uh direct means uh
uh in the past has been by telephone so
that a pharmacist potentially uh could
be the mentor directly to being absurd
50 pharmacies
um and have no direct contact
when I chaired the state workers comp
commission uh we discovered that case
workers were doing it directly but they
again telephonically and somewhere in
California being case managers
um so my my goal was to sort of avoid
the individuals uh monitoring uh just by
telephone many sites which is not what
we wanted and changed it to on-site so
that there would be direct
supervisory interaction
if I may Mr chairman that was one of the
things that was discussed too is we
didn't want to have direct done remotely
uh with a camera so it does provide
direct sight because you can visually
see somebody but you're not physically
on site which is what representative
wood was concerned about as well as
myself
foreign
representative gay
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um I may not have understood exactly
what uh y'all are talking about but the
Adverse Events the veres I don't know
what the status of theirs in New
Hampshire is but certainly if we're
going to be doing recording uh optional
or not whatever is legal uh if we're
gonna do recording of immunizations I've
I think the any kind of adverse
reactions needs to be in there but it
doesn't sound like there's any field in
this uh system that allows for that much
less requires it
that was really a question
I'm not an immunizing pharmacist I have
to go back and look at that
representative gay my understanding is
that if you do have a reaction to a
vaccine
from the peers I've talked to there is a
requirement to notify the um there's a
form to fill out to
um complete that notify within registry
not somewhere to the state but the
federal registry with what's going on
with the vaccine but it's not a
requirement
um built into the law I'd have to go
back and look at that and find out if
it's actually required as part of given
the vaccine That vaccine
reactions are somehow recorded in some
other database which I'm not aware of
yes representative gay yes well the
system that you're talking about
recording uh are you just talking about
the system that we're considering
whether to make it
happen or not
it sounds like you're counting on using
some kind of system so that the PCP can
be notified without you having to send a
fax no
um since the level said we don't require
today
um so
I just wanted to be clear that we've
been given vaccines in the pharmacy
Community for quite a long time and 34
of them were given the Community
Pharmacy so whatever is being done today
we're not trying to change we're trying
to basically leave it alone it doesn't
it seems to be working the communication
back to the provider is the critical
part to it
um I do know if you have an adverse drug
reaction that there is a requirement to
report that to the FDA so the FDA can
monitor certain things but to your point
it doesn't go back per se to the
provider themselves
thank you yeah it doesn't go into
registry either Registries only to
record the actual vaccination not
recording adverse effects that they may
occur within the vaccination that's not
part of the registry
okay thank you I have two more on my
list representative Marsh
a yes thank you Mr chair and I I wanted
to discuss a little bit more the vaccine
registry and the requirement to notify
practitioners about vaccinations
um given that the the vaccine registry
whether we make it opt-in or opt out we
have another bill about that uh the
people there will still be some people
who are going to opt out of it whichever
way it goes uh given that that system is
not yet functional don't you think it
might be a good idea to continue to
require that pcps when they're known be
notified about vaccinations that are
given
I think until the registry is up and
fully functional that could be a logical
thing to do I think we want to be sure
that the PCP
um is aware of what's going on the
vaccines what we're trying to avoid in
that is two things I believe one is
notifications of the BCP so they're
aware of it but number two is not to
have both providers giving a vaccine
when they don't require the patient to
do that I've been in my situation before
in a in a hospital where we had a
patient get a pneumococcal vaccine a
long-term care facility because of their
requirements with CMS they go to the
hospital for a cute situation they got
another pneumococcal vaccine they get
discharged to a third facility
and they get another pneumococcal
vaccine so I think communication is key
to it representative Marsh and until
that registry is up and running I would
say yes it makes logical sense to
maintain some sort of
communication tool back to the primary
care provider until the registry is
fully functional
and I'd be not opposed to it and not uh
not least but at this moment last
representative Weber
thank you so much I'm really sorry for
some reason my little yellow hand is not
yellow and it turns out to be exactly
the same color as the paint in the room
that I'm sitting I like the hand you
raised
um but I I have made other arrangements
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um I am hearing Mrs Casey my fourth and
sixth grade third and fifth grade
teachers
um voice in my ear as I read this and uh
if you look on line six and seven of the
bill is drafted
um it says May
May administer vaccines is approved by
an immunizing pharmacist and which have
been approved by the sender for Disease
Control but I think the words which have
been approved by the Centers for Disease
Control
ought to follow the word vaccine
and then there ought to be a comma and
as approved by an immunizing pharmacist
because uh those words relate to the
vaccine they do not relate to the
pharmacist and I would just suggest if
there is a um yes if there is a
an amendment that that might be put in
as a as a as a thought
absolute Weber thank you for that um I
totally agree with what you're saying I
also in the amendment inserted the fact
that which is not coming the one before
he doesn't include it but the one that's
coming is going to use this on boards in
the same language that you're
referencing but it did include the
language that the vaccine also had to be
approved by the FDA not just by the CDC
so that's going to be included in the
amendment but I will definitely go back
and work on the language and if you be
so kind for me to send it to you to
review it before I submit it I would
appreciate that
my editor of my second and third book
would like to meet your third and fifth
grade teacher representative Weber I
didn't know that until I started writing
as an adult and you were well educated
thank you representative Cushman
yeah Leah unmute
yeah
thank you
um thank you Mr chairman
um thank you representative Merchant I
am wondering does this bill so if we are
and I'm glad that you said that you
would you have an amendment coming
forward to include FDA approval
um this opens it up to pharmacists being
able to give a lot more vaccines than
they are currently able to give under
statute
um there are I counted last night 89 FDA
approved vaccines many
um are competing
um
with competing manufacturers for the
same disease and
um I just see this changing the dynamic
on how pharmacists decide to recommend
vaccines and I see an opportunity for
um
you know we see some whining and dining
of Physicians to prescribe certain
medications by pharmaceutical reps and
you know even when those are not the
first line treatment or you know the
best option for a patient as evidence by
the literature
The Physician is has chosen those based
on their incentives given to them by a
pharmaceutical representative
so my question is
um
should we really be opening this up for
a pharmacist to
um you know it could become a an
opportunity to sell as many vaccines as
possible for any disease Under the Sun
including ones that are not typically
recommended
um like the BCG the live BCG which is
the tuberculosis vaccine and um the
anthrax vaccine those have high rates of
adverse reactions
and I I'm I'm not sure do Farms if
pharmacists take a oath to do no harm
but I just see some problems opening
that up would you be okay with
um an amendment to keep it limited to
the current vaccines that are
administered by pharmacists influenza
hepatitis A Hepatitis B Tdap MMR
meningococcal
and covid-19 pneumococcal
and herpes zoster
I want to say thank you for the question
um what the amendment does because I did
make an error and I when drafting it and
it included all vaccines and it was
never the intent so the amendment
clarifies that to only the vaccines that
are on the CDC schedule for adult
vaccinations which includes 10 vaccines
um So within those 10 vaccines basically
eight of them today a pharmacist can
give or adding the other two to a line
of completely with the CDC guidelines
um as far as looking at the vaccines and
which ones most pharmacists today work
in Corporate America so the decision
upon which vaccine is being purchased if
you will is not done locally by the
pharmacist done by Corporate America
so
that's kind of I hear the concern but I
would say the concern for the most part
doesn't really exist at the pharmacist
level because they're not the ones
deciding upon which vaccine which brand
of a vaccine to utilize is done by their
uh the corporate America that they work
for
representative gay
thank you so much for taking my question
I'm sorry I didn't know it before
um VI record the vaccination in the
state vaccine registry
since that is going to be an option if
people so choose the rest of VI says uh
to me the whole thing maintain a record
of administration of vaccinations for
each individual as required by state and
federal law
would that be acceptable to you to
remove that record the vaccination the
state vaccine registry and just use the
rest of the sentence
represent gay can you say that again
which which line do you want ma'am VI
yeah the first words are record the
vaccination in the state vaccine
registry and find 26.
yes sorry line 26. because that's a
choice of the person who's receiving the
vaccine
and right now it doesn't even exist
but the rest of the sentence says it it
says you maintain a record
as required by state and federal law so
to me that would cover it without
yeah I'm not mandatory it's okay I'm not
a post taking out the word record the
vaccination in the state registry
because at the end of the sentence it
does say as required by state and
federal law so if the state and federal
law do not require it then Essence that
takes precedent over the earlier part so
but to pull it out completely I have no
objection to that I just think that
um it helps to clarify it so that the
person only puts it in there if it's
an opt-in opt-out situation which is a
different Bill I just want to be sure
that we don't have language in one bill
that conflicts with language and another
bill so I'm trying to write in such a
way that
when you look at the state law whatever
the state law is is what you have to
comply with so if it's an opt-in they do
that if it's an opt out they do that
representative gay do you want to follow
up yes so
um
this is that acceptable to you to take
that out to take the record the
vaccination the state vaccine registry
remove it it would make me a lot happier
because that comes across as we're going
to do it and you've got to really
you've got to make quite an effort to
make sure it doesn't get recorded if
that's so what you so choose
I'm not opposed to taking it out but I
do concern myself is that down the road
the Law changes something else I just
want to be sure that whatever the law is
there which we can leave in there is
what we comply with so if you want to
take it out the beginning of it say
maintain a record
um the question is what's the record
because there's no reference to what
that record is if we don't have a
registry when you talk about maintain a
record for an Administration where is
that record going
um but back to the same thing with
representative marks and we could go
back to the paper system and say you
have to submit it to a provider
um a PCB whether you have one or not
that's been
difficult for us in the past because
many times as pharmacists we provide
information back to the provider's
office but it doesn't get into the chart
because the staff at the office doesn't
always put it in the chart so I'm trying
to be sure whatever vehicle we have for
communication is going to be workable
timely so that all the parties are aware
of what's going on in the vaccine world
and that's my concern is that if we
don't put something in there about the
registry then
what are you gonna what are we going to
use for um recording the vaccine
what's the record I'm not opposed to it
I'm just not sure what the alternative
is
thank you uh representative Weber you
had your hand up
and your mic that was using that was
user malfunction I'm sorry
test them all out we got to do that
periodically
representative Cushman
thank you again for taking my question
Mr chairman
um representative Merchant um
I am just wondering what are those eight
vaccines that you were saying so in
addition to the ones that are in statute
currently
um can you can you send me those those
eight
and tell me which well I mean I can
figure out which ones are not last night
I sent out to the committee if you look
on the CDC guidelines on the links to it
um if you look at the vaccines that are
on the CDC
I can pull it up to the screen but
there's one two three four
five six seven eight
all right eight nine
ten there's ten of them that we
currently are allowed to to administer
and there's two additional ones and the
two are
um HPV
um and the other one's Thermopolis
those are the only two I only two
vaccines that are on the CDC adult
immunization schedule
that are not currently Allowed by law
for the pharmacist who administer
may I have a follow-up follow up
um so the HPV vaccine that's one that's
also got a high rate of adverse
reactions
um and I think that these are in statute
specifically named for a reason we don't
want to give you know broad open this up
broadly to anything that the CDC decides
is is added and I think we want to keep
the control within the state on on what
we can have our our pharmacists give
um so would you be okay with an
amendment
um uh if I if I would you look at an
amendment to just keep it with what we
have in statute currently
I would look at an amendment but I think
again the same thing what we're running
into now with cobit which is showing us
whenever there's another vaccine that
the CDC wants to be able to be provided
by a pharmacist in a pharmacy Community
then we have to go back to the stature
through emergency order to add it and my
concern is that by doing it that way the
ability for us as a state to react to
something in a relatively
timely manner is diminished
thank you the chair recognizes uh me who
has his hand up
um
part-time CEO of a
massage and Counseling and Family
Practice Facility with three pcps and
we have as most primary care offices our
patient visits skew very much to the
older we don't see the youngins very
often we see the old ones quite
regularly and they have at least as bad
a memory as I do which is not very good
and I'm sure there are occurrences where
they don't remember that their PCP gave
them something three months ago and here
they are in the pharmacy and it sounds
like it'd be a good idea and they're
with somebody and said Nana did you get
your shot and she says I don't think so
and um wouldn't it be advantageous
before the pharmacy gives the shots not
because they're not capable of it but
the person before them may have already
had one and doesn't need one uh wouldn't
that be a good idea is to call the PCP
first not later
um Mr chairman
um you spoke very eloquently to why we
should opt in not opt out of the
registry
um I couldn't have asked for a better
introduction to that
um I think part of it is communication I
think that's one of the reasons why
other states in the country have a
registry to avoid that because even
myself as a patient I don't always keep
track of my vaccines but if it's in the
registry as a record and therefore
everyone has access to it then at that
point in time the provider can go to the
registry and say oh Mrs Smith you've
already had your pneumococcal vaccine
you do not need to have it again you had
it two or three months ago or even a
year ago two years ago so to answer your
question I think it's back to the
communication tool that we all use and
therefore the registry becomes the
vehicle that we can all
utilize
independent of each other so therefore I
would say that
yeah that's definitely a situation but
don't forget also I I don't know about
you folks but
um most people today I know my father
goes to probably three or four or five
different doctors so the world of having
a primary care doc per se he has a
um pulmonologist he has a cardiologist
he has a rheumatologist
um
any sort of jokes about it he says you
know go back to the old days when I had
Dr Welby MD and I had one physician they
made my locker my life a lot easier
um you know the communication so I hear
what you're saying Sherman
yeah he wasn't trying to be eloquent I
was just trying to make more work for my
staff but uh thank you for connecting
the dots
anybody else with a question from the
committee
in which case thank you and thank you
for being our our committee now
appreciate that very much we've got a
couple of people that I've been informed
uh wish to speak and uh they wish to
testify they um
they include care yes sorry
representative Nelson has his hand up
representative Nelson thank you so much
representative
thank you to both of you
um could all the people have all these
suggestions for amendments could they
please directly send them to the author
of the of the bill
because I can't keep track of them all
the suggestions they have to fix this or
that
spoken as the clerk should speak yes
they should go to the primary sponsor
who coordinates all of that and uh
anybody can make an amendment anybody
can come in with a hostile Amendment but
it would be much better I think and who
we are if everybody with an
encouragement a suggestion or even
something a bit negative would get two
representative Merchants so we could
have uh one Amendment and if that
doesn't satisfy an individual we will
entertain that individual's Contra
Amendment as well but thank you
uh Laura Condon please
is invited
good morning good morning okay good that
means you can hear me
um
morning Mr chairman
um an honorable committee members my
name is Laura Condon I'm from Bedford
and I'm a volunteer New Hampshire
director of advocacy with the national
vaccine information center and I testify
today in opposition of House Bill 572
for three particular reasons
um but before I get to my three reasons
I would like to add some information to
prior testimony number one the the
adverse effect reporting
um from adverse effects of vaccination
is required by federal law that
providers of vaccination do submit
vaccine adverse offense to the vaccine
adverse event Reporting System there was
questioned whether that would be
required a pharmacist
um my understanding I'd have to double
check federal law that it requires
providers of vaccines and I assume that
would include pharmacists so I do
believe that is a requirement
it'd be great if that was highlighted in
the bill there was also mentioned that
um it is difficulty for
um providers to keep a record of
vaccines and you know how is a
pharmacist going to keep that current
Law requires that doctors provide keep a
record of vaccination given to their
patients I'm not sure if that law
required makes the same requirement on
pharmacists but it certainly does on
Physicians
um and it also requires that those
individuals being vaccinated be given
about a record of their vaccination at
the time of vaccination so those things
are currently required under current law
by doctors I'm not sure if that extends
to pharmacists I'd have to check that
so just wanted to mention those my
objections to the bill are number one
is that influenza vaccines should be
limited to adults in this law it allows
for intellect vaccines to be given to
the general public which of course would
include infants as young as six months
of age this trivializes the very real
vaccine risks and serious reactions by
giving flu shots to infants and children
and the corner drugstore or grocery
store pharmacy most pharmacies and
grocery stores don't have life-saving
defibrillators will pharmacists have the
equipment and training to be able to
tell the difference between Cardiac
Arrest anaphylaxis fainting and act
accordingly to save the lives of babies
and children who react at the time of
vaccination
also this bill undermines the need for a
medical home for a child pharmacists
don't have the necessary medical history
of an infant or child or the time to
pre-screen for contraindication based on
the child's personal and family history
and unique Health needs prior to
vaccination
children today may get as many as 70
doses of vaccines for 16 different
diseases many vaccines now come in
cocktail shots containing up to five
different vaccines in one shot it is
difficult for parents to remember if the
flu shot was one of them this is why
they need a medical home to keep a
patient history and vaccine schedules
including the flu shot when appropriate
foreign
vaccination rates have been reported by
Beth Daly of DHHS as being up to 70
percent for children in New Hampshire so
certainly there's no problem with access
to flu shots for children
my second objection to the bill is that
vaccines given in a pharmacy should be
limited to vaccines for which actual FDA
license has been given and for those
individuals For Whom the CDC has
recommended vaccines according to the
details of the cdc's ever-changing
recommended adult vaccine schedule
a pharmacy is not the place to be giving
experimental vaccines like the coveted
shots for which there is only FDA
emergency use authorization given and
not FDA license
and my third and final objection to this
bill has been mentioned here is it and
and I think maybe there's a resolution
to it that it cannot be required that a
pharmacist
um enter a customer's information into
the state vaccine registry because that
is a voluntary program and it is the
customer in the pharmacy who can who's
the controlling person whether that
would get entered or not so I appreciate
recognition of that concern and for
these reasons I oppose this bill is
written thank you very much for your
time
will will you take questions I certainly
may I have one I'm a little confused
about your point number one because as I
am reading the bill uh it says on line
four immunos immunizing pharmacist and
it has some helpers up there previously
may administer influenza vaccines to the
general public lots of lots and lots of
line seven to individuals 18 years of
age and older
so I think that obviates your 0.1 unless
I'm reading it wrong
actually and I I believe that what it's
doing is it's doing a carve out here
that the the reason that the influenza
vaccines are mentioned separately is
because that would be for the general
public at any age but all other vaccines
would be limited to those age 18 and
older
and I'm sure that representative
Merchant can correct me if I
misunderstand that well I'm really
looking for representative Weber's third
and fifth grade teacher here because it
is a linguistic thing and we can't bring
up the build sponsor to answer at this
point but we can bring up anybody else
who's learned to read on the committee
so am I correct or am I misreading it
that lines three to seven limit
flu vaccines to those 18 years and older
am I correct representative Cushman
the way that I read it
um is the way that Laura Conan reads it
I see that that is for the general
public for the influenza vaccine and
then the 18 years or older applies to
all the other vaccines approved by the
CDC as written in the bill well I can't
call Representative Merchant back up but
what I will do is ask him to make the
wording a little clearer so we know
exactly what you mean and I'm quite
happy to be proven wrong but you've got
to prove it and I'm sure representative
uh oh I didn't promote you uh Miss uh
Condon Miss Condon
um you've done a lot of work in this so
if representative Merchant could clarify
that linguistic question for me at least
anyone else wish to address Laura Condon
thank you
representative Cushman
um thank you Mr chairman
um Miss Condon do you see
um any issue with opening it up to the
the vaccines that are on the adult
um CDC schedule
in addition to the ones that are
explicitly mentioned in the statute
currently
yeah I appreciate that question it gives
me an opportunity to clarify further as
I do know that um it has been stated by
the sponsor is that pharmacists can
currently give I think eight or ten
different vaccines but in fact the law
specifically limits it to influenza
pneumococcal and varicella zoster so
which is which is only three which is
which is what is listed in the law now
and that's being you know crossed out in
this bill and then expanding it to all
vaccines recommended for adults
um you know as long as it's age 18 and
over you know represent Cushman you know
I mean I think it's buyer beware you
know it's up to the consumer to do their
adult you know their diligence I mean
these are adults
um this is an access issue to vaccines
um and you know I I wouldn't curtail
that personally I wouldn't curtail that
access
may I have a follow-up one follow-up
thank you Miss Condon
um and I I'm just I'm gonna point you to
the uh line in the bill it's section two
where it says repeal RSA 318 16d
um that one actually does it's in a
separate section but it's like a repeat
of this section for the specifically
hepatitis A B MMR
um
and a couple of other vaccines so they
are just to let you know that they are
in the statute
um currently so there are eight
sorry that's not a question uh well you
got to learn the Art of Faking us out by
saying wouldn't you believe or haven't
you seen or do you know the little guy
who told me I point you to
that's you're getting it yes you may
thank you
anyone else well thank you thank you
again you're one of our go-to people
here on these matters
now the chair recognizes Holly Stevens
good morning Mr chairman um and members
of the committee
my name is Holly Stevens I'm the health
policy coordinator at new Futures new
Futures is a nonpartisan non-profit
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates to improve the health and
wellness of all New Hampshire residents
in this role we work extensively with
policy makers Health Care Providers and
families to increase access to quality
affordable health care including access
to important vaccines throughout the
granite state Futures appreciates the
opportunity to testify on House Bill
572.
this bill not only expands on pharmacies
staff allowed to administer vaccines but
it expands on the types of vaccines they
are able to provide to the public
this bill would expand that capacity to
all CDC approved vaccines for adults and
the covid-19 vaccine for children and
adults when it is readily available
while new Futures certainly supports
increased access to vaccines for all
Granite Staters to do so while not
knowing how affordable that access would
be is problematic
while understanding that this testimony
is on House Bill 572 it would be remiss
not to mention the intersection of this
bill with House Bill 604 and house bill
221.
the intent of House Bill 604 is to
increase access to vaccines while
reducing costs to the overall health
care System
the pharmacies have resisted being
involved in the proposed expansion of
the state's vaccine program to include
adults however they are asking you to
expand the scope of their vaccine
practice
additionally having pedia pediatric
covid-19 vaccines administered through
the pharmacies could undermine the
successful and well-functioning
children's vaccine program that has
existed for nearly nearly two decades
additionally this bill removes the
requirement as has been mentioned
earlier for pharmacies to notify a
patient's primary care physician about
vaccines given relying solely on the
pharmacists entering the information
into the state's vaccine registry
and while I do believe
um some sort of a fix has been discussed
here my testimony was drafted is in
consideration of the bill as uh as
introduced
but House Bill 572
um in its existing form would need House
Bill 221 to be found in expedient to
legislate for it to function in a way
uh that the patient receives continuity
of his or her health care and not um
only that um but in listening to the
testimony here today as well
um even if the registry was an opt-out
alternative
those who are who decide to opt out of
the registry because they don't want
their uh information maintained in a
public registry held at the state they
still may want their doctor to know and
I I don't know that it's good enough to
just say well then it's on the the
shoulder of that uh patient to let the
uh their provider to know as
representative Merchant
um discussed not all individuals have
primary care physicians and for those
who currently don't have one
um end up getting a number of vaccines
at the pharmacy and then two years later
obtain a primary care physician they may
not remember what vaccines they received
at the pharmacy so
um
okay
and um
also they may not remember even two
weeks later when they have an
appointment with the primary care
provider if they have one to let that
provider know that they receive vaccines
it may not be high on their priority
list if they're dealing with other
medical concerns
um so until the overall impact of this
legislation is known given its
intersection with other bills that the
house is currently considering new
Futures takes no position on this bill
at this time instead new Futures simply
urges the committee to fully assess the
ramifications of House Bill 572
especially in conjunction with House
Bill 604 in House Bill 221 before
proceeding forward with the bill
this assessment should include any
potential impact to the overall cost of
to the Health Care system and I didn't
mention this in my written testimony but
inequality issues too I'm there were a
number of quality issues that have come
to surface
um during the discussion on this bill
and
I just want to Echo some of those
concerns the concerns mainly with the
providers being informed of the vaccines
um and you know how pharmacies are going
to deal with the covid-19 vaccine with
uh with children
um
and with adults currently adults have to
sit somewhere for 15 minutes after
receiving That vaccine as they look for
any signs of an adverse or allergic
reaction
our Pharmacy is going to do this are
they going to have us a place to park
children and adults
um
requiring them to sit there for 15
minutes
um and make sure that they do
um and or have them sign a release that
if they have an adverse reaction and
they leave it's on them it's not on the
pharmacy so with that I will take any
questions if there are any
um and uh allow you guys to do the
wonderful work that you do
any questions
getting ready
with that I close the hearing on 572
we're going to take a break in about 30
seconds before we go please everybody
with some input uh desired changes
suggestions talk to representative
Merchants
um
and uh I might suggest and it's only a
suggestion that a bill of this number of
lines which is to me a small bill
um 30 on one page one on the other
um by the time you cut and paste an
amendment should go here and an
amendment should go there allow me to
suggest that you write an amendment that
starts off roughly with the words after
the enacting Clause replace the whole
darn thing with the following I mean you
wouldn't say that exactly but that's
what it would want to say so that way we
look at a clean copy we look at the bill
as you have worked through what you wish
to take from the suggestions of various
people rather than having to draw arrows
and scissors and paste and so on
thank you for that advice Mr chairman
well something I learned the hard way
like most things
anyway let's
say let's break folks
then with
representative Merchant and another bill
foreign
everything
okay
before
chairman
Mr chairman
apparently not okay
um
I I just wanted to note for your
information that as I look out the
window the ice here is beginning to
build up fairly alarmingly so if I
vanish I will do my very best to find a
different way back to the meeting but
um
it it just looks like branches are
beginning to be weighed down a bit so I
wanted to let you know thank you you're
in Concord you're in Concord no I'm in
Walpole okay
all right
yes Walpole has not yet had any flutters
of the electricity knock wood uh but
Concord has so well I I looked in the uh
weather seven-day weather forecast
hoping that we might have a snowstorm
next Tuesday but unfortunately it's snow
on Monday and we meet next week on
Tuesday so yeah
and Lucy one time I I did actually use
the cell phone
um it's you know it's not optimal but
that's that's also going to be my backup
if the power goes out although we've got
a generator so I should be okay but the
cell phone is not fun but Bill can
attest to that one but
yeah I have the um I have a generator
and I have an iPad
well I've I have a generator but that
doesn't help me a bit if the cable goes
down or do I have the cables down you're
screwed
then you're good yeah
yeah I set up my phone so I can have the
app on my phone if I need to like Jerry
suggested so I won't get stuck like I
did last time
and I am hoping no darn it I didn't
manage to change the color of the hand
so
I like we'll see that when the hand is
raised the person raising the hand if
you're using gallery view goes to the
upper left hand corner and they show up
in the order in which they have raised
them so
I I have found that to be useful in
other meetings I wanted to make my
raised hand look purple because then
everybody would see me first uh it's
been
boom
okay we are
whoops we're not
um
wait a minute here
and it's that time so
the hearing on House Bill 479 relative
to pharmacist provider status and
nicotine cessation therapy
and that will be introduced by
representative
Merchant
I hope
representative Merchant was rebooting
his computer so it looks like he's just
reattached him there he is
479 representative rebooted merchants
thank you Mr chairman
also
the members of the committee for the
record my name is Gary Merchant
representative Gary Merchant from
Sullivan County District for Claremont
Ward 2. I'm here today to present House
Bill 479 house bills 479 has two
components to it one is reimbursement
through Medicaid and the other one is an
expansion of
scope or practice to allow pharmacists
to provide nicotine cessation therapy
let's talk about the first one health
care provider status and why that's
important
C Ms will only reimburse the state for
services provided by a recognized health
care provider and has to be done in
statute So currently when a pharmacist
provides services that are not related
to the dispensing functionality
such as smoking sensation or other
things they may have within the scope of
practice they cannot build Medicaid and
the reason why they can't build Medicaid
is Medicaid can't go to the CMS at the
federal level and seek reimbursement
which is normally about 50 of the cost
so what this bill fundamentally does is
recognize pharmacists as health care
providers which therefore allows
Medicaid the state plan to
secretly reimbursement from the federal
government on the provision of what's
provided by the pharmacists within the
scope of practice so it's a simple fix
that basically allow for that to occur
and for the state itself to get at least
50 percent of it back from the federal
government
the other one is about smoking sensation
which is really kind of a an important
part
if you look at the U.S
Surgeon General the report in 2020. one
of the things that was brought out by
the report is we know tobacco smoking
is a major contributor to health care
cost because of all the disease and so
forth related to it
what we're trying to do which is what
the report stated was to make it as
broadly available to patients
to have access to products that would
help the patient
to quit smoking
there's numerous studies that show that
it takes multiple times sometimes for
that to occur but the primary reason is
the patient has to decide when they want
to quit and trying to take advantage of
that by allowing the patient to have
access easy access timely access
to a therapy will help immensely in
compliance with the patient to make the
decision to take themselves off from
tobacco products
so the 10 here is twofold one is to
increase the reimbursement through the
Medicaid system for the services
provided and number two to Simply allow
pharmacists to provide smoking sensation
therapy nicotine replacement
based upon
schedule of the patient versus
otherwise so
we know that access is a primary issue
timely access is important and all this
does is fundamentally allow the
pharmacist to provide that access point
for the patient to pick up
nicotine replacement therapy at their
discretion when they feel comfortable to
do it number two when you look at the
number of times a pharmacist interacts
with a patient
Studies have shown that most patients
they go in Medicare visit a pharmacy
twice as often as a primary care so
they're an ideal situation
to identify patients or look and help
through a conversation with the patient
to encourage them to actually take and
stop smoking but again it's one thing to
say to stop smoking but to be able to
give them a product that will actually
help them quit the nicotine Cravings
that the body incurs when you're onto a
nicotine product like tobacco so that's
the intent of the bill it's
fundamentally to allow for reimbursement
into allow pharmacists to have the
ability to help patients in their quest
to stop smoking
thanks
it's all opened up for questions
representative Nutter Upham well thank
you for taking my question
um I know some people take shantex if I
pronounce that correctly to stop smoking
would a pharmacist be able to distribute
that or prescribe that
if it's approved by the FDA for that
reason yes they would so the law only
allows the pharmacist to provide to a
patient products approved by the FDA
which have an indication for smoking
sensation so if the product does not
have that indication by the
VA the pharmacist would not be able to
provide it okay thank you thank you
representative snow please unmute and
ask your question
representative snow you're still on mute
we can't hear you
my unbuted now you're good you're good
now okay should I sorry about that you
start over you can start all right I'll
start all over thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Merchant for
taking my question
I just need to be assured that what's on
page one lines three
through six which basically gives carte
blanche the pharmacists to perform any
services that are provided by positions
or uh business or ar andps and yet they
don't mention any specific services at
kamanda but I think that gets clarified
if I'm not mistaken uh
on page two
where it does describe that it needs to
be done under a prescription from a
pharmacist or an A rnp but in other
words they have to order that specific
treatment
smoking sensation and it wouldn't also
allow this pharmacist to do heart
surgery or something else that a
physician could could do or any other
Medical Practice am I correct in that
assumption that this is not Cod Blanche
but it needs to be specifically ordered
by a physician
so
thank you for that question and I will
clarify
um the ability for the pharmacist to
provide a product because twofold one is
the authority to provide it but also
they work under a standing order from a
provider so they don't have individual
prescribing Authority they work under
the standing order of a physician or
nurse practitioner and also there's a
Statewide protocol developed by the
Board of Medicine the Board of Nursing
the born of
um nursing medical and also the
Department of Health Human Services so
the protocol which is what they would
follow is Guided by those respective
boards and the Department of Health
Human Services as well as the authority
to do it flows through a provider
through a standing order
okay an outstanding order has to be very
specific
in this case it would not necessarily
extend anything not named an outstanding
order that would ordinarily be provided
by a physician is that correct
correct that's
so basically standing water which is
what the physician is providing was
specified to that fix exactly and then
what it normally says is that the
pharmacist to their Authority could
follow the protocol as this protocol
written
thank you very much those boundaries
that's not allowing them card blocks to
do anything yes thank you
representative Woods
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative Merchant for taking my
question
um we discussed this some time ago and
I've I've forgotten how this came out so
my apologies for asking the question
again uh but that refers to the standing
order which is introduced on page two
line 17.
um I need clarification again uh exactly
how that's structured uh and how it's
interfaced with uh the uh primary care
and his physician
um and I have a follow-up depending upon
the answer
basically my question is how is that
standing order promulgated
and how is it instituted
I mean who who uh there's a standing
order and I'm a primary care did I write
it is it a standing order written for
each individual Primary Care
uh if it's not if it's written by
somebody else an agency
um what uh what's the ability for a
individual Primary Care to shall we say
opt-in or opt out
of that standing order
you're on mute
that's why I was talking so well
so given the fact that today patients
see multiple providers
[Music]
um which pharmacists are basically in
this instance becoming part of the
healthcare team
we don't require the
position of the provider if you go to to
notify the primary care if they want to
treat the patient
um it's not built into the system today
again back to my father who sees a
cardiologist who sees a dermatologist
and sees a
pulmonologists and so forth the
pulmonologist doesn't call the primary
care to initiate therapy there's
probably communication back with the
primary care but it's not required
the issue we're trying to talk to I
think is a fragmentation of Health Care
system that we're involved with today
and what we're trying to do
fundamentally is not to
build barriers up to it but accept
what's in place that we have today that
allows for multiple providers to help
treat a patient this is a particular
case to talk about smoking therapy
sensation
um at that point in time because you're
working understanding order the
authority flows through that
position just like you would in the
other position
and as far as getting back to what
you're trying to get to is when he
the standing order comes from the
physician so that standing order would
therefore have to come
not So Much from the primary care
document from the position that the
patient's coming under which should be
the person running the standing order
taking the authority from that point of
view
um and I go back to what I mentioned
before with the system we have today
it's not always the ideal system but it
is the system we have
um
[Music]
versus putting barrier in place
representative Shapiro has his hand up
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Merchant
um I know the first part of the bill
recognizes pharmacists as providers for
the purposes of Medicaid State
reimbursement
um does this bill also
imply that pharmacists will be able to
be reimbursed for
prescribing smoking cessation therapies
I know they're not technically
prescribing it but
um through a standing order would it
allow them to be reimbursed
yes it would allow them to be in work
reimbursed for the
evaluation because when you look at the
patient coming in what the pharmacist is
going to have to do is sit down with
that protocol
and go through that protocol with the
patient to be sure the patient in fact
meets the criteria within the protocol
and that takes time so therefore that
time element would be built to Medicaid
the dispensing of the product who so
desired to do that would not be a
a service patient care service it'd be a
dispensing function so this allows for
the pharmacist to be reimbursed with the
time element that they need to do it
appropriately to be sure the patient
meets the criteria within the protocol
if the patient doesn't meet the criteria
within a protocol then the pharmacist
would therefore make a referral to a
provider because it goes beyond the
constraints within the protocol
thank you could I have a follow-up
follow-up
um so would that
work through private insurers as well or
just through Medicaid
um this is only dealing with Medicaid
okay
one more follow-up one more follow-up
okay so in trying to understand the
standing order
um the standing order is not given by
the primary care doctor but does each
Pharmacy have a specific standing order
from a specific doctor or is there just
a Statewide standing order
um that's a good question representative
Shapiro we don't use the Statewide
standing order when we do use it in
naloxone so for instance in naloxone the
department Health and Human Services
issued a standing order at the state
level so all pharmacies can therefore
provide naloxone Narcan to a patients or
family members that may have an issue
with opium opiate addiction
um this one here is more specific than
that it's not broadly written so that it
covers the whole state The Physician
that does it with covering only those
that are under the
direction of the pharmacist so in other
words
if you're writing a standing order
only the ones that can use the standing
order the ones that are coming under the
standing order by the provider it's not
Statewide it's specific to whether the
provider wants to do so if the provider
wants to make it General they could but
if they want to make it narrow they
could too they could specify within the
standing order they only want these
pharmacists to be part of it or they can
make it Broad and say I'll think around
the responsibility for the community at
Large
thank you
representative gay
thank you very much
I guess I need to clarify something
really basic and that is by making the
pharmacist a provider at least to
Medicaid people
that's another clarification I need by
making the pharmacist the provider that
means they can order the the
prescription they can write the
prescription to use the standing order
so that's question one
and question two is
what exactly is considered nicotine
cessation therapy because it says means
medications
and the medications are either with
prescription or without and if you don't
need a prescription
what exactly is nicotine cessation is
there any counseling involved in this is
this just writing a prescription
okay let me so the first question
representative gay
in regards to
the authority to prescribe is not
independent the but the authority to
prescribe and it's really not
prescribing in a sense but to order the
medication
flows through a provider so it's going
through a physician or a nurse
practitioner so the pharmacist is not
independently have that Authority they
have to work with a provider or a nurse
practitioner
so they are the ones that assigned to
the pharmacist The Authority under their
authority to provide the product
to order the product to corrects in
other words they only can do it if
they're given Authority by the physician
through the standing order so they
cannot do an independent of a provider
so their Authority flows as a subset
under the provider they don't do it
independently
if you want to follow up representative
gay are you okay yes thank you uh does
this mean that the provider through whom
it
okay it sounds like a pharmacist has an
agreement with the um provider that they
can use a standing order
which brings up to me a question like
does the person who's asking for this
treatment are they is this their
provider or is this just a provider who
has given authority to a pharmacist
without regard for who the person is who
comes in for the uh treatment
it
The Authority flows again back to the
provider
um it's kind of
oh in other words
I'm going to say this when you when a
patient comes in and has the therapy
what the standing order does through the
provider is say if a patient comes into
your Pharmacy
I'll give you authority to treat that
patient but you have to do it with the
constraints of that protocol
if you don't follow the protocol you
don't have any Authority so at that
point in time is the position or the
nurse practitioner is granting the
pharmacist the ability to treat the
patient
provided they follow that protocol
they can't they can't that's a gay they
cannot as a pharmacist they cannot
deviate from that protocol it's
basically an algorithm they have to go
down through it's a checklist
to be sure that patient qualifies for
the therapy
but the authority flows back to a
physician ultimately
okay and my first question
uh can you my second question
what com what comprises nicotine
cessation therapy other than just
ordering a medication well this is
another quirk in the Medicaid system
Medicaid recognizes that nicotine
cessation products to help a patient
get off from tobacco products can be
over the counter as well as prescription
however Medicaid will only pay for a
medication
if it's ordered by a provider so if the
patient decides to get nicotine patches
instead of them having to reach into
their pocket which becomes a barrier
Financial barrier what the state
recognizes that we want them off the
tobacco because it's in the best
interest of the state both economically
and for the patient health-wise is if
the provider authorizes it the state
will pay for it
so it's a quirk in the system it's in a
lot of ways it's the same way with
health care insurance today if you have
an over-the-counter product sometimes
the insurance company will pay for it
sometimes they won't but if it's not
something in which a providers
ordering for you in some capacity they
won't pay for it so it's one of those
things where we're trying to write it
and saying whether it's over-the-counter
or a prescription reps of gay then
reimbursement to the pharmacist for the
product as well the service would
would occur and we're trying to
encourage again back to the same thing
we talked about before it's not just the
assessment of the patients also the
counseling that goes with it so it's
time consuming
um when you start looking at the
engagement with the patient
we want to be sure that the pharmacist
is fairly compensated for the additional
time that they have to take with the
patient to do it safely and
appropriately so that they have the
counseling and they have the right
product they need to try to get to the
end result which is getting off the
tobacco products
we're going to move on to the chair
recognizes representative knurk
yeah you right I didn't realize that was
up next
um thank you very much for taking my
question so on page two uh lines 20
um
6 through 29 which precludes uh it
prohibits seeking first personal
financial benefit with incentive-based
programs which I think is great wish we
had it for surgeons um but in any case
um there because there is a bit of a
conflict of interest with a vertical
Monopoly where you decide that the
patient should get it and also you
provide it so does this
um
sentence apply to only outside
inducements like from a company that
makes them or does this also apply to
the metrics that might occur in the
pharmacy lighting compensation based uh
on the productivity of the pharmacist
that's a good question representative
knurk
um the language in there applies to all
providers including Physicians and nurse
practitioners so therefore whatever is
applicable to a provider uh be a
physician nurse practitioner and so
forth as far as the disincentives that
we're talking about would be equal
across the board so all parties follow
the same rules and regulations
so if a physician is in the office
could do the same thing where all of a
sudden a patient comes in and they
robotica look at and saying I'll give or
do something for the patient
procedure-wise and so forth because I'll
get extra Revenue
that's not what we're the intent here
but it's nothing to prevent a provider
from over doing things for a patient
either
but I I agree but would you like a
follow-up sorry I agree my apologies I
agree but my question is what about
um other incentive programs for
reimbursement within the pharmacies
based on Pharmacy pharmacist
productivity in terms of the number of
people they either interact with or that
proceed on to the
intervention
I don't know I'm asking
no I I think
not that I'm aware of I think is
somewhere along the way we're all
including providers and Physicians
offices we all have people that look at
our productivity and say you know are
you generating enough Revenue to support
yourself I mean it's very much a common
in medical
um where I worked before because a lot
of doctors were measured by their rvu's
relative value units and if they didn't
have enough rbus which is kind of the
same thing in a lot where you'll be
billable hours someone had to talk to
you
so I I don't like it but it could
possibly be there yeah
want another follow-up please yeah yes
and I agree with you it's a problem so
here's a question too though that
relates to the same issue if a patient
comes in to fill a prescription for they
were lisinopril or something is the
pharmacist allowed to solicit uh and ask
them about are you having any
difficulties with tobacco and you like
to participate in nicotine cessation or
must be a patient initiate the visit for
that purpose of nicotine cessation wow
good I would say that's a possibility
but I also encourage the pharmacist
engagement with the patient because as I
mentioned before the number of times a
patient goes into a pharmacy to see the
pharmacist is probably twice as often as
a primary care dog they know the patient
population I would not want to gag the
pharmacist when they recognize a patient
may benefit from the therapy or the fear
of someone saying well you're trying to
do it for self reasons versus for the
patients reasons it's a difficult thing
to tackle if I don't understand
where you going but I would not want to
include in the bill some sort of a
clause in there I think we have to look
at people professionally and honorably
and until until otherwise that they're
doing things best for the patient and
not for themselves and that's kind of
why we're professionals I hope that
stays with most my peers and colleagues
if it could be very quick it is quick I
think because I think it's obvious but
I'm not sure but thank you and I agree
with you um you guys mentioned this is
only Medicaid so why not including other
insurances or is that just too complex
it's too complex because the Medicaid
system
it's just a long story that's fine very
complex and it's not Prime Time first to
go thank you representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and I realized
when I was listening to some questions
by representative gay that I was not
I may have been making assumptions about
who we are contemplating as a provider
um
is this intended
to be used by individual pers providers
prescribing for individual patients
known to them
or is it intended to be uh the sort of
standing order that
um one of the state doctors rights is a
Statewide thing
or is it intended to be both
it could it could be either
um it would be nice if we could do
something at the state level and the um
chief medical officer within Department
Health Human Services would sign a
standing order which applied throughout
the state in the past that hasn't been
the case so it does allow for a
physician within it
the confines of whatever they want to
control and say within this group
population of Pharmacists I'm okay with
giving them the authority because they
have some
um way to direct it if I'm working in
the medical center and I have the
ability to work with pharmacists in
outpatient setting I'm only giving out
authority to people within my own
organization so it could go at the state
level which is what I liked to occur but
that we haven't had that successfully
done except for naloxone but this does
allow a physician within an organization
to say if the pharmacist is within my
organization I feel comfortable and they
can take come out of the standing order
but the position controls It ultimately
okay thank you very much
representative Woods
um my thank you uh
um Mr chair and again I'm going back to
the same question
um I'm a I'm a patient and I come in and
I have no doc uh I'm just you know I
want to get uh get rid of this smoking
problem
um do you have the standing order from
someone how do you proceed if I don't
have a doctor
because in that case
if you have a need for the therapy it's
been identified as appropriate the
authority of flow would be just like a
provider the pharmacist becomes another
provider within the realm of the
healthcare team so the Authority for
them to be taken care of flows through
the position
um and therefore we've lowered the
barrier for the patient to get the
therapy
versus making another appointment with
somebody else so if you have a primary
care doc you probably not go to the
pharmacist sometimes you would have a
situation where if you don't have a
primary care doc they could walk into a
mini clinic now and see a nurse
practitioner they could walk into an
urgent care center
um so basically we're trying to build
access points for the patient to have
the ability to see a provider who's been
trained appropriately like all the
others to provide the therapy but the
Again The Authority for it flows through
the physician or nurse practitioner not
independent of them
you know but I I understand that and I
understand the need and the Arc of the
changing of Medical Care uh such as we
have hospitalists and some Physicians
don't go to the hospital anymore a
variety of other changes uh but I again
going back to my question what happens
to the person who comes in I don't have
a doc I don't have a nurse practitioner
how do you get the authority at that
juncture you uh the point has been made
that it flows through the physician or
nurse practitioner so I'm I'm I guess
I'm dense here and I'm I need some help
but how how does that person that comes
in that has no contact get how does the
pharmacists get to the authority
well I think it's two parts of the
question one is the patient doesn't have
a primary care dog
and then is sort of out there on their
own to some degree they don't have a
medical home they don't have that kind
of uh infrastructure that they can
advantage of what this bill does allow
the patient to do is access
therapy through a pharmacist now back to
the issue about the authority the
pharmacist Works under the pharmacist
Works under Authority like
a
big pharmacy at that point in time
there's a position at the medical center
who gave me the authority
through the standing order to treat that
patient
so therefore if the patient comes in
wants to have access to nicotine
sensation therapy and I recognize that
they do and they can follow within the
guidelines of the protocol then because
of the authority from the position
within my organization I would be able
to provide it
but it's up again it's up to the
position at that point in time deciding
upon what the extent of authority they
provide to the pharmacist because they
control it
it's kind of like working under a PA or
someone else so you you give them the
authority
to work the patient
um I'd like to see it at the state level
so that we waited
organization approaches it differently
so we don't have a state standard but
that's kind of the way it was structured
representative marshes texted me
thinking that he might be able to answer
this question uh with other language so
I'm going to bump him up to next
representative Marsh
uh thank you everybody I think I'm
unmuted I wanted to help participate in
the discussion I hadn't originally
signed up to speak but I think I can
answer your question uh representative
Dr Woods the way we originally crafted
this language was to craft it with the
most flexibility possible so if you in
your local community where you've been
the primary care physician forever and a
day want to take care of the members of
your community and issue a standing
order to your pharmacist to say that if
people can come in they want to start
smoking cessation therapy fine Gotta
Give them this counseling you can do
this particular treatment and then they
have to come in to see me two weeks
later or whatever you can include all of
those things in your protocol as you
read it write it but we're controlling
that by the protocol so it's under the
Physicians control and not mandating it
by the legislature putting in particular
requirements so uh it's not that
representative Merchant is trying to not
answer your question it's that we
intentionally left flexibility in the
way we structured it
so a pharmacist could have
something from Dr Pearson
saying treat any and all have fun and
therefore the pharmacist is now got his
standing order
well if Dr Pearson were a licensed
medical doctor yes that that that could
be true yes but but uh I I think that
since the pharmacists hold liability
here if they don't follow things
correctly uh they they would be uh uh
well served and I think intentionally
would would uh only follow standing
orders that they too feel comfortable
with so they do have to work as part of
the team and and the idea is to increase
patient access uh and use the pharmacist
as physician extenders so ultimately we
can reduce the cost of health care for
the State of New Hampshire
I actually was referring to my wife but
I'll let it go representative snow
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
Merchant I'm confused which is not
unusual but
there are two documents we're talking
about one is a standing order and one is
a protocol which is I understand it is a
list of questions that are asked to
determine whether it's appropriate for
the person to receive this treatment I'm
like now does one grow out of the other
are they totally separate documents and
who originates those documents
okay
remember that style that's a great
question
um there's two separate questions and
what that question let me deal with the
first one the authority
to do something flows through the
position
or through the marriage practitioner
[Music]
to provide products or the therapy
patient now as far as the protocol is
concerned that protocol is developed
through a joint effort with people from
the Department health Team and services
for the Board of Medicine in the Board
of Nursing so they're the ones that
create the protocol based upon Nationals
which pharmacist has to follow
so there's two things to one is if you
give in the authority under a provider
to provide the therapy you have to stay
within the guidelines of a protocol
based upon national standards approved
by the Board of Medicine the Board of
Nursing and the Department of Public
Department of Health and Human Services
does that help answer the question yes
foreign follow-up though
follow-up Islamic protocol been
developed or is it something you would
develop once this bill has passed and
isn't that sort of putting the
before the horse I mean shouldn't we
have this protocol available before we
approve
using it to qualify people to get into
this program
the protocol is not developed
needs to be developed
um we did the same thing with another
form of therapy we basically things
change standards change kind of
basically at that point in time we're
leaving it to the Authority and the
wisdom of the Board of Medicine the
Board of Nursing and the well the
department
helping Human Service for them to
develop
article
that
did for that therapy Pharmacy is not
developed will have to be developed but
until the board of matter the Board of
Nursing the important human designs off
on it would not become active
one final brief follow-up Mr chairman
yes go ahead
am I assuming then the date in this
build coming into effect is July
uh 30th 2022 is it my assumption that
prior to that time this protocol will be
developed or not
uh could you hear me am I am I not muted
again no you're okay I don't know where
representative Merchant went right there
he is I'm having a little problem like
I'm having a challenge with connectivity
um I'm hoping in this neck of the woods
like representative Weber talked about
before uh we don't have a problem I
think the wires are starting to uh
wiggle
um but I'm holding on as much as I can
um reps of style can you repeat that
question please certainly I'm sorry uh
yes I noticed that the date this bill
comes into effect is July 30th 2022.
that's a year from this July is can I
make the assumption that this protocol
will be developed and in place prior to
this uh Bill going into effect
did it how did I come across that time
representative snow yes that's the
reason why is the delay and the
implementation is to allow for the
protocol to be developed and quite
frankly even if it's after January 2026
um until that protocol is developed the
pharmacist is going to proceed
accordingly so it's going to require
the consensus of the Board of Medicine
nursing and the Department of Health
Human Services on that protocol before
they can move forward regardless of the
day
I read on page three line 18 the
effective date is January 1st
2015. that's okay your question still
holds
um and I believe the answer was whenever
the date is uh it won't happen until
Protocols are in place
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and I'm going to
try one more Circle back and I'm going
to hope that we do not get swept away
again with authorities flowing from one
person to another because I'm going to
ask the question in the other direction
if I walk into a pharmacy
and I say to the pharmacist I desire to
stop smoking but I do not have a primary
care provider and I do not have a
prescription I just want you Mr
pharmacist to very kindly help me stop
smoking because now is the moment
am I correct in thinking that unless you
have some kind of standing order
if there is no standing order that I fit
you have to say to that patient you need
to go down to the Urgent Care Center and
talk to a
provider and they will then contact me
and at that point I can help you with
your smoking cessation is that how it
works
represent Weber thank you for the
question exactly
um thank you the pharmacist doesn't have
that Authority you send them to another
provider
thank you thank you representative
Nelson
thank you for taking my question
is the authority of the local doctor
whatever provider is that somebody
sitting in the Walmart out in California
doctors sitting there and big office
saying I give you the authority to do
that or does it have to be somebody that
the person sees locally
that's my question
well if you go back to on page two
under line 18.
it has to be a licensed practitioner in
the state of New Hampshire
so if the provider is from California
and does not have a license in New
Hampshire they would not qualify to
create the sending order it's limited to
those who are licensed by the state of
New Hampshire both a physician as well
as a nurse practitioner follow up follow
up
well if Walmart hires one doctor just to
do this in Concord New Hampshire he does
the entire state for Walmart sits at
home
can he do it for any Walmart all over
not never well could he do it for all
any Walmart in the state of New
Hampshire
you need to talk about outside of the
State of New Hampshire within the state
of New Hampshire within the state of New
Hampshire they could because it's within
their organization so you got to realize
the physician when they sign that
standing order takes responsibility as
well as the pharmacist
so it's a shared responsibility between
the two uh The Physician does not Escape
some liability because if they gave the
standing order to a pharmacist that was
a qualified and the pharmacist did
something
on behalf of the patient they would have
the liability as well thank you
Dr Makai
Representatives
if you ask Dr McKay to him on mute he
will get a button that he can see right
on his screen
Dr Mckay please unmute
I
I say I think Lucy met the dentist has
to ask him to unmute
well he doesn't have to but if he does
there will be a button on his yeah yeah
you can see
yeah I just bet we couldn't tell them
verbally
my list is sorted by first name
alphabetically so try Jim
and you need to go to panelists rather
than attendees yeah
if you go to panelists and then gym you
can give him a button to unmute
foreign
oh there he is
he's under initials RJ if that helps
okay and you're unmuted Jim
okay can you hear me now yeah yeah okay
I'm sorry for that uh
uh Lucy has been great helping me but
I'm not a good student but my interest
is that uh having watched over time
uh the evolution of Pharmacy care
that at the same time my impression is
that the training of Pharmacists has
also evolved
particularly at the doctorate level and
some of these questions have to do
underlying with the competence of
Pharmacists so I wonder if the
representative Merchant very briefly
would say something about how this
training has evolved
foreign
representative McKay that's a good
question
did ground us um when I was first in
a student at Pharmacy I worked with a
colleague who was my mentor at that time
who actually never graduated from
college
um all you're required to do was take a
apprenticeship program under the hospice
of a pharmacist at that point in time
and then passed the exam
since that time it's evolved to your
point
where our pharmacist today spends four
years in graduate school
through either a two or four year
undergraduate degree so the level of
training and
expertise as well as the classroom
experience that we have a lot of people
today as pharmacists go into a one or
two year Residency program set up a
hospital on top of that
so pharmacists are well educated well
trained
today to assume some of the
responsibilities we're talking about
today and that's kind of what we're
trying to advocate for is that we have a
resource within our Healthcare team
that is many ways underutilized and we
have a situation today in which we have
a tsunami coming at us with a lot of
people looking for health care and we
can't meet it we have access issues that
we need to address so by elevating the
pharmacist to allow them to do more
things we accomplish two things one is
we allow the patient to get access to
that Health Care Point number two we
allow providers
themselves to work at the top of their
license so that they could take care of
or complex patients and allow the
pharmacists do some of the things that
they could do within their training they
have today so I do want to say thank you
for that question per episode of McKay
because it's important one
I see no further hands up from the
committee and I see no attendees with a
hand dot indicating wishing to testify
um
so it looks like we're finished and when
I find my gavel we will be but don't run
away herein's the
um hearing on House Bill forces Mr
chairman we had three people who signed
up
uh there they are suddenly with their
hands up
so I am going to reopen this hearing
and I beg your pardon I didn't see them
with hands so there they are now
um uh the chair recognizes uh Bob Terrio
and with apologies for somehow missing
you you may uh come into the meeting
thank you Mr chairman can can you hear
me we can sir we can okay I've hit the
unmute a couple times thank you and
we're good very good all right
um my name is uh Bob tariel and I'm
speaking in support of uh House Bill
479. uh I am the I'm a pharmacist I'm
the director of pharmacy at Wentworth
Douglas hospital and I'm the legislative
chair for the New Hampshire Society of
Health Systems pharmacist uh what I'm
hoping to be able to talk about is
provide some examples of
Pharmacists as uh part of the healthcare
team and uh physician team extenders at
my health system we have a number of
Pharmacists that have a collaborative
practice agreements with providers
uh and so in our Seacoast Cancer Center
I have pharmacists that work with
providers and and in their practice they
uh work with the patients and they work
on the anti-nausea medications and their
pre-meds they order them monitor their
treatment
I have a pharmacist in cardiology that
also meets with patients on heart
diseases and anticoagulation and then I
have a pharmacist in a primary care that
has a collaborative practice agreement
with diabetes and all of these
pharmacists practice like a provider
they they have appointments the patient
comes in they sit with the patient go
over their drug therapy they monitor
their drug they order different drugs
they they change Doses and uh currently
you know they don't get paid for that
that service
I've had other clinics requests those
types of services such as uh
chronic pulmonary disease pain
management and opiate use disorders and
again to make the business plan it's
it's often hard to make a business plan
which is quality metrics and freeing up
the provider time so uh payment for our
services would really help uh give more
access to care and uh would improve
quality outcomes for some of these
patients additionally when you look at
some of these diseases so cardiac
disease and cancer a number of patients
do want to quit smoking and so it's not
included in their CPA right now but a
standing order with with our chief
medical officer would allow during one
of these appointments if a patient
expressed that they would they're ready
to quit that pharmacist could then
initiate smoking cessation therapy
uh additionally at Wentworth Douglas we
have a community Retail Pharmacy so when
you get admitted to the hospital one of
the uh questions that is asked you know
are you a smoker and uh are you
interested in quitting and so that
information again during the
hospitalization doesn't usually get
addressed but one of the Visions we have
is our ambulatory or Retail Pharmacy
would have access to that information
and then upon discharge they could work
with the patient to implement smoking
cessation and become you know their
source for helping them uh quit tobacco
utilization
so
um any questions that you might have as
I said I'm in favor of this I think
pharmacists are well trained as
representative Merchant said uh it's uh
they have a doctor of Pharmacy and most
of my pharmacists are residency trained
either one or two year uh post their
pharmd program
thank you any questions for Mr Terio
saying none from the committee I will
call next on Tanya Carlton
foreign
can you hear me we can
oh good morning chairman Pearson and
members of the committee
um thank you for the opportunity today
to provide testimony my name is Tanya
Carlton I am currently the clinical
Pharmacy manager at Wentworth Douglas
Hospital in Dover as well as the
immediate past president of the New
Hampshire Society of Health Systems
pharmacists I'm
here today to express my support of HB
479 and it's full of increasing patient
access to nicotine cessation therapy
so as you all know cigarette smoking
Still Remains the leading cause of
preventable disease disability and death
within the United States we still have
approximately 34 million Americans who
currently smoke cigarettes and most of
them are still smoking daily smoking
kills over half a million Americans
every year and millions more live with
serious chronic diseases caused by
smoking in addition smoking-related
illness in the United States costs more
than 300 billion dollars a year
including nearly 170 billion in direct
medical care for adults and 156 million
in Lost productivity
in the 2020 Surgeon General report on
smoking cessation the Surgeon General of
the United States states the following
clinical interventions for smoking
cessation are critical if we are to
achieve our goal of eliminating the
devastating effects of smoking on public
health
primary care physicians nurses
Pharmacists and other providers and all
medical disciplines in an all Health
Care environments should take advantage
of these opportunities to inform and
encourage smokers to quit
therapeutic assistance for smoking
cessation includes medication treatment
of nicotine dependence and counseling
based upon Behavioral Science for
psychological dependence pharmacists
plan important role in encouraging
smoking cessation and are poised to
provide this type of support
pharmacists have a good understanding of
the medical condition and
pharmacotherapy to treat patients and
are able to obtain training specific
smoking cessation
as Bob said currently at Wentworth
Douglas we have three pharmacists that
provide care to patients in the
ambulatory settings of oncology
Cardiology and diabetes management all
of these pharmacists have their dog
shirts and Pharmacy have obtained
Advanced Training and have advanced
certifications
collaboration between Physicians and
pharmacists with respect to managing
smoking cessation therapy could achieve
two beneficial goals of reducing demands
on Physicians time while increasing
access to therapy that can help those
motivated to quit smoking succeed in
this endeavor
one of the factors that plays a key role
in the underutilization of nicotine
cessation resources is the barrier to
accessing
a medical professional who can prescribe
smoking cessation medications at the
time when a patient decides to quit AC
479 eliminates this area by providing
pharmacists one of the most
pharmacist one of the most accessible
Health Care Professionals the ability to
manage pharmacotherapy
thank you for your consideration and I
can answer any questions you might have
of my
before I turn anyone loose to ask a
question I'm going to ask representative
Folsom who has just joined the meeting
to give us the essential information
about where you are and how many people
are there with you
hello good morning I am at home in
Wentworth and my husband is roaming
around the house somewhere
thank you and I'm going to keep
representative Nelson on his clerk until
we're finished with this bill because
he's doing a great job coming out of
retirement thank you representative gay
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um Mrs Carlton
um I just have one question and that is
how much time with a patient do you
envision the therapy to offer
so our Ambulatory Care pharmacists
um they had like Bob said they actually
have appointments with these patients
and so they can piggyback on to you know
if they're managing a patient for heart
failure or for anticoag or for diabetes
um they'll spend upwards of half an hour
an hour with these patients they can
include nicotine cessation as part of
this conversation which if you're
talking about oncology patients and lung
cancer or Cardiology patients and heart
failure or cardiovascular disease or
diabetes management you know
including smoking cessation and the
ability to be able to treat it is vital
um to
you know improve patient outcomes and
improve patient access to these you know
critical medications
um they are also counseling and
educating the patient on how best to
take these medications and they also
have full access to their medication
history
allergies drug interactions so that they
can provide the appropriate care to
these patients
follow up
you're on mute
this still seems to apply just to
Medicaid patients for your private
patients do you get to bill for them
because it sounds like y'all offer a lot
of time
um
so is this a standard thing that you can
bill for in other insurance
at this point in time no because we're
not considered to be providers this bill
is only going to allow us to build
Medicaid
at this point in time however we would
still offer these services to anybody
that we see however we wouldn't receive
payment
thank you any further questions for Miss
Carlton
seeing none the chair recognizes Brianna
wheeler to speak
good morning chairman Pearson and
members of the committee can you all
hear me okay perfect perfect so um as
you say my name is Brianna wheeler and
I'm here to testify in support of house
bill
479. I am a pharmacy student in my final
year of school at the University of New
England School of Pharmacy and I'm
graduating with a pharmd in May
I currently live in Hillsborough New
Hampshire and I'm a student at Wentworth
Douglas completing clinical rotations
right now and so I recently had the
opportunity to complete a clinical
rotation with Dr Maureen Brady who is
the Ambulatory Care pharmacist at the
primary care setting who has the ability
to treat patients with diabetes and so a
large amount of these patients struggled
with addiction to nicotine and numerous
patients did express interest in wanting
to be rid of this addiction when asked
and so without pharmacists having the
opportunity to take lead on managing
treatment for these patients they were
not given the attention they needed and
many were lost to follow up as you know
nicotine addiction does take a lot of
time and attention and so this build
could change that as the pharmacist did
have a lot of time and opportunity to
create appointments with these patients
and spend the time really needed to help
them and so I saw firsthand the impact a
pharmacists could make on the patient's
health and quality of life when given
the chance to manage more serious
conditions such as diabetes so if you
can imagine the impact this could make
on the serious disease of nicotine use
disorder this bill is not meant to
undermine the leadership of the
patient's PCP it is merely adding
another tool to the patient's toolkit
and so with that I thank you for your
time and I can answer any questions that
you may have
well as I think you know because we've
corresponded my wife graduated from the
University of New England with a
doctorate and Osteopathic Medicine some
years ago so that that prods me to ask
the questions since une has a pharmacy
school and an osteopathic medical school
what collaboration do you
to do people from both schools do along
the way
we have many
um many instances to collaborate not
only with the medical students but we
also have a school of dentistry
nursing
and and so it's we actually fall under
the umbrella of the Westbrook um Health
College
um College of Health Professions
um and so we we have
um activities that we're
um required to complete um that are
called ipac so it's interprofessional
collaboration
um because you know outside of school we
are expected to communicate with the
rest of the healthcare team so we are
trained fully to do that
um many times through our school career
and you know osteopaths love that stuff
yes
as do pharmacy
you have a question for soon to be d
farm Brianna wheeler
seeing none thank you so much thank you
and I see no one from the attendees who
has a hand up who hasn't spoken yet
so I think we are finished on the
hearing and I will reprise my
uh closing the hearing now let me ask
representative Merchant
um are you ready if we choose to exec
the bill or would you want to hold it a
week and Tinker with it I I think that
bill talk about Bill 479
I think it's ready for prime time to
exec on it
um based upon the
testimony and also based upon the
questions from the committee I do see a
challenge though with 572 and I'll say
challenge with 143 which I need and
we're going to do them next week well
seeing that I am opening what I hope to
be an extremely brief exec session on
Bill 479 and representative Merchant
would you care to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman I will definitely
make a motion I make a motion to ought
to pass on House Bill 479
and would Representatives so second did
I had a feeling because it's right here
in my paper Okay so any discussion
seeing none I am going to ask the acting
Clerk
to call the role representative Nelson
as acting Clerk never thought you'd get
to see this happen again did you well
there we go
could you repeat the bill number please
479 look at look at he's right in there
he he got right back in
okay here we go
representative Marsh
votes yes
representative Folsom
yes representative McMahon
Harley
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King
yes representative Cole thought yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay
representative snow yes representative
yes representative Salway yes
representative Cannon
representative
yes on Canon yeah
and yes yes Shapiro representative
yes representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative going back to McMahon
representing the k
representative McKay signified by
raising his thumb we honor his thumb
yes okay that's it all but once so
what's wrong what's the count well I
can't keep track of the count it's
um
excuse me Mr chair oh no no no no no no
you are not recognized zero
who's missing could I ask who's missing
because we have 21 and it I think only
McMahon oh that's true good point
I don't know let's uh put it up to 20.
how about that is that your final answer
that's my final answer okay well done 20
to nothing any uh buddy object and I
don't know why you would to consent
no
and representative
um Nelson you may go back to being a
civilian and thank you so much for your
work oh you're quite welcome and uh I
may just do it again sometime when
representative Marsh can take the chair
with that we close the hearing on 479
and we will see you all back at one
o'clock look at that lunch break I can't
I'll get lunch 51 minutes yeah wow I got
here just in time
McMahon Charlie was treated as the was
not there
right right he was treated as absent but
he's there he's here Charlie Charlie if
you had been able to speak
would you have been in favor of this
bill he's muted well he has to unmute
and I should remind everyone if you do
we're on the executive session and your
face was not showing that you would not
have uh
I know and he arrived part way through I
don't hear when the question was put
and and we have ended the session and
but if all of those things weren't in
place what would you have said it's a
hypothetical question it is totally
let's see there he's saying nothing he's
still muted
well okay then we can all go to lunch
just be away quietly then you see and
yeah we're 20 to nothing as
um representative Nelson said let's go
to lunch folks to win
when right now I want to win do we have
to come back are we executing it well
you don't have to come back but we all
are coming back at one o'clock we have a
bill we have someone wishing a point of
personal privilege and then we're going
to exact so it's going to be quite an
ordeal so I would make sure you have
plenty of protein at lunch
one o'clock we'll see you then
representative Marsh are you still on
yes I am
um do you want to just run through for
me what happened this morning
uh we heard testimony on four bills and
we had one exact uh which I've recorded
on the exact session Bill report form
which I am completing
okay that was that was
um
okay so 143
is there going to be an amendment
brought in uh I was actually at the
chairs meeting for much of this morning
so I can't answer all okay questions
okay I'll I'll check with him later yeah
uh when we when I talk to him off screen
then I'll go I'll go get some lunch
uh representative uh regular chair you
can uh get in touch with me but we're
going to on 572 and 143 and 582 we have
finished the hearings we are going to be
in exact session we hope next week and
there will be some amendments okay all
this way across okay thank you very much
so you really didn't miss anything
you got here for the fun yeah yeah
foreign
thank you
I think
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
you know
foreign
thank you
okay
I thought I'd let you all know that on
the 24th and the 25th if they let us out
of our seats
I'm going to come find all of you so we
can actually meet face to face so don't
be surprised if I am walking around with
a floor plan or whatever seating plan
trying to find you guys because that's
my goal for those days
I think that's a wonderful plan
very nice
[Music]
I wonder what the rules will be for
eating lunch
no lunch
well
I've already filled out my requests so
yeah I I one day or may not feel
comfortable eating much depending on
what it looks like when I get there
question
[Music]
Mark send it out
I must I got other emails about bills I
could have missed a lunch invite still
not um I'm gonna go or not but anyway
well if you search under Paul Smith
that's where you'll find it but I think
you have to reply fairly soon well you
could just call them
anywhere near as appetizing as the
lunches we got at
unhunits were very nice yeah that those
were really good
nice I went to uh Trader Joe's yesterday
I haven't been in there
I don't know months and months and I
bought quick stuff for today so had a
nice lunch today
well I I didn't eat my lunch at the um
UNH representative Marsh for the same
reasons that I I didn't want to take the
mask off but
um I certainly enjoyed it on the way
home I broke the rules and went outside
hey Jerry connect did you have your PB J
today yes I had my usual peanut butter
and jelly yeah
very simple
quick never spoils you can eat it three
days later and it's just as good
it's a little crunchy I like it like
that
do we think George Washington Carver for
peanut butter sandwiches yeah yeah I
hope so I think we should I fished
birthday is in early August I think we
ought to have joy it wasn't a comment
day and have another three day holiday
I'll take that I've got a birthday early
in August so that would work how about
the Lucy
I have done nothing anywhere near as
important as as well you've never been a
penis breather but
well I was born on a holiday but he's
not popular anymore so um
Christopher Columbus OH
yeah yeah I know I mean if you know that
all the whole story it's it's
fascinating
um yeah they're speaking about speaking
of outcasts
and the new lawsuit against the State
against the speaker I think I would not
be off at a lunch even if I did it then
say that and I missed the
Renny and seven others of us filed a
lawsuit against the speaker in the in
the court uh looking for remote access
to the sessions because we've been
denied and I can't go and a lot of other
Susan Rogers can't go a lot of it I'm
absolutely prohibited I can't join any
meeting larger than 10 people
because of rules that have been imposed
upon the place where I live
right right
so we need to make you your own room
in groups of ten can you remember that
would be 40 different rooms we only need
a couple of for you
for you and the other fellows who need
it well
you could tell that to the speaker but
okay
no I I don't think anything's going to
come of it to tell you the truth how big
does the room have to be
oh you know I don't think that's really
hello around here we have a huge
uh kind of living room
area where a lot of us meet in the
evening for a little uh together time
and they're only allowed to have 10 in
that whole room and you have to be six
feet apart and wearing masks yeah and
you know the fact of the matter is we
don't object because up until recently
we've all been very safe we haven't
nobody in the independent living
apartments in this unit even though a
lot of the people in the nursing home
got it but recently we've had nine
people which is kind of a community
spread thing and so they've really
nailed down on us now and I don't I
don't resent it because I don't want to
get sick again you know but
how about putting it tent up could you
put that in in Bedford right on the the
grass there set up a little tent so you
can do all by yourself
yeah that would be good no I I often I I
asked about that at one time is there
any way I could be in a separate room
down at UNH and they said oh absolutely
not and I said what if I stayed in my
car
and I just got a call I can listen to
the going and then you call me and I'll
walk to the doorway and vote and they
said no you can't do that either so but
this isn't UNH UNH has their own very
Persnickety rules I surely think we can
make you a room and there must be some
other people who need that room too
oh no because he would need to have
remote access to anybody here is to be
remote and that's what's not being
allowed yeah if it's remote right I'll
tell you what I am hoping I just got my
first shot last week and I got my second
shot uh March 2nd and then 14 days after
that which is a day before Saint
Patrick's Day
uh I'm I'm through it now I can seek
permission to see if I can then join in
in the legislature now you're feeling
they'll approve it but I think our
chairman wants us yeah
I really was enjoying this and
particularly representative snows
wanting to multiply three-day paid
weekends I just wonder if he ever worked
for
um municipality or anything that would
give him such an idea
well I never actually did work for
municipality but I I've lived in a
number of numbers you're living in one
now okay good uh all right we're going
to start the uh hearing opening up the
hearing
um on House Bill 492
requiring the maintenance of the
covid-19 dashboard and establishing a
legislative committee to study Health
Care disparities experience by
underrepresentative populations during
the Health crisis and we bring in to
introduce her bill representative
Schultz the floor is yours
uh hello Mr chair and HHS committee I'd
love to be on video if that's I saw Mary
Beth earlier asked for that but uh
regardless it's an honor to be here I
also was enjoying the discussion uh
that's us
she just got muted
how can she be I was just chatting away
what can you hear me now
I think I'm even gonna be on video hey
there you are Merry Christmas I was
saying not only are some of my favorite
human beings on this committee but uh
that includes some of my favorite
Republicans and if you think I'm talking
about you I am
so here we go this topic uh is an
interesting one uh and I hope that the
discussion around these the this bill in
this topic in some way uh becomes a
benefit and
um just want to tell one quick story
that gets to the root of what my
intention is with this bill I grew up in
an area of the country where uh being
aware of the sirens that the government
would sound to alert us to tornado
warnings and knowing where to get your
news source for those tornado warnings
uh improved over time as I grew up from
using the basic data that was available
from the National Weather Service which
is basically what the weather channel
uses all of that data and made it a
company good for them
um
to news stations fighting over who had
the best Doppler radar and it really
literally hit home bad analogy but uh
when my brother's neighborhood was in
the path of a bad tornado and they of
course sought safety and it did in fact
level
uh most of his neighborhood and
miraculously his house had very little
damage uh having that ability to know
with the sirens and with the news
sources and the National Weather Service
issuing those warnings and perfecting it
over time has definitely saved lives so
talking about the coveted database in
this way and the dashboard in this way
that's my intention because people are
making life and death decisions based on
the data where things where the hot
spots are where the flare-ups are
um it has hopefully saved some lives and
um concerns from my constituents
probably from your constituents too and
just criticisms of various aspects of
the dashboard is what led me to want to
do this bill to make sure that uh in no
way shape and form is the information
that is available uh influenced by
political decisions to make sure that it
is non-partisan unbiased and impartial
as impartial as the Doppler radar is uh
I also though want to say for just a
moment what I'm not criticize it as the
spouse of a software engineer who worked
for the Department of Information
Services and admin Services who also
handled State data I am not criticizing
the staff who are doing their jobs and
doing what their bot with their boss
orders them to do in no way shape or
form I believe for sure that those were
workers are doing their best to help
inform the public and affect safety
um maybe my criticism is of the
commissioner of HHS possibly the
governor and concerns that my
constituents have had about in
discrepancies in data regarding school
systems that what is on the dashboard
often didn't match what was being
reported uh from their home communities
through uh local information sources uh
that there hasn't been until more
recently enough uh
sunlight placed on other areas the way
that the school system had its own
segment of the data the dashboard we
should have always had as well uh
sunshine on how is this affecting
minority communities because we've seen
in other places where the data has risen
uh more or where the cases were um
more more cases of covid were happening
more quickly and more severely than New
Hampshire that early data was indicating
that the the number of deaths and
hospitalizations among African-Americans
and Latinos were much higher and while
technically we have a smaller population
than many to Most states uh any
um way shape or form that it would
affect our 10 percent of our population
that are people of color would
definitely should be mindful of that I
have also I'm sure we will hear from
staff at HHS who've done a thorough job
of raising their um points regarding
that data I I think that's again I don't
criticize them at all I think that that
is good information that will be helpful
to make this build better
um and really
I'm not exactly sure how we get to
um other than reporters questions and
things I've heard from my constituents
how can we make this non-partisan
unbiased and impartial and I've made an
attempt to do that with this film so let
me go through a couple of the details on
the bill itself
so as I try to figure out where I had it
open
here we go
um so in the first section it's just
because uh there is no official I don't
believe statute requiring any sort of
coveted dashboard in the first place uh
I realize that has been voluntary on the
executive Branch's uh decision making
and I'm grateful I'm sure we're all
grateful for that
um if we could find a way to uh codify
this for the future and not just have
section one is specifically about
covid-19 if you perhaps as a committee
would like to make this something that
any pandemic would produce I think
that's also a good idea but for now this
obviously the text is just about the
code 19. uh included UNH I thought that
might be a way to ensure that the nature
of the dashboard can be non-partial
impartial
uh include lots more demographics not
all of these need to be released to the
Press necessarily or to the public where
it would
um you know I definitely would want to
be mindful of
uh not just HIPAA laws but uh privacy in
general but at the Town level have uh
the amount of data I've listed in here
is age race town and eligibility
um and also that vaccine information
could be cross-referenced uh by
geography age race and eligibility I'm
not sure if anything you or the governor
have done thus far already addresses the
vaccination issue but when I wrote this
bill there I wasn't aware yet of how far
that information was being made public
other than what I saw in the press
conferences which were at that point
inadequate
um that has improved by necessity to
some degree but there still are
questions about vaccinations and where
is that where where is the flow going
well and not going well I think that
also is important for the public to know
so folks in any areas that have
difficulties
um that shining a light on it being
transparent about it can help everyone
maneuver the system and improve it
um and I also include really for the
purpose of is of since we've gone
through uh not quite a year of covid in
New Hampshire but maybe close to that
a legislative committee since the
majority of coveted decisions have
happened under executive order and uh
you know conferring with the state
epidemiologists the governor and his
staff and the commissioner of HHS and
her staff I thought it might be a good
idea to include a legislative committee
you know not ignoring gopher but to do a
review of this information this could
become something that would review uh
how have we done under covid but really
with the at least the way it's written
now looking at underrepresented
populations in the pandemic and then uh
more details about that committee I know
study committees are not really
happening right now I will also admit I
am not an expert
um this just comes out of concerns I've
heard uh from the media press conference
is here from news stories from Florida
and New York and just from conversations
between lawmakers and the general public
my constituents included that there have
been times that the New Hampshire
coveted database
uh for lack of a better term has felt
um
opportunistic no that's the wrong word
has seemed to have been influenced
potentially by politics or political
decisions I don't have any proof of that
this is just going and when data seemed
to be flowing more freely versus when it
wasn't uh somewhat in proximity to an
election
uh I'm not raising specific allegations
other than I heard concerns about that
and I did see there were times that the
data lagged and it just so happened to
be near an election I am not saying for
sure that someone did anything wrong but
I do know the system as it exists today
for all of the good intentions of the
staff implementing the dashboard which
again I'm grateful for are no doubt
above board but by including the
legislation or the legislature and some
oversight that we can look at the kova
database in future pandemic
dashboards in the same manner that we do
the Doppler radar that's my purpose
other folks that are speaking uh are
much better at the details and are
better experts than me I just hope that
this conversation and hopefully this
bill creates the scenario where to
whatever degree we as a legislature can
improve this process for the health and
well-being of our citizens
that we can do that and on that note I
will take questions
I will try to answer them
uh have we lost representative Pearson
I've been trying to make sure we
actually had a host here
looks like he's muted
which is why I am so understanding with
all of you my colleagues representative
McKay would you please unmute so we can
hear your question to the representative
thank you very much am I coming through
you're doing great better than I did
thank you during the break I've went out
and came back in again so straightened
out that little problem but my uh Chris
I think this is a
a thoughtful committee I'm not sure it
sounds as if this committee does not
gather data but it reviews data that
exists in Corrections Health and Human
Services and what I don't know is how
are you going to use that data and who
is the audience for this committee
um well this data would be hopefully
used to improve the dashboard as it
continues to exist in the short term
uh I do think there's again a value to
looking at this information
and
um questions that maybe weren't
completely answered by the media and by
our cons you know some concerns that our
constituents have had about the
discrepancies between what numbers seem
to be reported in local communities on
even just schools versus what was
showing up on the kova dashboard I think
it would also be helpful to have a
review of some sort
which is what in part the intention was
by creating a committee
um so does that answer your question
partially but do you like a follow-up
sir would you like to follow up uh no I
think I'd like to listen to All Those
Questions okay thank you representative
Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
I'm wondering how you are thinking about
dealing with the issue that unlike
tornadoes we have
um conflicting interests here one being
the very real necessity for
sunlight and data and and information
that people can use to make important
decisions for themselves and their loved
ones but on the other side we have the
issue of privacy for many of our sisters
citizens and
um if if we're looking at a system that
can be cross-referenced uh via age race
and geographic location I'm thinking
about living in a small town and the
number of African Americans in my small
town is very small and I could find out
an uncomfortable amount about their
health uh if I can cross-reference
according to all of these factors so
um my concern
is how do you envision
resolving those two issues the one of
privacy versus the access to data
that's a great question and I'll be
honest with you that it
um maybe because I'm from Concord it
didn't occur to me but as you ask that
that is obviously a concern I know I
used to go to a retreat center in
Springfield that would bring in
African-American Retreat leaders and I
realized from the population that
Springfield had two African Americans
based from the last census in 2010 and
we would more than double the population
of African Americans in that town so I
apologize that I didn't it didn't dawn
on me sooner uh it would probably be a
great idea then to regionalize certain
rural areas based on
um perhaps well you guys probably have a
better idea of how regionalization
already occurs in various Health Care
populations I know whether it's from the
opioid crisis to just which hospitals
serve which communities
um I'm not the best person to draw those
boundaries but I would would be more
than happy to research that and make a
determination to regionalize that to
some level but I'll admit that didn't
occur to me until you asked the question
and I apologize because it's a great
point
thank you
and representative Shapiro on mute and
how about it thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Schultz
um
I'm assuming that the
kova dashboard currently is set up and
run
um
by health and human services without the
help of the University system is that
correct it's my understanding that the
university plays some level of a role
I'll be honest that I don't know the
details
um actually I think a member of your
committee might be able to answer that I
might be wrong on that
um but uh that was my attempt to make
sure that those working on the database
uh had a level of impartiality that
um
could possibly exist with this with the
university system uh to be impartial
uh
anyway basically repeating things I've
already said but it's my understanding
that UNH uh plays a role already if I'm
wrong on that I apologize
um
and I know I'm gonna go back to the way
it's worded in here representative you
may be interested to know that Trisha
Tilley from DHHS is next up to speak
she may be able to address a number of
those things
outlining a number of things I found
very helpful and I wish I had connected
with her when I was writing the Bill
so that's a good point follow-up uh
follow up yes okay I will wait for that
information from the next speaker
um
I I have a question about the committee
which is while I really like the fact
that it's very
well maybe very is not the right word
but it's narrow in that it's it's
supposed to address
um
disparities in care and treatment during
the
um covid pandemic
I think that's a good thing do you know
if there are is or are going to be
committees or commissions that
have a more overarching
um
effort to just evaluate our whole
response to the pandemic
I don't know the answer to that question
I will be honest that when the bill was
being drafted and I started working on
it in October and November this was a
concern that was being raised by
minority Health Advocates and because of
that I wanted to include it I believe
that the executive branch has now some
time ago now addressed
and released data on some aspects of
this
if I could rewrite the bill today which
we can amend it and I'm very open to
amendments I would maybe rework this to
be to include that as a
item of study as well as a review of
what what worked well and what didn't go
well with our data dashboard and where
were we able to successfully keep folks
safe and make good decisions for their
communities or schools or businesses and
what what can be improved for the next
pandemic representative Schultz when I
introduced a bill to a committee uh
three weeks ago I had the good liberal
arts broad 50 000 feet up in the year
top down looking approach which is sort
of my world view anyway and I suggested
to the chair that since the person from
one of the Departments knew way more
about the details than I did could I
turn my time over to that person and
then perhaps come back for a little few
minutes at the end and that was allowed
would you would you be uh comfortable if
I asked Tricia Tilley to speak next As
Long As I give you a lasted bat I am
always uh very eager to say when I don't
know something so please I would love to
hear from her go for it thank you thank
you for your cooperation and could we
bring in Trisha Telly please
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Patricia Tilley and I am the deputy
director of the division of Public
Health Services here in New Hampshire
DHHS so the department truly appreciates
the concerns the sponsor brings forward
and and I think what I would like to do
today is seek to provide some additional
information about our dashboard and the
efforts that we've had to address the
health disparities to supplement any of
the additional testimony that you're
going to hear today Above All We Share
the common goals of data transparency
sunshine and and most importantly the
Improvement of Health outcomes for all
Granite Staters and we agree
wholeheartedly that the data is
critically important so let's talk about
the dashboard so DHHS has had a covid-19
dashboard available to the public for
much of this pandemic it's updated daily
and is actively used by the public and
the media the bill is in alignment with
much of our current practice with some
notable exceptions so first there's a
reference as we've just been talking
about to the university system of New
Hampshire the university system is
currently provides us with timely data
and they are a great partner but the
website itself is not necessarily a
collaboration UNH is developing their
own dashboards and we link to them from
the schools dashboard to gather
information that we provide but we
partner with an existing vendor to
actually do the development of the
dashboards and ultimately the dashboard
is managed solely by the Department of
Health and Human Services
to some of the other points in the bill
we have not created specialized tabs for
nursing homes prisons congregate living
but we do have a number of ways right
now that individuals can track long-term
care facilities
and it is possible that we could
consider how we could provide other data
that in ways that are useful to the
public while protecting privacy I think
that's the that is the balance that we
have had throughout this entire pandemic
of being transparent and protecting
privacy at the same time
and you know to the point around vaccine
data we I think we all understand the
value of tracking that data to ensure
that our vaccines are delivered fairly
and equitably and currently we provide
information on Fridays as part of our
daily DHHS updates some of the important
demographic information that the bill
describes such as race and ethnicity
however is unlike is likely to be
incomplete right now in part because of
the CDC vam system we use doesn't make
that a required field
the committee has likely seen that on
our covid-19 interactive Equity
dashboard that has been available since
we launched our interactive dashboard
and even prior to that one we just had a
static piece of data on the site we
always had some information about race
and ethnicity inequity but on these tabs
right now on the interactive Equity
dashboard tab you can see that race and
ethnicity is only available right now
for about 61 percent of cases and we've
been actively working with those that
submit specimens for testing to us to
improve that rate it takes a village to
create the data that you see here it
takes information from the people who
submit the data to make sure that that
is clear and accurate it takes the work
that we have within our department and
within our vendors to then turn that
around and make sure that it is it's
this it it provides the sunshine that I
think we all are interested in
and to representative Weber's Earth
Point early on we are very focused on
how to protect privacy so that there can
be no constructive identification
especially by wraith or ethnicity as you
get down to those smaller geographical
regions
throughout the pandemic we have used the
data that is available to us to build a
dynamic and responsive dashboard that
meets the needs of state agencies
Community organizations and the public
creating a specific statute may run the
risk of pigeonholing our limited
resources and it may require elements
that were currently unable to share
again thinking about things like privacy
there may be other ways however that we
can continue to evolve what is presented
so that it paints a more comprehensive
picture
and I'm just going to note that Dave
Wieters who is our director of
Information Services is also available
to answer any of your technical
questions about the functionality of the
covet dashboard
but let me just sum up by thinking about
the equity and health disparities
legislative committee that is suggested
and I think we have similar common goals
and concerns in this area for
redirecting time and energy from other
similar ongoing efforts to begin I just
want to say that we know that Health
Equity means that everyone has a fair
and just opportunity to be as healthy as
possible covid has put a spotlight on
communities that have not been equitably
served by our health care and our Public
Health Systems in the past and the
existing cracks in the foundation have
really only widened DHHS has used our
data and the lived experience of our
partners to focus on Health Equity and
the disproportionate impact of covid-19
within certain New Hampshire communities
this work has occurred not only within
our covid response team but throughout
the entire department ensuring that we
can better serve both the health and the
social service needs of all New
Hampshire residents
DHHS has provided leadership to the
governor's covid-19 Equity response team
and is actively beginning to implement
many of the strategies within the
governor's covid-19
initial report and recommendations there
that Equity Response Team report and
recommendations
we target specific Outreach for testing
and vaccine for black and latinx
communities including our new Americans
that live right here in Concord or in
Manchester in Nashua we're committed to
a 10 allocation for vaccine for
disproportionately impacted populations
as identified by Community Partners and
through a a database called the covid-19
community vulnerability index
the Department of Corrections has been a
strong partner and our team has worked
closely with counties to investigate and
mitigate Transmission in county jails
and nursing homes
so with regard to both the dashboard and
Equity strategies we hope that any
legislative efforts would support and
Not Duplicate or redirect the
Department's current focus on data
transparency and our focus on health
disparities
DHHS is very open to suggestions and
feedback for improvement the dashboard
and all of our work has been an
iterative process that has evolved over
time but it's unclear right now if
codifying the requirements of the
dashboard and statute would actually
give us the needed flexibility to be
responsive as the pandemic evolves
a new legislative committee may not be
necessarily duplicative of existing work
but it may have limits on the lived
experience and the diversity of the
makeup you know of that group it might
be more impactful to create a more
permanent version of the equity response
team so that broader voices can maybe
engaged to improve safety and reduce
disparities so I think I'll wrap up by
saying we look forward to working
together to achieve the common goals
that we all share right now and I'm
happy to answer any questions or to
defer to my friend David Wieters who is
far more the technical expert than I am
so thank you chair
thank you
and thank you uh Miss Tilly uh
representative soloway
uh thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
we can uh thank you so much I'd like to
direct your question to representative
Schultz representative Schultz thank you
so much for your efforts uh in this
regard
um just to let you folks know that uh I
and other members of this committee sit
on the governor's task force on covid
and reopening we hear from Ms Tilly at
every one of our meetings we go over the
dashboard at every one of our meetings
so I'm very familiar with how that
dashboard operates and it's a genuine uh
value uh to those of us who are trying
to make decisions
um I I wonder representative Schultz if
we look at that dashboard not as a
single event but as one of many events
in which the state is attempting to
Grapple with
epidemiologic issues
would you consider uh rewriting your
legislation
um to create either a commission on
information flow out of DHHS and the way
it is packaged or would you consider
remanding this to the uh oversight
committee on a DHHS I think there's
somebody you can speak to that committee
and ask the chairman of that committee
to create a subcommittee on information
flow out of DHHS
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Schultz
I would I would be interested in doing
that yes just to follow up on what he
requested the chairman of that group to
do I would be happy to do that I'm sorry
I walked on you representative Schultz
here you go Mr chair that is your
prerogative wow
thank you to your first point yes I
think I know enough to answer yes to
that to your second point I don't know
nearly as much about that as you do
um now that I know your level of
expertise I wish I had worked with you
from the beginning I just didn't know
um mm-hmm I'm glad legislators are
involved in this process because it
should we should be
I'm open to amending this uh any way the
committee feels would be of benefit
uh let me jump in again as the chair and
say that since all of our work has to be
done by March 11th and what you raise
are very very good points but require a
lot of comparison to what is being done
what could be done and so on would it be
helpful and this is your call that you
recommend to us to hold on to this bill
and retain it and work on it over the
summer and the fall so that what comes
out would be very much to everyone's
Advantage would that work for you
otherwise this has got to get done no
later than March 11th
I I do know representative Muse was
going to speak I'd hoped he was going to
be a co-sponsor of this I'd like to hear
what he says about that as well uh I
don't have an answer at this moment I
need to think about it good just
floating the idea representative Marsh
you're recognized to speak thank you Mr
chairman and uh uh thank you
representative for bringing this bill to
our attention my my question is mostly
to Patricia Tilley because I too agree
that that we need to be concerned about
health care disparities but uh uh I
Patricia Tilley and I uh and
representative Canuck all serve on the
State Health assessment State Health
Improvement plan Council and it is my
understanding that that Council has
significant resources to address Health
Care disparities and uh are you of the
opinion that that section of this bill
at least could perhaps be addressed
better in that ongoing Forum than in a
smaller Committee just for a single
purpose
thank you representative Marsh for that
for that question thank you and again
our work at the State Health assessment
and State Health Improvement plan was
affectionately known as Shaw ship
um to your point absolutely uh has it at
its heart to address those disparities
throughout the state
um specifically we have not focused on
covid related disparities
um within Shaw ship but it is certainly
something that is within the context of
that group to look at and to consider
um to my earlier point I think there are
a number of different groups that are
all interested in better understanding
um both what the health outcomes were as
a result of the pandemic and um and how
that might affect us moving forward as
we think about other
emergencies that might might come in the
future
I I thank you for that and I thank you
for all the improvements that you have
made to the dashboard over the time that
representative soloway and I have been
serving on the reopening uh task force
and the various briefings that you've
given us I think that you've given us
increasingly more data as time goes by
and I truly appreciate that
thank you sir the chair recognizes
representative Cannon
thank you Mr chair and um
thank you Ms Tilly and actually and even
um
uh Christine
um my question has to do with
um how to how do we identify the sources
of information to be provided for the
dashboard I sit on a Somersworth school
board and we've been trying to build our
plan to bring students back to school
and some of our members have acquired
information from other towns and even
from Somersworth and when they take a
look at the the dashboard associated
with the school system
um
it doesn't seem to be up to date with
the information that's needed even
Somersworth data was not up to date so
do we have a regular source of
information in each of the towns and
cities to provide this information
thank you very much representative
Cannon you're asking a really important
question
um and the answer is it's very complex
and there are multiple sources of data
um that fill each of the different
components of um those tabs that we see
right now on the interactive dashboard
I'm going to start off and talk a little
bit specifically around school and then
I will also defer
um to David Wieters who's the director
of our information Services who will
clean up any inaccuracies that I might
have I'm not the technical expert in
this space but let me start off by
simply saying in schools one of the
things that we are um I'll actually even
back up even further so one of the
things people might want to know is so
how do we know what's the data source
for the number of cases that we have
well that comes directly from the data
that we have from testing so it is a
requirement in the communicable disease
statutes that positive test for covid-19
are reported to the Department of Health
and Human Services so we receive all of
those positive
positive cases and that's what's
reported to us and that essentially
gives us that information about the
number of cases that we have and in that
there is further information so it will
give us the location of that person
their Town their residence and some
other demographic information to my
point earlier about even race and
ethnicity race and ethnicity is a
required aspect of that data and yet we
all know especially in the volume of
work that we've had right now sometimes
things are incomplete when we receive it
in and so I will often use the example
even about towns where people
um a town may even be incomplete as many
of us live in rural areas our mailing
address may not actually be our town of
residence and so that's an area where we
sometimes have some discrepancies
um and with further investigation we can
clean that up with the high volume of
cases we've had sometimes that
information we don't get to that quite
in the timely way that we would hope to
as we could possibly as we did back in
the summer when we had far fewer cases
for schools in particular this is where
it gets a little bit trickier because we
also need to know whether that child was
in person attending school at that time
so it no if my child is fully remote and
is not attending school in person but is
only attending school remotely they may
not show up in that school dashboard
because they were not actually putting
any other people in that school at risk
because they were home fully remote at
that time I'm going to pause and hand it
over to David Wieters and to for him to
provide any additional information that
I might have left out
well the chair would have to recognize
him for that to happen and the chair
indeed does that we recognize that we
recognize David Waiters
thank you very much my name is David
Wieters I'm the information Services
director for DHHS and I appreciate the
opportunity to address
this legislature thank you chair for
recognizing me
so I don't really have additional
information other than we are working so
one of the common
concerns that we've heard regarding the
school's dashboard specifically is
understanding the the school Community
versus the covid community transmission
potential at the school and there are
two different perspectives so I have a
student that goes to a school a school
in this in this wonderful State and he
is a fully remote student if he
were to come down with covid he would
not be shown up on the covid
transmission
schools dashboard however you would see
him in the community dashboard as a
potential Community transmission
perspective and so you still would see
him there
but understanding the perspective as a
parent I was looking to see well he is
still a student at the school so how
does he impact that student population
as a as a as a community member of that
school
so we are looking at expanding that
dashboard to show Active cases of of a
person that we are that is known to be
attending a school but then is fully
remote
so that you would still see the com the
population as the student population or
the the edu the the school population it
could be educator or administrative
staff but don't but for our purposes of
understanding Community transmission
within the school you would have that
alternate filter to say who is attending
or actually physically on site at a
school that could put my student or
educator at risk of getting covet so
there are two different perspectives so
we we certainly acknowledge the
perspective of wanting to see that my my
child is one of many students at at the
kirschard school district and how does
he reckon how is he recognized amongst
that so we continuously my purpose of
this testimony is to say we get that
feedback and we continuously evolve our
dashboards to meet those needs and we
are working hand in hand with the
superintendents within the schools as
well as the nurses to continue to convey
that information and evolve it
hopefully that helps clarify the school
specific but
if you have any other questions I'm here
to answer as possible that helps a bit
thank you
the chair recognizes representative snow
on mute yourself and address your
question to one of the now three people
I think my question was already answered
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative representative Weber
thank you Mr chair and I have a couple
of questions if I may uh I think the
first one is for Ms Tilly or it just
arises out of her testimony I'm
wondering as as one who wrestled
mightily with Vamps both on my own
behalf and on behalf of quite a number
of other people over over time how it is
possible that vams only captures 61
percent of ethnicity when you cannot get
the website to move unless you
appropriately enter an ethnicity
um and it's unclear
even to those of us who have a great
deal of of book learning at least that
you had to not only highlight your
ethnicity you had to move it via not
arrows but little tiny teeny tiny carrot
signs over to a blank box in order to
advance the
um program at all so how is it possible
that only 61 percent of people are
showing up
as identifying with one ethnicity or
another
thank you representative Weber so I
think I was unclear in my testimony that
61 is actually in reference to the data
that we show right now on our Equity
dashboard which is around Active cases
so in that case it is the data that we
receive from those who order the testing
or put forward that data through us that
it may not be fully complete so that's
where that 61 number comes from so I I
apologize for not being clear about that
in my testimony regarding vams and again
if with the chair's permission
um uh David Wieters can speak a little
bit more in detail about the ways in
which that data may come through and and
I agree it was a complex task to do that
sort of moving over of the race and
ethnicity
very easy as soon as you knew how may I
have a follow-up Mr chair yes you may
um it's it's actually it's a whole new
question but you may have a whole new
question thank you
um
my question I'm not sure which one of
these it's from for is I notice that we
report data regularly
um on towns and when we get down to one
to four we under five we say one to four
because we don't want to highlight too
specifically who may or may not be in
the spotlight in a particular Town
particularly small towns and it it it is
a mystery to me that we can why is it
that we can report data on the town of
Roxbury population 229
in the aggregate of course uh when we
cannot and we cannot report data in the
aggregate on the 424 public servants who
are members of the legislature
thank you for that I'm I'm sort of
processing how I I can answer that right
now I you know I can speak to the town
um and again we are working closely on
constructive identification and you're
correct we have we have a process by
which we do not respond we do not
provide detailed information you know
when the number is below five
um for lots of reasons one that may be
an unstable number but really in this
case it is more likely so that you
cannot do that constructive
identification
um in general
um we do not provide
um you know clustered info information
about particular clusters unless there
is a risk to the public so that is why I
I think I'll just end my statement there
and we can follow up um offline for
additional information
thank you and thank you Mr chairman I'm
I'm all set good anyone else in the
committee for the
gang of three
seeing none I call Representative David
Muse
Rockingham 29.
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee
I'm going to commit this a little bit
different than the way we've heard this
comment uh up until this point part of
my professional background is I'm a
former partner in the customer
experience practice of aeon Hewitt and
one of the things that I've had
experience with over the years is
actually creating dashboards and
applications that sit on top of a
complex database systems
and
one of the things I think that's really
important to keep in mind is that
um
my personal expertise uh does not have
to do with public health I think you
have members of the committee who have
uh a huge amount of experience in that
area that that is is not my thing
but what I'm trained to do is I'm re I'm
trained to recognize an expert system
um that's posing as public information
um and so so what I mean by that is that
um
the tendency of people who are experts
in any field is to create informational
resources that are useful to them uh and
to other people in their field
and one of the things that I think has
been left behind in this process uh has
been the fact that there are also School
administrators uh teachers parents
citizens uh everyday people who are
concerned about this information who are
going to this uh to this dashboard and
these other resources and really trying
to get answers to simple questions uh
one that I get all the time is how many
Active cases are there in Portsmouth
um so I actually can't get an answer to
that question on the dashboard what I
have to do is I have to go over I have
to kind of look underneath the graphic
of the State of New Hampshire on the
DHHS covet website and tucked in
underneath there are two links one to a
PDF file that has a map of the state and
all the communities with a number of
active cases listed beside it the other
is an Excel file
um I I think I'm the only person in my
community who's managed to find that so
far uh because I keep getting asked for
it over and over and over again and what
that points out is the fact that
we have one of the problems that we have
with a lot of the resources on this site
um is a fair amount of fragmentation
so while there are critical resources
that are aggregated on what we call the
dashboard there's a lot of other
important information that's not
included on the dashboard and so things
like cases and communities are one good
example and something that's actually
from from the purpose of a tools
dashboard
um you know you would think would be
very important too
um another area where I'll Echo
representative Schultz's observation is
it can be very frustrating seeing an
article in the newspaper that talks
about active covet cases in a school in
your District as a state representative
and that those cases appear on the
dashboard for four or five days
sometimes for until four or five days
later
um and I understand that there are all
kinds of reasons why that's happening
but the whole idea of having a dashboard
is to uh enable people to make what the
governor calls data-driven decisions uh
and when the data is not up to date uh
when it doesn't represent the true
status of things like Community spread
in a community then there's a question
about how useful it actually is and and
I'll give you an example in the schools
dashboard in particular
um on above the middle of January uh
there were days for the city of
Manchester when that when the dashboard
was showing no Active cases at all in
the Manchester school system however we
were getting information that there were
a ton of Active cases among children 18
and under in the city of Manchester
so the dashboard the dashboard if you
were if you were to go solely from from
the dashboard and you were looking at
the number of cases that are accounted
for in the schools you would get the
impression that covet has ceased to
exist in the Manchester school system
when the reality is is that as soon as
we start sending kids back to school
we're going to have cases and and that's
exactly what's happened not only in
Manchester but in a bunch of other
communities so one question is is this
data-driven dashboard really giving us
the information that we need in order to
be able to make decisions like this
another area where I'll kind of echo
what representative Schultz has said is
the information around vaccinations
right now is a huge gap
um once a week There's a vaccine
allocation summary that gets appended to
dhhs's daily summary
um and and essentially it's it's one of
the most cryptic things you'll ever see
I'm sure that there are members of the
committee who can look at it and tell
you exactly how to read it and exactly
what it is but when I look at it as a
citizen I'm wondering so how many people
in New Hampshire have actually gotten
the first dose you know what percentage
of people have been completely
vaccinated
how much vaccine that the state has
received has actually been put into arms
you know is it like half of it is it
three quarters of it is it almost all of
it you know and it's very very very
difficult to tell that from the
resources that that we have and there's
also no information on vaccine equity
so the governor has decided that it's
important enough to reserve 10 of the
doses that are allocated in Phase 1B for
people who are in communities that are
disproportionately infected but we have
no information about how much of that
vaccine has actually gone into the arms
of people in the disaffected community
so it's one thing to allocate the doses
and that's a nice thought and it's it's
something we absolutely should be doing
but the other part of it is is do we
have the data that allows us to
understand whether or not that is
actually happening
um and right now
um the data may be collected I don't
know I don't have this visibility into
that but what I do know is that when I
go to the resources that the state of
New Hampshire is designed I can't find
the answer to questions like that and
and I think that it's really critical
that we do have answers to questions
like that
um and with that uh with that I'll I'll
stop and if anyone has any questions I'd
be happy to to take them
seeing none
um uh Maura Condon has signed up to
speak in opposition
to the bill and we will get to her as
soon as I call on representative Shapiro
thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you representative Muse
um
so we have a bill before us that does
certain things and then we've had a lot
of testimony with various levels of
critique about the job that the
dashboard is doing currently so I would
ask you given your particular critique
of some of the shortcomings
what in this bill
or what possibly in an amended bill
would address some of those shortcomings
well first of all I want to say that I I
do agree with the study commission I
think that that is something that it's
it's absolutely essential when we're
past this to be able to look back on it
and to and to to learn from our
experience and to make sure that we get
that down uh so that when the next
pandemic comes along and and uh and it's
inevitable inevitable that one will
um we have that information we've done
the work
um it's it's it's wonderful that we were
able to create a resource on the Fly and
and I know that there are people who are
working very hard to continuously
improve that resource so
one of the things that I would say is to
me one of the most critical the most
critical part of the bill is actually
looking at this study commission I'm I I
have uh I have reservations about
retaining the bill as a whole because
um hopefully everybody's going to be
vaccinated and it might might be by the
time that a study committee is actually
able to meet you know to to do this so I
I question whether you know how much
we'd be able to to get accomplished if
there was one thing that I would pick uh
to put in the dashboard that's not there
now it's much better information on on
vaccinations I I wish we had better
information uh as we were dealing with
the long-term care crisis in our nursing
homes
um 75 of the deaths in our state have
occurred in nursing homes and the
information on the nursing home
situation is very fragmented and again
some information is available on the
dashboard but the weekly case updates
are only done one once a week in PDF
form appended to a daily summary so the
information has been kind of all over
the place and it's not easy to get a
full picture of what the situation is
what I would like to see us do is I'd
like to see us sort of learn from that
and say okay how can we repeat not
repeat the mistake of not having done
that earlier with long-term care and and
how can we accelerate what can you know
at this critical point for vaccination
how can we make sure that um that better
information on vaccinations is available
on the dashboard that would be the
number one priority I would suggest
thank you
thank you Mr chairman you're muted
chair would now like to call on Laura
Condon
good afternoon
good afternoon oh good you can hear me
okay well good afternoon Mr chairman and
uh committee members my name is Laura
Condon I'm from Bedford I'm a volunteer
New Hampshire director of advocacy with
the national vaccine information center
and I speak today in opposition to house
bill 492. but first I would like to say
that I thank representative Schultz for
her efforts on this bill and
specifically for bringing forth
constituent concerns I think that is one
of the the greatest services that you as
state reps provide is being our voices
for those members of the community and
for that you know I much appreciate your
your efforts
but I do know while we are currently
experiencing covid-19 pandemic and there
are emergency orders that have issued
been issued to provide for emergency
actions this bill proposes to put
certain reporting requirements into law
as a permanent feature this would not
allow for modification of action in
reporting as a pandemic weakens and this
becomes an endemic illness more typical
of influenza for which we do not have
these types of extensive reporting
requirements as are proposed here
I would say that DHHS has done a good
job of providing covid-19 information
and details and updating it regularly on
their coveted website and being
responsive to public concerns about any
sort of inadequacies of that data or
request for additional information and I
think leaving that data reporting
decisions to the department allows for
the flexibility that is needed to report
what is needed what is useful and when
it's needed and when it's useful
there there are there is a call for
specific data here that concerns me and
I would caution against the section
calling for tracking vaccination metrics
by age raised Town ineligibility
category it's concerning for a number of
reasons in particular would involve the
collection and sorting of personal
information and their obvious privacy
improved security concerns
the CDC and DHHS have already made
recommendations on who might want to get
a covid vaccine we do know there's
categories A1 and B and such
not everyone can safely get a coveted
shot and not everyone wants one
these shots are a treatment offered to
minimize symptoms for those at greatest
risks they have not been shown to
prevent infection or reduce the spread
of infection treatment options are
important to have it's never one size
fits all
reporting of vaccination rates to the
public Broken Out by various locations
the demographics is not particularly
useful to the public
historically the purposes of such
collection and posting of data is to
coerce individuals to submit to
vaccination
covet injections remain in the
experimental phase under emergency use
authorization and are not FDA licensed
and this fact should be recognized and
appreciated
were this data to be compiled and
presented it would be important to also
include some of the data on the injuries
and deaths being reported and a link to
the beer's reporting system
DHHS already knows how many coveted
shots have been received in the state
and how many have been injected
aggregate vaccination rates are
typically published information by DHHS
without a statutory requirement to do so
I don't believe that's appropriate at
this time to be permanently collecting
sorting reporting data to the extent
that's called for in this bill although
again I do appreciate very much
representative Schultz you know actions
in bringing forth constituent concerns
but I do ask that this bill be
appropriately considered for an Ito
recommendation thank you very much for
the opportunity to speak
would you take any questions if there
are any certainly if there are
well thank you for being willing you get
extra points for that
thank you you're welcome
well that's it folks and uh we have no
one else signed up to speak and so
really the question the opportunity I
like to give is to the build sponsor to
say are we ready and when we exec it is
it good to go as it is do you wish to
make changes and if you do just remember
they got to be done on the fast
thank you Mr chair I will say I have the
time and inclination to improve this
bill I think the feedback I gained from
Testament the other testimony and from
the questions and comments from the
committee I think that it should be
amended
um open to doing that in a way that uh
the majority of you would like and I
will be calling many of you uh I did
also send an email so if any of you
would like specifically to make sure
that I call you uh you can reply to that
email and
um I just thank you for your patience
this you are the experts uh and um
saying anything more would just prolong
this and I appreciate your time
and we'll be looking forward to what you
present to us so thank you for coming
thank you and with that I close the
hearing on Bill 592.
Representatives Solway has asked the
chair for a brief
point of personal privilege
and so the chair calls on representative
soloway
the chair also calls on the
representative to unmute
there
is that better much better okay
um thank you for the opportunity to
speak uh I'd like to speak under
unanimous consent for uh just a few
minutes
I want to put our current discussions of
a number of bills in a historical
perspective
um about
um boy
over 20 years ago
um it was a book published by a science
writer named Lori Garrett that book was
called of the coming plague
and in it Laurie Garrett who is just a
superb science journalist
um reminded us that we are in the midst
at that time in the late 20th century
now in the 21st century in the midst of
not a disease
but a series of waves of disease
that have assaulted us
as a species for quite a long time
you can go back to the turn of the uh
20th century you can go back to the
Spanish Flu you can take a look at
tuberculosis through the 1940s until we
invented the mycins some of you may even
be old enough to remember
polio coming through New England in the
1950s and if you think through your own
ex lived experience
and you think through the Advent of HIV
HPV
the threats of uh SARS sudden acute
respiratory syndrome
um the threat of Ebola coming
um if you think through the Advent of
MERS Middle East Respiratory Syndrome
and now here we are wrestling with a
whole new not a coronavirus but a family
of coronaviruses that are mutating and
they're mutating dare I say faster than
we can develop effective vaccines to
deal with them
and what is lurking on the horizon that
you probably don't know about is a new
virus that has shown up in Asia Nipa
virus
a new strain of Avian Influenza that has
shown up a renewed strain of Middle East
Respiratory Syndrome all of this is
coming our way so Laurie Garrett in the
coming plague alerted us to the fact
that we were seeing waves of virus waves
of bacteria that
we probably had not seen before not only
that if you look out there you may be
aware that here in this country we had
an epidemic over the last couple of
years of whooping costs which we hadn't
seen in decades
um
and you will be pleased to know that
Ebola
is back
we have an outbreak in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo that's new this
week so you have to see that I need to
tell you that Laurie Garrett as I
mentioned is a brilliant science writer
and she wrote a follow-up book and the
follow-up book was called
betrayal of trust
and in it rather than simply looking at
the Advent of these diseases
she looked at our Public Health efforts
around the world to contain these
diseases
and what she said was in this book
we have trusted CDC who
National governments state governments
local governments to protect human
populations from these diseases and that
trust
has been betrayed
we have not been successful we have not
built the systems
to control the arrival of these diseases
and my friends here we sit in the middle
of a covid pandemic
and you know that before this is over
we will have half a million dead
from covet or covid Associated illness
in this country it's here it's now you
have lived in South quarantine for a
year
and the question becomes what do we do
now
now I want to tell you
that um I mistrust government
and I know that's an odd sentiment for
everybody on this committee
that said tongue-in-cheek
um
I value my privacy
I value my right to make decisions about
my own health
I have no use for government intervening
in the relationship between patient and
practitioner I believe that that is
sacred on all counts
I am a weary Watcher of immunizations
and public health interventions
generally
uh if you feel that I am speaking
without expertise let me tell you that
the first volume on preventive medicine
ever published for healthcare
professionals called the course book in
healthcare delivery was written by
me
the first volume on Health Care Delivery
Systems for healthcare professionals
introduction to Health Care Systems was
written by
me
two further volumes on epidemiology was
written were written by
me
I've been there I understand Public
Health I understand how it works so now
my friends I have to balance
my
doubts and mistrusts about government
intervention in my life the lives of my
constituents I have to balance that with
what I see as a looming Public Health
threat and I have to ask is this a time
when we need to suspend our doubts and
when we talk about permitting
pharmacists to expand the numbers of
health professionals to deal with health
threats when we talk about entering data
into databases as to who has been
vaccinated and who is not I'm at the
point where in order to make a decision
on all of these I now must fall on the
side of Public Health intervention
it's that looming it's that dangerous we
need to make a very considered set of
decisions
and I have to suspend
my fears and doubts and my protections
for my own privacy and that of my
constituents my own protections for the
sacredness of the practitioner patient
relationship and I have to say no now is
the time when we are all together and we
must make our commitments to the health
of the community
as public health thank you very much for
listening I'm sorry to take so long but
it was terribly important
thank you my friend
you're always worth listening to thank
you
I'm going to open now a an exact session
on House Bill 617 that's not one of the
ones that's on the list but this should
go real fast
and as you know one of the things we try
to do here is come to
a good understanding we try to get good
work done and sometimes as I've been
instructed The Way Forward is not
necessarily by legislation it could be
by a remonstrance to a department
so we had 617 before us about food
safety training for child care workers
in communities and I had a wonderful
chat with representative Jan Schmidt who
you'll remember presented the bill to us
and more importantly she's had a
wonderful conversation with the good
folks over at DHHS
Fanfare is appropriate and her
suggestion to us
is that the bill should be itl'd and as
one who italed or recommended itl of one
of my bills to this committee uh
recently a year or two ago uh we're
happy to do that so she suggests on this
bill that it is not necessary what she
wanted to have happen is happening now
and so therefore the bill is moot
um
I if there is no discussion on that
representative Weber
having also received a communication
from representative uh Schmidt I would
move itl on uh six one on six one seven
and I would if there is a second like to
speak to my motion
um I already actually I have already
moved it and I've written the blurb and
disseminated the blurb uh pursuant to my
conversation but if you would like to
Second it representative Weber I'd
appreciate that would you no name
was that yes
I said no need
um it's it's a little unusual for the
Cure to be moving the bill but it's
perfectly acceptable thank you and do we
have a second
all right representative Marsh now
anybody wish to discuss it further
seeing no further discussion than when
she is ready the clerk may call the rule
but I also remind the members that they
will have to turn their videos on in
order to vote
turn on your video
and appear so uh wait wait wait we got
Betty gotta get Betty on
there we are okay we're right here
okay the motion is itl on Bill 6 hb617
representative Marsh
votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yeah
representative Folsom yes representative
Kelsey yes
representative King yes representative
cook fault yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
snow
representative snow
yes thank you representative Knuck yes
Representatives Holloway
Representatives Solway
uh you need to unmute
representative soloway
yes thank you thank you representative
Canada yes
representative Nutter upper yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant
yes and representative Pearson yes
it is
21-0 I trust there's no objection to
consent
seeing none
the in our exec session here the next
one under consideration
is 604
expanding the New Hampshire vaccine
Association to include adult vaccines
and uh
may I have
emotion on the amendment first I'm
reading
my notes Here uh representative canurk
this yep go ahead thank you very much
yes I would like to move Amendment
2021-0230h
do we have a second
representative Makai okay please speak
to the amendment
thank you very much
well there's really a lot to say about
the bill itself I'll confine myself here
to the amendment
it's important to note that although no
representatives of pharmacies testified
at either the 2020 hearing or the 2021
hearing
sorry
Representatives thank you go ahead go
ahead represent or the 2021 hearing
during this year representative Merchant
kindly pointed out that the
reimbursement to pharmacies through the
pharmacy benefit manager was really not
well captured enough in the bill and the
amendment that I introduced in the
hearing
so as a result a few days later
representative Merchant Tyler Brannon of
the New Hampshire insurance department
and I met together to craft Amendment
site-0230h which is identical to the
amendment that I introduced at the
hearing with the exception of some new
language in the amendment on page two
from lines 17-35 which would protect the
pharmacies by ensuring that they would
be reimbursed for administering an
injection at a rate similar to Medical
providers
we use language adjuster by Tyler Bannon
of the commercially reasonable value
which is available from the New
Hampshire insurance department for every
CPT code
the amendment also protects the insurers
from being billed twice for a vaccine
since they've already paid for it once
in the assessment and then language was
added again at uh Tyler Brennan's
suggestion to provide for dispute
resolution between the insurer and the
provider using the same mechanism as the
balanced building statute
subsequently representing Merchant
informed me that the pharmacies were
still not satisfied so eight days ago he
nicely convened a meeting of all of the
stakeholders including the pharmacies to
develop a new Amendment
during this meeting it became clear to
me that the chain Family Pharmacy is
really simply don't want to participate
in this program so we crafted another
amendment that divided the providers
into either participating or
non-participating using reimbursement
ideas and language from the pharmacy
representatives and this really was a
pretty big compromise with the
pharmacies as doing this actually
lessens the savings of the adult program
by decreasing the size of the pool
because as representative Merchants said
earlier today the pharmacies are doing
about 30 percent of the adult vaccines
so that final language was circulated to
the parties involved that night asking
for response within a day but none of
the pharmacy Representatives responded
over the next two days so in the
interest of time I went ahead and
submitted that Amendment and then a few
days later representative Merchant and I
had our daily telephone call and he
informed me that pharmacies were still
not satisfied and subsequently the
insurers noted some concerns that the
compromise gave away too much so I'm
actually kind of bringing forth
the Goldilocks Amendment the first one
was a little too cold the last one a
little too hot but Amendment zero two
three zero for right now at least is
just right
now it's important to realize that
Department of Health and Human Services
the New Hampshire vaccine Association
America's health insurance plans New
Futures and I revised multiple parts of
the 2020 bill over the course of the one
and a half months this fall to develop
the 2021 bill
we kill we still have three more months
to fine-tune a new Amendment if needed
regarding Pharmacy participation on this
bill
that'll be as it goes through the second
house committee and through the Senate
before the Senate needs to act in early
June
we remain open to continue to negotiate
that degree in terms of the pharmacy's
participation in the program as we go
forward but such negotiations do not
require retain the bill as this is
really the only issue that still needs
to be resolved and delaying it
particularly for those freshmen may not
understand this delays its
implementation for a full year because
it works done in the summer it doesn't
even come into consideration until next
January
we really should be able to achieve this
final language if necessary before it
even gets to the second Committee of the
house additional amendments are
frequently brought forth to a bill as it
goes through the subsequent committees
so
bottom line is I urge you to vote to
accept Amendment 023h oh sorry
0230h and then devote otpa so we can
move this bill on to the next committee
and again I'll continue to work with the
pharmacy to finally come up with
languages that they will be happy with
um and which will represent significant
compromises from the other parties but
which hopefully will give us at least a
70 percent of the loaf instead of a full
loaf if you will
um thank you very much will you take
questions on your Amendment
of course
we just got to find some
representative Merchant
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative for taking my
question
in regards to looking at this
what it's requiring is for the pharmacy
community
to utilize a system creative for the
medical office community
and not for the pharmacy Community I
think the concern that's still there
is that we're taking a square peg and
put it in a round hole it was not
so people understand the medical
community now participates in the
vaccine for Children's Program
so therefore by adding adult vaccines
onto an existing program
is just building on something already in
existence
by taking something that is outside of
normal operations for a pharmacy
regardless of the reimbursement model
it still makes it difficult
cumbersome for the pharmacy Community
utilized
I looked at the immunize Colorado and
they cited also that a major obstacle
for the pharmacy Community to
participate in a program like this
was the financial burden but also the
administrative burden
that you're going outside of a
well-oiled
supply chain that works very well
and then trying to have them utilize a
state program and we could look to covid
he will now look into the pharmacy
Community because the system they
utilize is very efficient and very
effective so regardless of the
reimbursement model the concern that's
there is the system that we're going to
require the pharmacy Community to
utilize
doesn't work
it doesn't work within the pharmacy
Community itself
and I can tell you from personal
experience having worked with that
system
the delays in getting vaccines you
cannot transfer a vaccine from one place
to another you have to report the
temperature in the refrigerators which
is redundancy and so forth I still see
what I'm starting to get to foreign
as much as I look at this amendment
going the right direction it's not there
I did send out to the committee for
their review just shortly another
amendment which we talked about which
would carve out the pharmacy Community
today
which is 66 percent of the loaf
work with the pharmacy Community going
forward
and then build on the rest of them
so that we can capture the full loaf
but I think without the pharmacy
Community buy-in and support my concern
is that throughout the country
pharmacies do not participate in
state-run programs unless for the
uninsured so I just want to alert people
that I want to say thank you
representative Canuck for what you're
doing with the amendment I think
fundamentally it doesn't really solve
the underlying problem and that is we
have a system that was not created for
pharmacy for asking them to utilize
may I respond you may
um fair enough I I was actually going to
address some of those issues but I
thought they were more germane to the
issue of passing the bill itself rather
than the amendment but I'll go ahead and
address them here
um first as I noted we I had a remember
and I brought forth which would carve
out the Pharmacists and the uh I have
seen representative Merchant's Amendment
the difficulty with that is that it
requires shifting to a retrospective
assessment and the current assessment is
a prospective assessment
this program has been in place for over
15 years working extremely well and with
that in mind trying to completely change
it over to a different system just
didn't make sense and the amendment that
we came up with that I thought it the
pharmacist would be happy with because
they were at the table when we developed
it
um really gave away a lot and did allow
them to be non-participating if they
wished to do so there were still some
questions regard from the pharmacy
Community about
some of the issues about reimbursement
which could conceivably just be simply
stripped from that Amendment and they
would just be able to either participate
or not and that would work with the
current system far better than would the
uh representative Merchants Amendment
which would be you know reasonable if we
were starting from scratch with a new
system but not when we already have an
existing system
um
if you will if you wish I could go ahead
and address these other questions about
the supply chain and what the pharmacist
burden would be at this point in time
and perhaps I should because it was
brought up
um it's important to realize that the
comment that no chain drug stores
because you all you all got a letter
from the lobbyist for the Coalition for
New Hampshire chain drug stores I think
it was just yesterday or day before and
the problem is it reflects a lack of
understanding how the program works
he said that the chain drugstores
couldn't participate in a meaningful way
well they certainly can and we want them
to he talked about concerns about how
the state stores and distributes
vaccines but that's not a real concern
the state does not store the vaccines
the vaccines are shipped directly to
their Provider from McKesson who's the
federal distributor and it is not at all
like the trouble played covet vaccine
supply chain
it is an entirely different issue the
current system really works
exceptionally well the small practice
that I worked in in Conway
as I spoke to both of our pediatricians
about this they have been extremely
happy with the program they have never
ever had a problem with supply chain
problems
the comment was made in that letter and
also by representing immersion that Jane
drugstores aren't doing the for example
in this state the vaccines for children
program but that's not really surprising
because the pharmacies are not allowed
to vaccinate children in New Hampshire
except for flu so they wouldn't be able
to have participated in it even if they
chose to at least at this point in time
as far as the burdensome requirements
for storage of federally supplied
vaccines it's important to realize that
those CDC requirements
our reason actually just simply best
practices to assure safe storage of
vaccines so that they're safe to use
and they're effective when they're given
because poor storage can lead to either
complete loss of thousands of dollars of
vaccines or a loss of potency of
vaccines which could then be unknowingly
still be injected I would say that if
the pharmacies aren't following those
best practices they maybe should and I
would also again note that the small
practice I worked in in Conway with only
two pediatricians handles it just fine
they don't have any trouble
so the other thing was about you know
moving vaccines from one place to
another
um though that can be done I confirmed
that with Dr Beth the other chief of
infectious disease Bureau they're the
ones that administer this program she
stated that in the current program
providers can transfer vaccines as long
as they document the transfer
so the point is I do appreciate that we
have not reached a final uh conclusion I
mean that's that's obvious guys
everybody knows that because rep Richard
and I are talking about this weekly
aren't agreeing but this is not a burden
which should take this bill and require
it to either die or be retained and go
through some process this summer and be
delayed by a whole year we can accept
this amendment as I said I did a lot of
rewrite on this in the fall over a month
and a half multiple meetings with
providers stakeholders I mean and we can
do and then probably the next two weeks
because I think rep Merchant and I have
really at this point pretty well
identified some of the issues and I
think we can fine tune a couple of
issues now and have an amendment before
it even gets to the second committee
that we probably would agree on again I
know that
New Hampshire vaccine Association new
Futures DHHS they really don't want to
have this program diluted and have it
with only 66 percent of participation
but everybody has to make compromises
and they may need to compromise on that
to satisfy the desires of the pharmacy
Community to just keep running theirs
separately and doing their own
negotiations and I certainly am
comfortable with making those kinds of
compromises but today if we decide not
to you know approve this
it just either dies or gets retained and
then has to sit around for another whole
year as Charlie McMahon likes to say we
need to get this done while we're still
young we can get this out of our
committee get it to the next committee
where they can where uh where Merchant
and I will continue to work with those
other stakeholders and get some final
language and if we never can get there
it'll get retained or italed and the
next committee or in the Senate and you
know Gary I want to keep working with
you we are still friends and we talk
every week every day usually
if I if I can say I I want to say this
to everyone here
um
I want to recognize the work that
this the sponsors put into this bill and
I'm not trying to to uh
to make it
un difficult for him or anyone else but
also at the same time if I know
something's got a flaw in it
and I let it go forward without dealing
with that flaw then my concern is we
have
the potential create legislation that we
could possibly cause a lot of issues in
the settings for access to vaccines we
just talked about how important the
access point is just to give you a heads
up
I talked to a board member in the state
of Vermont because Vermont also has an
adult program not one Pharmacy folks
participates in the program for children
or for the adult program
number two I looked at Alaska
I looked at all the registered providers
they have on Alaska on the website you
can go there and I'll send it to you
there's not one Pharmacy folks that's in
it
so I'm just cautioning people is that
the pharmacy Community is a very major
component of access to vaccines and
there's got to be a reason in the other
states that pharmacies have not
participated in the program number two
as far as looking at things
retrospectively versus prospectively
we could break it apart and saying if
it's a children it's done under the
current model but this is a new
opportunity for adults and saying going
forward to Department health Team
Services we build a different model for
the adults so therefore the insurance
companies
are basically utilizing two different
systems
in order to accommodate that and I think
what I'm saying to my friend on on my
own side of the aisle is that I don't
want to work with you but I just think
that this bill is not ready for prime
time
and I think to move it forward even out
of the committee until we have buy-in
from the pharmacy community and deal
with their concerns which I think are
significant it's not a logical thing to
do so I would vote to retain the bill
versus to uh pass the amendment but I
will pass the amendment because it's
better than what the bill has but I
would definitely vote against the bill
representative snow
you were unmuted now you muted yourself
my buttons don't work right I know that
a lot of ways it comes with age thank
you you're welcome to ask one of the two
of you probably representative can Eric
would be the best one to ask
he's basically saying that he agrees the
bill right now is not ready for prime
time but he thinks he can work on it
while it goes through another committee
and at that point we can still vote to
retain it if it's not ready but at this
point I say we ought to move it along
and and pass it because one of the
things if we can get it through this
year that saves a stage four million
dollars
which we're going to lose if we delay it
until next year so I would ask that we
do what we can to move it along at least
at this point and commit ourselves to
try to work out a a compromise that
meets everybody's needs
thank you am I correct in that
assumption but I have a point of order
Mr chairman yes you can
thank you
um
it is correct that if we move it forward
the bill
you muted yourself oh sorry
those buttons are tricky I'm I'm sorry
um I'm conscious of having intruded a
dog into the frame and the word into an
unmuted microphone earlier which I
apologize to the entire committee and so
I'm trying to err on the other side
um
my point of order was that yes if it is
moved on to another committee it can
then be retained but it will not be
retained by the Health and Human
Services committee it will be retained
by the finance committee and if
you think that the finance committee is
going to devote itself to the finer
points that we're talking about here
um You probably really ought to think
again
um I have a great regard for them but
that's not their Forte
um would this representative Weber go to
finance or finance division free
uh it would undoubtedly go to division
three because everything in finance goes
to a division uh I simply asked the
clerk where it was going in hopes that
it would go to Commerce which might have
been a much more
helpful place for it to go on issues of
both insurance payments and business
models because that's what Commerce does
it does not have a huge amount of Health
content of the sort that this committee
deals with but that is water that's gone
both under the bridge and over the dam
um
I'm going to say that I have listened
very carefully to both of my esteemed
colleagues and I esteem both of them
very much
um
but I've also done a great deal of
negotiation
and mediation in my life
and I think the likelihood
that this is going to get resolved in
the next two weeks is very very slim
um that's that's just my observation and
it is a concern of mine and I am
conscious of a growing concern arising
out of the concerns of new futures
uh about a number of the pharmacy bills
all of which are interrelated in
interesting ways
um but I'm
becoming more concerned about the
interrelation and getting it right so
um those are that's as far as I've gone
in my thinking so far and what I'm going
to do about it is another question but
in your experience and that was beyond a
point of order and I'm sorry for having
exceeded what I was recognized for but
we're going to ask soon anyway
um in your experience representative
Weber when things come out of the house
and go over to the Senate
there would be another chance to amend
this
happened
then of course it would have to go to a
committee of conference but we're not
done
when it leaves the house is that correct
that is absolutely correct
um I will also offer my observation that
the Senate often does not go into the
depth that house
committees do because they don't have
the time and the energy
and that they are far more receptive
um depending on the issue on the input
of lobbyists than on the input of say
a broad Coalition of expertise
who else would like to speak remember
this is an exact session it doesn't have
to end in a question but it could
representative canark
only if no one else okay yeah I will
um they were just actually I do have a
question and that is
after it if if it does pass through here
and it gets through the house
could it be vacated to go to from uh
finance and go to Commerce that's the
question the other one is just a point
and that's the pharmacies even under the
amendment uh zero two three zero
pharmacies can still choose not to
participate in the
current program it's not mandatory but
nearly everyone participates because it
works so well and so a pharmacy still
doesn't have to participate even under
this uh bill and the amendment as it is
sitting there so they could choose to
all say we don't want to play but I
would also say I've I've vowed that I
would not say oh gee got it through I
would continue to work with rep Merchant
uh until we really got something that
satisfied everybody and where everybody
gave a little bit and I think that we I
think we well I guess I'm more
optimistic than representative Weber I I
think we're so close and I can already
see a couple of the solutions of just
simply removing all the language about
the reimbursements that is in the other
Amendment which I didn't burden you all
with because it was too much and just
allow they're participating in the
non-participating and be totally silent
on the rest and just let those Market
forces of the pbms and the pharmacies
manage that and I think that was really
where the the pharmacy still had their
concern and then it achieves just what
representative Merchant wanted and that
is that they don't have to participate
they they aren't affected and so I I
think let's ask him that's I know my
other people I know my other people that
are working with another side are not
going to be happy with me for saying
that because they're going to be giving
up a lot but that's the nature of
compromise and so I you know I I'd vow
to work on that I would not let it drop
representative Merchant would you care
to respond if you wish yes but I can
progress the referral issue first
sure yeah go ahead
um it can't be referred to a third
committee because we have deadlines
oh I didn't mean third I'm in place of
uh
I think that there is okay that's fine
way to do that at this point
okay
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chairman
in regards to the pharmacy
they can voluntarily participate or not
participate the challenge though if they
do
part of the reason why we're trying to
use the state program is the state you
can buy the vaccine for 30 to 40 percent
below the fair market value so if we do
that for a pharmacy what we're asking
them to do is to submit a claim to the
insurance company at 30 to 40 percent
below the cost
so I go back to the same thing is that
why would a business
bill into the business model
something that's going to fill out at 30
to 40 percent of what they could buy it
at and take a loss on the vaccine
and then only have if you will the
administrative fee again one of the
things not to conflate things but it's
part of it at least in the provider's
office a provider can build for an
office visit a pharmacy cannot
um so it's not just a reimbursement
model that's part of it but it's also
the burdensome so we're asking them to
increase their potential cost of doing
business while we decrease their
Revenue stream coming into offset and
maintain a business model my concern
fundamentally is the pharmacy committee
is really wants to work to make this
thing
we just need to sit down around the
table with all of us and figure out how
to make it happen and I look at other
states throughout the country that have
not embraced this in a pharmacy
Community is not part of it and my
concern to this committee is that if we
lose the pharmacy Community which is a
possibility without getting the buy-in
support then would taking
dollars and saving dollars but we're
taking access points to patients have
utilized it conveniently and so forth so
it's a trade-off and saying we could
save a lot of money but then if we don't
have higher vaccination rates and we're
trying to do everything in our state to
increase vaccination rates not decrease
vaccination rates we know that they're
low we need to find more ways to get
vaccines in the patient's arms for all
the reasons that you do it and not
finding ways to just save money so we
have to balance the issue of trying to
save money with access and being sure
the patient at the end of the day do in
fact get the vaccines that they need not
just to save money representative knurk
yeah I I think first off the issue is
that if we say Hey you can either
participate or not if uh first of all
the pharmacies may have very good cheap
Supply chains too and if they can buy
the vaccine at a cheaper rate they're
still going to negotiate with the
insurance company for the rates they're
going to get paid that's their business
just like they do now
um
but the thing is if they can't get that
they might choose to use the state
program it's like any other business
decision you you weigh not just your
costs but your convenience you may say
gosh I can get it on Amazon two bucks
cheaper than this store down the street
but I can go down the store down the
streets this afternoon and it's in my
hand and you make that decision that
that value to you is worth paying that
extra couple of bucks here because it
drives traffic into the store and there
are the things they may say yeah I lose
a buck or two on it but it's for on a
particular vaccine but I want to do that
because it helps me in my bottom line
that's a choice you make and they they
can the goal of what I was getting at
was it would be a choice
it'd be their choice and so I'd be
comfortable that
um it is interesting to note though the
comment about increasing vaccine rates
um
it is I get my flu shots at the pharmacy
because I do like it I do like the
accessibility
um like if you're doing up getting
groceries it's kind of nice but it's
interesting I went back and dug up the
data on the adult flu shots because
that's about the only thing we have
where we have old enough data to see
what the trends are and in the period
the three years prior to us allowing
pharmacists to do vaccines for flu for
adults the vaccine the percentage of
adults 18 and older getting flu vaccine
in New Hampshire was 42 percent I didn't
count the year of transition because
that'll be fluky
but in the eight years following
allowing pharmacists to do it it was 44
with a variation between 38 and 49 which
means that we didn't actually see an
increased rate of vaccination in the
state we just saw a different point of
service now again that doesn't discount
that I get mine there I think it is a
convenience thing and I would agree with
it again what I get back to is if we
change it to the amendment I didn't
bring forward because the pharmacist
didn't like it
um I but I think we I still we could
work on that and get rid of out of the
language so they have total flexibility
the same they have now in terms of
negotiating with the pbms and the
insurers I mean between the pbms and
insurers if we did that
um they've got just what they have right
now we would not change anything for
them but if there's a small change of
sorry a small Independent Pharmacy if
they wish to participate they could hop
in and participate if they didn't wish
to they wouldn't we could also go to
just say no pharmacies but it wouldn't
give The Independents a choice to
participate because they haven't got
that same large supply chain as you know
CVS might have
um again these are not compromises I
wanted to make on this because we wanted
to keep the program big and robust but
if we have to I would be willing to do
that and knowing that the people I've
been working with will be unhappy with
me but knowing that it's something which
is the art of compromise so again I
since I think we're so close with just
that little bit of a language thing
because that was the major glitch again
answer to representative Merchant it
isn't I agree it's not just
reimbursement but they have the perfect
choice to either participate or not they
can keep things exactly as they
currently are by being non-participating
and the amendment a new amendment being
mute on the question of reimbursement
yes sir if pharmacist people
representatives were willing
would you do some all-nighters on this
because it's got to get out the door on
March 11th at the latest from uh Finance
three
oh yeah well I mean as I said we we met
a week ago well eight days ago I thought
we had reached a conclusion because on
the phone on the call the language I
adopted a lot of it came from uh and
fellows who was one of the pharmacy
representatives for one of the chains
and I thought that we had something we
agreed on
um unfortunately nobody got back to me
and so I didn't I submitted that
Amendment as it was
um and it just then I got information
that people were still unhappy with it
if we could negotiate in good faith
where we just communicate back and forth
we can get that done and I think we
really can I I guess I'm a big Optimist
I'm sorry but I'm an optimist
it's the only way to survive is a spine
surgeon you got to be an optimist you
know representative Merchant I was about
to ask representative Solway what
Solomon would do in a case like this
um or to quote somebody on a cop show
ladies you're both pretty I love you
both
um do you
do
yeah uh representative merchant do you
think that you with some Representatives
could do a an intensive work with
representative canark and if at the end
you can always say to finance division
three kill this sucker right
I think you could deliver some folks to
this meeting let me ask you this
question Mr chairman when I look at the
calendar what are we looking at out the
door today from this committee over to
finance division three out their door no
later than March 11th
I I concern myself with it going to
finance and working on it there because
the people in finance don't have the
expertise and the knowledge
um so I'm really kind of reluctant to
let it go out of the committee this
committee really is the one it's going
out of the committee it will be going
out of the committee no matter how it
goes out right unless we kill it I don't
want to kill the bill I'd rather
I'd rather retain the bill and let us
work on the bill and get all the parties
around the table I think one of the
things we talked about before is the
offer on the table to carve out
pharmacies at least temporarily for a
year will we build on certain things was
a fair thing to accomplish and at that
point in time what I heard from
representative canark in his
conversation with the vaccine program
that was not acceptable to them so uh
now actually may I clarify no actually
not true because it's going to be two
years before this program would be stood
up anyway there's going to be a lot of
preliminary work
um we can as we work in rules to begin
with but we could even have time
probably for another statutory bite at
it next year but I don't really think we
would need that I think the bottom line
is you know Gary and I could you know we
did work out of that Monday uh we can do
we did have all the stakeholders I mean
we don't need to process it in the
committee as much as Gary and I got to
get to work and and really get to work
with these stakeholders and just get to
the point where everybody can shake
their hand and be well we don't do that
in covet anymore shake their head on
zoom and say okay we're good to go and
then again if we can't we just have to
say Okay this is no good and and uh not
let it go I don't you know if we retain
it it's not the end of the world it's
just again we lost four million bucks
last year because it died a covet death
over in the Senate but uh because we
passed it out of the house
if we delay it again there's another
four million bucks you know we got all
excited in that uh in that recent uh
thing where we're going to get 3.3
million dollars over five years in that
settlement about the opioid stuff well
this is four million bucks a year
um that's not chicken feed and I'd like
to just get this bill going I think we
can get it I personally do all right I I
would like to say that unless anybody
really feel feels an existential need to
speak
we have the topic here either we vote
the amendment and the bill up and over
to finance three or we don't and if we
don't then I believe we can look at
another motion and I would really unless
anybody can convince me
um I would like to call a question
and the the question actually is on the
amendment
uh made by can Eric and super seconded
by McKay for Amendment zero two three
zero H and would the clerk please call
the rule it and it is to accept the
amendment so a Yes means accept the
amendment of no means we don't
okay if everybody could unmute that
would be great
um representative Marsh
um one second please we need to see
representative McMahon's face yes sorry
it's okay we're learning we're all
learning
we'll get it down and then we can all
meet in person thank you
everybody and representative
Makai and Shapiro and Nikki Kelsey and
we're uh good okay okay so
representative Marsh
on the amendment yes
representative McMahon yes on the
amendment representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes representative
gay yes representative Cushman yeah
representative Folsom yes representative
Kelsey on the amendment yes
representative King
Amendment yes
representative co-falt
no
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes
representative snow yes representative
nurse
yes representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes on the
amendment and representative Pearson yes
and that is a 22-1 vote
to accept the amendment
and now I need a motion and the courtesy
is to the sponsor of the bill for 604 FN
as amended representative knurk you have
a motion yes I would like to please move
H
ought to pass with Amendment sorry hb604
ought to pass with Amendment 2021-0230
H do we have a second second
and Makai second okay now we can discuss
but please let's not make it terribly
long
may I speak to the motion
um you may
uh speak to the motion yes and then
represent much of what I was going to
say I've already said because I kind of
moved it over to our discussion of the
amendment so I just want to remind the
goal of this bill then is really to
expand our currently successful
pediatric vaccine dog purchasing program
to the adult population
the bill enables the insurers to band
together so that they can both purchase
the adult vaccines the only reason the
DHHS has to get involved is to allow the
insurers to access the very low cost
federally discounted rate through the
CDC
because that's only available to
governmental units to remind you the
Pediatric program has worked well for
over 15 years allowing us to purchase
annually 38 million dollars of vaccines
for 28 million for a savings of 10
million dollars annually
and the study by New Hampshire insurance
department about the extension just for
the adults showed that the expanded
adults will save an additional 4 million
dollars over the claims paid costs of
vaccines for that group in addition to
saving money it will help Finance
vaccines to the uninsured
now the extension of this program is
actually Revenue neutral when you look
at the fiscal note it looks like it's
going to cost 366 thousand dollars but
it's red for new neutral because all
those administrative costs are recovered
dollar for dollar in the assessment on
the insurers to fully cover the cost to
the program
the overall Bill itself is actually
Revenue positive for the state because
as part of getting the insurers to come
on board for this they have agreed to
absorb the assessment for the
administrative costs for the Pediatric
program
which were left out in the Pediatric
Bill and that's about a half million
dollars a year so what we end up getting
is a savings to the state's budget of
five hundred thousand dollars a year
because those dhh costs get absorbed by
the insurers and and they in so doing we
get the four million dollars of savings
on the vaccines now the important thing
you realize is the the insurers don't
get to pocket that money it doesn't go
to their bottom line because insurers
are required by the medical loss ratio
calculations to continue to spend a
certain percentage of their premiums on
Medical Care the reduction in vaccine
costs which are medical costs will lead
to either premium reductions which is of
course never likely or more likely lower
premium increases in the future in order
to maintain that medical loss ratio and
I do need before voting to clarify a few
non-factual statements that came up in
the hearing and subsequent there was
confusion during the testimony on the
bill regarding the savings calculated by
the New Hampshire insurance department
a statement was made that that was a
comparison between the list price and
the federal discount rate that is not
true I sent it out to you again so you
could look at it and Tyler Brandon send
it to you as well it's the difference
between the actual claims paid by the
insurance companies
in other words it's already their
discounted rate and the federally
discounted rate so the four million
dollars are real savings and to remember
this bill does not mandate vaccines it
has nothing to do with the decision to
vaccinate that's between the patient and
provider it's only about paying uh we
already talked about some of those
inaccuracies from the letter that we got
a day or two ago
um and so I don't I'm just kind of
scanning down what I made a list of
things I think I covered most all of
those
um yes I did cover all those again
basically we can move the vaccines as
needed to handle shortages the
requirements for storage are the state
of the art
um and again if we do decide to move on
first of all it's already voluntary
according to the amendment we just
passed but if we want to make it even
clearer and cleaner that the pharmacists
are carved out we can do that and still
keep the retrospective assessment uh and
I would be happy to work continue to
work on that so again bottom line we
lost four million bucks last year due to
covid killing the bill if we retain it
we lose another four million dollars
obviously if we itl we lose formula
dollars in perpetuity any case but
the hell uh DHHS nhva American health
insurance plans New Futures and I really
I will solidly commit that we will
continue to work with representative
Merchant and the other pharmacists to
negotiate the degree in terms of the
pharmacy's participation as we go in the
other committees and I really do believe
we'll reach an agreement um but I guess
I'm I'm a Pollyanna
um and because we often bring forth
amendments to bills does it goes through
subsequent committees that's not an
unusual thing and again there's plenty
of time because this would not even be
operational until 2023 uh with rule
making and even more statutory work of
need to so I just urge you to vote this
bill ocpa
to move it out to the second committee
well we continue to fine-tune the
language and make that progress toward
annually saving four million dollars for
insurers and five hundred thousand
dollars for the state rather than delay
for another year we really have plenty
of time
thank you representative knurk the chair
called son representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um
I don't have much to say but I will say
that for so many years I've heard so
many of us talk about our frustration
with lowering health care costs relative
to the effectiveness of our Health Care
system and people blame each other and
um
people have different
um ideological points of view but
nevertheless there's just it seems
intractable
um endless frustration about health care
costs
um and I would say that after this
afternoon I understand why
um
so I am going to cast my vote
um to save a few dollars in health care
costs and put my faith in the optimism
of Representative knurk that an
agreement can be reached and this can
actually happen and we can save two to
four million dollars in this next year
thank you representative Folsom
um yes just a clarification I did not
get who was the second on the amendment
McKay and I just finished Mackay but
yeah I know you're talking about and uh
I did not
um have a second on
the amendment I know representative
knurk made the motion but I don't
remember hearing it also also it was
awesome okay thank you very much
plus Jerry we know where you live
and if you are not doing full complete
due diligence to help we're coming for
you brother
no problem I I you know as soon as I say
Gary and I we have been friends for four
years we will work on this and I know I
will make some of the people on the that
I on the other side unhappy because uh I
want to make this come to fruition even
if we only get 66 percent
yes you will representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
um
in regards to the amendment it's it does
go in the right direction although it
doesn't get to where things I think have
to get to
I would say this I've heard from pvm's
time and time again how much money
they're saving the healthcare industry I
have yet to see my premiums on my drug
benefits no matter how much money they
get back from manufacturers and rebates
so if you think I'm a little bit jaded
and pessimistic about not being quite as
optimistic as my colleague
um
that's where I am because in this
industry everyone talks about how
they're going to bring down the cost of
Health Care I have yet to see it happen
um so that's part of my concern number
two this bill doesn't take
into effect until 2023. so therefore if
you delay it a year on retaining it we
haven't really delayed it so we could
work on this bill over the time still
have it effective date on 2023 without
losing any Steam on the dollars we're
trying to save that's there and if I
know the pharmacy Community has Grave
concerns about this bill
and they have become a major player in
giving vaccinations to patients when I
then hit the big yellow caution button
put my foot on the brake and take my
foot off the gas and give the parties a
fair time and not work under the gun to
work and Hammer out something that's
works for everybody in a reasonable
period of time not trying to do it under
the pressure we're all under today and
make something work so my recommendation
of the committee is to not vote for the
bill even though it's been amended and
again to go back into retain it and let
the parties come together
in a reasonable period of time logically
and thoughtfully figuring out how to
make this thing work
representative clarification
just because it's a point of information
issue about that it's got to be really
brief it is the effective date is
actually when it's passed
no it's it's upon Passage the reason for
that is that allows them to start the
setup um if the effect takes the ACT
takes effect upon passage the idea is
that allows them to start setting it up
the bill was 2022 the amendment makes it
upon passage that was modeled after how
things went for example with the
therapeutic cannabis program we passed
that in 2013 but it was not until 2016
that all the pieces were in place this
requires a number of things that have to
be done on the stepwise sequential
fashion so we with the drafting attorney
we said effective immediately which
enables DHHS and nhba to start their
work but the issue is that they have to
first enroll people that's the DHHS part
then the nhva has to make the assessment
which occurs in the spring they gathered
up by June then they pay it off to DHHS
who then goes to purchase the vaccines
which are for the next year so the the
reason I say keep saying 223 is that's
not the effective date it's simply
that's how long it will take if we pass
it in 2021 before the program is
functional so if we do retain it it will
move it back to 2024. so it it really
will move it a year so sorry about that
but I wanted to be clear that where
those numbers come come from
representative Canuck and representative
Merchant one will write the positive
blurb one will write the negative verb
who is going to be whom we will see in a
few minutes but first we call on
representative March
thank you everybody I have to say that I
have found this debate confusing uh it
is not clear to me whether we're going
to actually save money for patients in
the state of New Hampshire it is not
clear to me whether we may save the
department money and then offset that
with higher health insurance costs uh it
is distinctly unclear but I can say one
thing for certain I'm not in the habit
of voting bills out of this committee
until we feel like we have a good bill
we have a reputation for passing really
good bills out of this committee and at
this point in time I'm afraid that I am
not convinced that we're having a good
product to the next committee and I
don't want to basically expect them to
fix our problems for us
representative Merchant
you have your hand up
I didn't lower it from the last time
sorry okay hey now this is the moment
we've all been waiting for
and the motion is ought to pass with the
amendment that we've cited
and representative knurk and
representative McKay or Makai and uh the
clerk when she's ready please call the
roll
motion
ought to pass as amended 604
um representative Marsh
well it's no
representative McMahon no
representative Nelson no representative
Acton no representative gay no
representative Cushman
representative Folsom no representative
Kelsey yeah
representative King no representative Co
Falls
no
representative Weber oh
representative McKay yes
representative snow
unmute and vote please Representatives
no it doesn't work yes sorry
representative knurk yes
representative Solway
investing
representative soloway has out of the
room
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant
no
representative Pearson
I love you both but no
and do and I do not see representative
Solway coming back to the absent
but they have to be in the room when the
question was put so they can't come in
halfway okay thank you
it is uh 13 yeah a nose
seven yeses and one absent
so it does not pass
representative Weber please help the
current chair who's still learning his
job is a subsequent Motion in order at
this point a substantive motion is
necessary at this point because we have
not resolved anything
and I make a motion Mr chairman yes you
may may a motion to retain the bill
in a second yes my little my friend yes
sure because we're going to be working
hard together this Summer that is going
to be uh oh that's just I know where you
live that's okay man I know where you
live too I will be working on zoom over
the summer I think so and there's 19
people who are going to hold you to it
yes I hope there's no more discussion
hey
um
I miss representative salloway is still
not here it's representative Nelson
president
oh there he is okay sorry I couldn't see
you okay
um this is
um Xiao
604 as an FN as amended
be retained
representative Marsh
but yes
representative McMahon
yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Folsom yes representative
Kelsey
representative King yes
representative co-fault yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative snow yes
representative
yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes representative Shapiro
yes
representative Woods yes
representative merchants
yes
representative Pearson yes okay that is
20 to zero and one absent
incent it's not on the calendar not on
the calendar no not on the calendar it's
at Gary and Jerry's calendar
yes okay sorry
now before we move on to something that
is going to be totally non-controversial
that being the protective order for
adults I suggest no I demand we take a
10 minute break yes thank you
oh
yeah
investigators
in a surveillance footage
but they believe they have enough
service
foreign
hi Jim it's Lucy could you just give me
a quick call I'm trying to get hold of
you before we go back into session it's
nothing major I just want to clarify
something thanks
representative Weber uh I just want to
let you know your microphone is on thank
you
I appreciate it
foreign
you have a friend here on that one and
other things to do
thank you very much
foreign
Pearson here I just want to double check
it on 246 which is what we're doing next
you're down to move itl yes okay good
just wanted to check thank you and I
will remind the chairman as somebody
just reminded me that he is also unmuted
he's unmuted because yeah yeah watch
what you say because we can hear you yes
I really can't hear us because we have
his headsets on
yeah exactly
um mark
Europe nope he's not hearing yes
yeah Mark you're unmuted no just so you
know that we're hearing everything you
say well I was about to say some things
about you and so thank you
feel free my friend just just because we
are next to each other we can't hug each
other okay tough noogies
no elbows either
I know
I guess you don't miss sitting next to
me anymore Jerry oh yes I do because we
had a hell of a good time
with Frank
[Laughter]
you know when I was in radio one of the
first things they banged into our head
is every mic is a live mic
and every one of my teachers had some
horror stories as to how they learned
that one the hard way
foreign
while we are waiting to 3 30 hour to
arrive we will be meeting next Tuesday
not Monday next Tuesday and I should
have sent you a list of the bills we
will be having hearings on and some of
the ones I hope we might be able to exec
so that's next Tuesday
it's going to be a busy week Tuesday
for us and then Wednesday Thursday for
the entire house
but we're up to it so there it is
all right it is now not quite
I promise 3 30. well Mark that's why
they pay us the big bucks so we can get
all this stuff done yeah
Thursday is a normal week exactly yes
yes
although we normally start at 10 rather
than nine but that is a normal week we
usually have either two committee days
in one session day or two session days
and one committee day depending on how
close we are to a deadline so it's not
unimaginable it's the other zooms that
all of us have endlessly that then make
our weeks seem far longer and the other
thing that I notice is that
um
we used to have an actual Rhythm to the
week because you did here exec on
Tuesday reports on Wednesday scheduling
on Wednesday session on Thursday and
repeat next week uh now there really
isn't any rhythm to anything we just
have zoom meetings all the time so and I
find that infinitely more exhausting and
uh I can't appreciate the kindness of
all of everybody
uh recognizing the difficulties that
everybody else is working under I
appreciate that very well it looks like
we will only have to have one meeting in
March uh first week of March and one
meeting in the week before the 11th
um we're moving things along fairly well
everybody's you know everybody's had
their say but they're not taking too
much time and so I don't think one of
those weeks we will need to meet twice
so let's let's keep at this
well now I open the exact session on
House Bill 246 establishing a protective
order for vulnerable adults introduced
to us by representative Renee Cushing
and the chair calls on representative
king for a motion
unmute
I can't see him on the screen anywhere
sorry about that there we are it's okay
representative king for a motion that
was a good practice run it was
thank you Mr chairman uh similar to what
representative Marsh said on hb604 I'd
like to see good bills come out of our
committee and as much as I'd like to see
the elderly protected I just don't think
uh HP 246 is going to be that bill so
I'd like the motion that we move HB 246
to Ito
and
someone had asked me representative
Betty gay had asked if she could second
that and if you still would like to you
need to unmute and say so
I second the motion thank you now we may
discuss it
and representative King because you made
the motion you may continue to discuss
it if you wish
yes this this bill in in my opinion is
um
it's it's missing a few
uh I I think the language is just um
it's it's lacking a lot and the biggest
one is really the due process part and
um and I think somebody that's that is
wrongly accused could go a long way down
the road of having possessions taken
away from them and as some people have
mentioned Firearms would be some of
those possessions
um and there's really no recourse for
that person that's wrongly accused so I
really think that this bill needs to
really do a better job with identifying
due process
thank you representative Weber
thank you
um
the bill
and I'm incredibly saddened by this bill
because it has had an enormous amount of
work
from an enormous amount of people
and the intent and the effect
would have been to protect people who
are desperately in need of protection
and
there due process protections that are
in the bill
comport with due processes we already
know it
I think that
uh the
the very remote possibility
that somebody might have a firearm
removed
inappropriately can be rectified very
quickly
the very
real and and and let me say that those
people are not people who are actually
in this proceeding being accused of a
criminal event so uh they're not accused
they're there are allegations but this
is a civil proceeding it's not a
criminal proceeding
but what I really want to say is that
the amount of misinformation and
fear-mongering that has been generated
about this bill
really really saddens me because the
effect is that vulnerable adults who are
being ripped off
or exploited
or harmed
is very real and the the
um
means
to quickly resolve that from them are in
this bill and they will go on suffering
and yeah a couple of people who may have
been
um I
I think I'll just leave it there they
will continue to suffer and a very small
theoretical
potential
section of the population
um
has triumphed over a very large segment
of needy people and I think that's wrong
thank you thank you representative
representative snow
look at how he's really learning how to
do that isn't that great well the
buttons don't cooperate with me I
apologize for that oh you got it that
time you nailed it
thank you I'm I'm I I shared
representative webin I mean I do
understand that some people are
concerned about due process but really
all the due process arguments I've heard
about is the ability to confiscate
Firearms or limited access to firearms
and really when you look at the number
of Elders that are really impacted by
somebody threatening them with a gun
it's rather low it's realistic and the
consequences could be very serious but
the majority of things that will be
dealt with under this is the financial
exploitation The Taking of property the
misuse of property the transferring of
property selling cars on people are
doing that sort of thing and neglect is
the biggest form of abuse where people
just aren't properly cared for instead a
left very unenchanitary situations none
of which is in any way probably impacted
by the possession of firearms in any way
so I I sent out a proposed amendment to
this to all the members of the committee
uh on the 7th of February and I'd like
you just to consider this to see if this
is a protective action if we said
on deaf on page uh uh two line 19 and
20.
and again on page 11 line 22.
if we made this statement any protective
action taken under this statute protect
seniors and vulnerable adults for abuse
neglect or exploitation shall not
included audit the confiscate or limit
access to firearms for a person named in
the complaint
now I don't like that because I don't
think it's really a gun grab bill but
this at least eliminates any possibility
of people calling it a gun grab Bill and
would still give us a course of action
in the majority of cases to take some
action protect very vulnerable people
early not just the elderly too but the
individuals with developmental
disabilities and others that are often
get taken very great advantages
so I don't know how people feel about
that I wish we could pass it without
saying that but we tried to remove every
mention of firearms in the last bill
and that wasn't good enough because at
least one of the representatives who is
a child a member of the grabs the gun
lobby said that because it comes under
the jurisdiction of the district court
that Court person could still confiscate
weapons
so I thought that at least if he was
acting under the under the terms of this
statue this would prohibit him from
giving such an order unless he was going
to take additional criminal charges
under another statute to accomplish it
so you know to me I think possibly this
would be a way of saving the bill I
don't know how other people feel about
it I didn't submit it to OLS for a
formal Amendment because it seemed a
little controversial for the way
everybody in this committee really
talked about it but I do know that I
can't remember one of the other members
of this committee said what if we just
excluded firearm and that got me
thinking about it it would still protect
most of the people we're most worried
about
but when we some people still a little
bit at risk and if it turns out that
later on we discovered we should have
included that to be very easy to remove
it but let's put it in now and get the
bill passed
um
[Music]
through OLS as a formal Amendment coming
to us did you
you do I want to be 100 sure okay I
would I would I didn't well I sent it
out to everybody and asked me to think
about it and so forth I didn't think it
was appropriate to have a discussion
online because we weren't officially in
the committee and I know the rest of you
felt about me putting in this amendment
I think if you feel that it would save
the bill and it would satisfy some
people's due process concerns let's
submit it and and see what happens but
if not and I did when I wrote it I said
I wrote any protective action taken on h
no 246 and I realized that you'd have to
take out HP 246 and put in this statue
but other than that I think the wording
is relatively simple and if you know
I've read the bill a number of times and
I think these are the only two places
you really have to put it in order to
have that
I I think I can I I think I can speak to
that representative snow in a number of
discussions Each of which was quite 91a
legal
we feel that even if it was stipulated
that this has nothing to do with guns
and Guns are forbidden subject in this
we we have other trouble with the bill
so even if your Amendment came forward
which we appreciate the graciousness of
it I do anyway
um it wouldn't have made any difference
on how we'll vote
in what way I don't I do not understand
uh we have other problems with the bill
even if it was
written into the bill your Amendment
we would still have other problems with
the bill so
that's why we didn't salute it it didn't
fix
the problem I don't understand the other
problems well let me call on a few other
folks and if they don't outline them I
will but I'd like to call on them
representative kovalt please
thank you Mr chairman
um
so yeah I am actually the one who who
had asked one of the uh one of the
people getting testimony about
whether or not they would be comfortable
taking or inserting language that would
would specifically exclude Firearms
confiscation and I found it rather
interesting that the the answer to that
was not an affirmative yes at the time
um I I actually think that the the
Genesis of this bill uh several sessions
ago in which Firearms were mentioned
some 20 times or so or perhaps more
um is is fairly revealing I think that
even if this were to exclude uh Firearms
confiscationist it is still problematic
insofar as it
um it it does exclude due process and
um there are implications even if
even if we were to insert language I
have learned uh that there there still
would be implications for firearms
ownership
um which is that you know someone who is
Accused under this statute whether
rightly or wrongly uh would go on a list
that is checked as part of the
background check process when a Firearms
purchase occurs so there there are
fundamental issues with this premise of
a bypassing due process whether whether
the bill says that Firearms seizure will
be excluded or not the the concern is is
still very much there and I guess I
would I would just underscore the fact
that
um the the right to keep and bear arms
is is a constitutional right it is
um is specifically called out in the
Constitution uh for a reason just as
free speech and free exercise of
religion
and so it really goes far beyond what
might you know some some people may
prefer to see it as uh something more
like uh driving which is actually
categorized as a privilege not a not as
a right under under the law so
you know I I believe that whether this
is amended as uh as representative snow
is suggesting or not I still think that
it is not a good bill I do not think we
should uh you know I I do not think we
should move it forward so I will be
voting to itl
I think your representative
representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
almost almost everybody who I've heard
talk against this bill has started off
with I know this is a well-intentioned
bill but
um and in my view this bill has been
permanently stained since it did include
Firearms confiscation a few years ago
and there's no way to get beyond that at
this point so I would challenge people
who are voting against this bill
um because I don't think that we can
find an amendment that is going to um
convince people to vote for this bill
but I would challenge people perhaps in
this conversation
to talk about their ideas about
how we could start over and what we
could do to address the problem which is
the exploitation and abuse of elderly
and
um disabled people who are not able to
fend for themselves if not this bill
what ideas how do we perceive
thank you I I would agree oh excuse me
Mr chairman uh representative gay we're
going to let everybody have a go and
then we'll go to round two
representative gay thank you Mr chairman
and I definitely agree with
representative Shapiro and
representative snow and representative
Lucy what's your last name
um
there's a crying need for protection and
I went through with a friend who had
developed Alzheimer's and never got what
we went to court and nothing good
happened
um and so I think we do need a totally
new bill there's a definitely crying
need for one but this one this bill was
way too much like the one before and I
also agree that I'm always want
um
I let's see what do you call it when
they have hearings and you're not
invited and it's all about you
um
anybody think of that word ex parte ex
parte yeah yes I absolutely don't like
ex parte and yet there must be some way
to protect people's
um bank accounts when somebody is
stealing them so if that's a much more
complex thing to be dealt with it does
need to be dealt with this bill doesn't
does not offer the protections that we
really need but we really need that bill
so I'm hoping that we follow
representative Shapiro's recommendation
that a lot of heads get together and
write the bill that we need
representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
everyone for your comments I agree with
representative Shapiro that there is a
need to protect uh elderly people
particularly from Financial exploitation
and other sorts of exploitation and I
will call as attention to existing law
RSA 6319 is entitled Financial
exploitation of an elderly disabled or
impaired adult and I would suggest that
if this existing statute is
unsatisfactory we amend the existing
statute and not write an entirely new
section of law uh to solve a problem
that we already have a statute in place
to attempt to solve thank you chair
calls on himself we also have RSA 631 8
and 631 10.
uh in the bill itself on page three line
29 it speaks about not being bound by
technical Rules of Evidence there's a
number of these little flaws and uh why
and my my final point is
on February 8th page A4 of the New
Hampshire union leader woman charged
with stealing identity of adult
acquaintance I thought they couldn't
charge her because this bill hasn't
passed this is an individual who
um eight felony counts of identity fraud
and theft by unauthorized taking
uh elder abuse is here and this person
could have
30 years in the state prison and four
thousand dollar fine for each of the
charges
now
that sounds like we have some things on
the books with teeth so the first thing
people wanting a bill on this have to
convince me is what is missing from the
existing law because that person that 56
year old Pelham woman who may be going
to jail for the rest of her natural life
uh committed some crimes against laws
that are already on the books
one final Point
um
in my 46 years as a clergyman I have had
four cases of adults who have been
exploited elder abuse
I also have had two cases of individuals
who are improperly and unjustly accused
and after their lives were made of
shambles after a lot of money had to be
spent after they lost their job after
their reputation was ruined the finding
was oh they didn't do it we caught the
person who really did so while I very
much weep
for those people who are abused I very
much weep for those who are have their
lives ruined by a bill that is not as
tight and precise as it should be so I'm
very clearly voting against this bill
and I would say the burden is on those
who think that the laws we have on the
books are insufficient
to show us why and how what is missing
it wasn't missing for that woman in
Pelham what is missing and then show us
some ways we can fix what we have and do
it in a way that doesn't violate the
civil rights of others
representative Shapiro
foreign
I would just say that I think the
difference between someone being charged
after the fact is that this bill was
created to for prevention rather than
accountability afterwards and
um
and the idea of taking immediate action
to prevent abuse happening in the moment
creates some real trade-offs or
conflicts with due process it it
um
and I I understand that and I understand
that's a hard pill to swallow but many
many things we do in this country in
this democracy
um
involve trade-offs of
the greater good versus the individual
good or one person's rights versus the
others and that's the thing that we're
here trying to think intelligently about
and
um
create a good bill for
so I understand what you're saying but I
think the difference is that this bill
would address protecting somebody in the
moment versus accountability after the
fact
thank you anyone else wish to comment
seeing none we have I did I wanted to
yes that's right you get a second go I'm
sorry representative I'm sorry no no I'm
really sorry I I I I read almost every
one of the hundreds of responses we got
to this bill all of which
maybe two or three defended the bill all
the rest was saying how due process
against people who might lose their guns
was the point of the thing but what
about the due process of this elderly
woman that has seen her relatives
siphoning off her money
okay so you go to court and you make a
charge against her in the meantime this
woman is still subject to the influence
of these relatives who are stealing from
her
there's no immediate action that can be
taken to stop it
I as a social worker used to have to go
into homes and I saw people lying in a
bed in their own filth have not been fed
in days and you can make a charge but
nothing immediately happens to stop this
from going on in the meantime and we can
talk about due process but under the way
the bill goes there is a bit of an
expati but I don't know where that
applies other than I don't see why if
you were told to no longer steal money
from your grandmother
that that would in any way come into
being when you're going to purchase a
gun
because we're not talking about guns or
anything to do with it uh
I don't know if even anybody that has a
restraining order placed against him by
a relative and you could do that as well
but that's a court thing in office no
immediate satisfaction in fact sometimes
it takes so long that something happens
in the interim but I guess I'm concerned
that we are very concerned about a few
people's due process rights I know the
expat a thing isn't good but you can ask
for and you'll be right right in this
bill ask for an expedited hearing the
longest that can go is three days
and the only thing that I know that that
really
defends against is having a guns return
but we're not taking their guns away
anymore we're simply saying you can't
continue to do this right away later on
you can challenge that whether or not
you were doing it or not doing it and I
don't know why being accused of
something and founding innocent other
things like this that we would now
include in this bill exploitation
neglect
and that board is on abuse I think
you'll agree some of the things that
I've seen over the years are clearly
abusive but they don't involve beating
someone up but threatening them with a
gun
but I I think we haven't done enough
I think we could look at some of those
other bills but what that would require
is taking those bills and building some
immediate protective action in you know
if you had the abuse bill I don't know
how long it was between the time that
woman was charged and when she ended up
in court but I'll bet it was quite a
while
it was two years sir yeah it makes your
point what can happen in that two years
whereas a bill like this would say Okay
immediately you need to stop
now they also are free to bring some
other challenges and if it turns out
it's more serious than you immediately
thought
and they do have a right under any of
these things if your name appears on a
complaint brought by someone
you can request an expante hearing
and I mean an expeditious
hearing is what I meant to say and and
that gets wiped away but it still gives
people a
ability to develop a plan with increased
knowledge to keep that person protected
and that's what I'm basically hoping
this bill would provide now it may be
that down the road we can take one of
those other bills as I think you
suggested and build some things into
that to give a more immediate response
but in the meantime I don't know who
would really be hurt by putting this in
it's easy enough to take it off the
books but right now there's no immediate
protection for people are being abused
in this way
uh by other people either in their
family or you know people at a Hyatt
that come in as temporary help and I
think we've all heard horror stories
about things like that
anyway I guess I'm just
I think I've seen enough things in my
career to know that I'm very bothered by
the way some very vulnerable people are
treated and people are much more
concerned about the due process of the
person committing these acts they are
the due process of the person that's a
victim
and I think they deserve some immediate
response to protect them if they're in a
situation where they're at Great risk so
that's that's my only argument against
it and it's I'm the only one that feels
that way it sounds to me like at least
representative Shapiro shares my concern
but he's in the same profession I'm in
but he's seen a lot of the same things
I've seen over the years and I think you
have Mr chairman and you're yes sir I
have yes I have and let me take my
second round turn here I too would very
much like something that's immediate and
that's why that two years before Justice
was served for that poor woman in Pelham
yeah we have to do something better but
I find it ironic because the very people
who taught me
we have to
have the rights of the accused
upheld is not my people on the political
right
and I if I I could even stipulate this
bill has nothing to do with guns and I
try to say that to the hundreds of
people who email me about the gun grab
this bill is and no it's not it might
incidentally be so in a few cases this
is not the bill from a few years ago but
it still troubles me that the rights of
the innocent may be inappropriately
trampled on and as I say I learned that
from my liberal friends over the years
so there's got to be a better way I
think
to
do expedited things so that the the
putting people at risk harming
vulnerable people is stopped not two
years later but immediately and still
uphold the rights of somebody accused
who might actually be innocent so that's
my plea anyway
um representative Weber
thank you and thank you for letting me
have my second round and and I will
dress it only a couple of things
the statutes that you're citing uh in
the 600 range are criminal statutes
they don't happen quickly because we do
liberal or conservative are are are
pretty careful of the rights of the
accused because we are bringing the
entire force of the State against an
individual so we cannot take the
criminal statutes and make them quick
that's item number one item number two
is if you are concerned about removing
Firearms
um
somebody who is charged under the
criminal laws more likely to have their
firearms taken away than somebody who is
caught up in a civil proceeding
uh the third thing is I'm just going to
point out that
it is horrible to be accused wrongly and
it should not happen but it certainly
happened to two people that
representative Pearson knew without the
benefit of this statute that's going to
go on happening
and the other thing that is going to go
on happening is that the rights of
innocent people are going to be
infringed upon every single day going
forward
it's just going to be the rights of
our vulnerable people our more
vulnerable populations
um and and I just think that's a
terrible shame and I certainly will be
glad to work
going forward on other ways of dealing
with this but there are not a lot of
other options to work quickly
through to address quickly a problem
that needs to address quickly and it
can't be done through the criminal
justice system
um and that's I I will try very hard not
to say anything else at this point and I
thank you
if I could
perhaps one other area we could explore
currently if you're under the age of 18
and you're being abused there is a state
office that can walk in and without
if they determine that this child is
very much at risk they can be removed
or other actions can be taken and people
can be forced forced in the end it could
end up in court but in the meantime some
protective actions can be taken to make
sure that child is safe
I am simply saying I saw this bill is
doing the same thing
for elders and vulnerable people if we
rework it then I think but we've got to
think in terms we're willing to protect
children
but older people with Alzheimer's
disease or other kinds of physical
disabilities we seem to think they're
grown up they should be able to take
care of themselves and the truth is they
can't
and it's it's wrong to hold the rights
of
people who think they can own guns and I
have no problem with people owning guns
my father was a gun collector my son
collects guns I mean I'm not against gun
owners I'm just saying that at times I
think you can recall a couple of
incidences that recently happened there
was a man that walked into Mary
Hitchcock hospital into the Intensive
Care Unit shot his mother
we had a we had a young man that went to
a police or a supervised visitation at
the YWCA
shot him son and shot and shot himself
and so at times
this comes in so guns but I'm not
willing to give up all the protections
for older people merely because some
people are so concerned that maybe their
right to own a gun or buy a gun or
whatever else it is of being infringed
upon because it would almost never
happened
nor am I representative snow and I would
remind you you did not ask to speak and
this is your third round so now
representative gay has been called on
again thank you sorry that's okay buddy
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm not being an attorney
um I I'm very basic at what I would love
to see what representative snow is
talking about take the child protection
laws
and rewrite them or don't rewrite them
just put put substitute uh vulnerable
people where you have child uh the other
I'm sorry my my computer keeps acting
funny so that's why I'm not showing
anymore
um also when somebody has a DUI they
they're supposed to have a hearing in
three days but they don't wait for three
days to arrest them or stop them and I
understand injunctions can be made under
other legal excuse me
situations so that you could free I want
to see a bill a law that says you can
freeze someone's asset so somebody else
can't take them an elderly person or a
person who's sick
uh and this other person that we all
have horror stories of being robbed by
somebody who pretends to be their friend
I can't believe we can't come up
applying laws that are applicable to
other bad situations we really need to
do this and they do need to be immediate
and we have rep we already know about
immediate reactions to children that we
think are in dangerous situations
immediate situations for somebody uh
stop driving
drunk or under the influence there has
to be a way to write some good laws and
we need to do it soon thank you
representative gay representative
Shapiro
yes I hope I can count myself as one of
those liberal friends who's um maybe
influenced you about the rights of
victims I hope you you are a liberal and
you are my friend so I guess so
um but what I would say about the the
criminal justice system is that
it's inspiring to me anyway
um and it's imperfect and so especially
in recent years with advances in DNA
technology we've had a lot of
exonerations
where people were proven to not have
committed crimes that we thought they
did and some a lot of them have served a
lot of time in prison
um
and I know you're looking to
avoid those kinds of miscarriages lesser
miscarriages in this kind of situation
but I would say that we
find someone who was
um
convicted of murder and spends years and
years in prison and when we realize that
he is innocent or she is innocent we let
them go but we don't repeal the laws
about murder
and so I would say that in some way this
is an equivalent that we're
um we're we're throwing out the
possibility of protection in the form of
this potential law because
um there may be someone who would be
um accused unfairly and in fact
undoubtedly if this law if this has
become law eventually some people would
be accused unfairly
but our system is imperfect
thank you my friend
representative Nelson
I see uh I'm not a big gun person I have
a gun but I'm not a big gun person in my
vote on this will not be to help the gun
people because I have seen people who
have been taken advantage of elderly on
the other hand I think this needs to be
I want to see this fix somehow I'm not
sure this bill
is what's going to work is there going
to be another state somewhere or
somebody that's done this that has a
better
look or an answer to doing this because
I'm all in favor of protecting the
elderly and I do believe they got abused
but I also like the last person said
there are people who
there are bad people and there are other
people that just take advantage of the
situation so I'm not really sure how I'm
going to vote on this one
thank you representative Makai
all right thank you Mr chairman
I won't repeat everything my fellow
social workers have said I'm more
pragmatic at this stage of my life I
pretty much know how this bill is going
to end up therefore if we are hearing a
tremendous
support for this type of legislation
I think we should get to work and bring
that in
to the second year and do the best we
can because I think everybody is in
favor of that so even though I'm kind of
bought against this motion I very much
support going ahead with this and
solving it as much as we can thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
um more of a procedural issue is there
any advantage of retaining a bill versus
bringing another bill completely
different in the fall for next year
there would be perhaps a Time advantage
that a retained bill could be heard in
January
um
we have a motion itl on the floor that
would have to be defeated and then
another motion would have to come
forward
um
so I believe
um I think that's correct if yeah I'm
learning thank you yeah
um that could happen that's what it
would take
so Mr chairman if I may just I'm
learning as well so in saying that it
sounds like we do a retain then the
committee or subcommittee or group of
this
get together and work on the bill
to make it workable for all the parties
involved and then ultimately that goes
back into legislative Hopper next year
versus starting over from scratch it
sounds like we're tanning it does allow
for the opportunity for people in the
community to work on it either during
the summer and the fall and not have to
literally start over from scratch is
there any that's all I'm trying to get
to I think honestly we would probably
start over from scratch except for the
idea that we very much want to help the
elderly and as much as possible knowing
it will never be perfect lower the risk
that somebody will be inappropriately
can accused and ruined I think would
have to start over from scratch and what
I would like to see my fantasy is
um when when the when a bill comes back
I want to see 10 Republicans and or five
Republicans and five Democrat
co-sponsors I want to see somebody who's
an NRA member and somebody who's an ACLU
card carrier and if you think Canuck and
yourself are going to have fun this
summer uh this group is going to have a
lot of fun but I think it might be worth
it
yes yes yes
is it possible to withdraw like I
seconded this bill to I tell it I would
rather retain it is it possible if the
both of us re withdrew
and put a new without voting on it can
we just withdraw it an issue of make an
order um
make a motion to retain I believe it is
possible representative Weber
uh it is possible if the moving party
and the seconding party decide to do
that and I will certainly go along with
whatever people decide to do but I have
to say having worked on this bill three
times including the time when we brought
it out of this committee you will
remember twenty to zero
because we had addressed many many of
the issues that we've already talked
about
um and I could go on for hours about how
this bill does exactly
the thing that several people have asked
that a subsequent bill due
I really think at this point that taking
a new start
is a better idea because just the fact
that it has the same bill number
even if it is completely reworked I feel
that people who are not going to read
the careful reworkings that are done
over the summer I think we are far
better to start again with a new build
number and and work at that and see if
we can't come up with something than we
are to retain this bill and bring it
back under the same number I think that
well has been poisoned I think you're
right and this does not mean that this
summer and I appreciate the thought it
could not mean it could mean that this
summer
a group of people from all across the
Spectrum
could try
to see if a new bill
yeah sure a lot of the work's been done
and we know that but we don't have to
give it the same number because I agree
the weld's been poisoned but if a
bipartisan by sponsored
bill
if it's possible
could be brought forth and thrown into
the hopper in the fall and come up next
year
I think
um representative Cannon
I'd be willing to help on that I have
both an ACLU card and an NRA card so
um also just write the bill yourself oh
yeah you'd be the sponsor I would I
would love to help out also because I am
a transgender person to add another
voice from the community because I think
it would be important for us all it was
also subject to abuse at times yeah I've
been there in there representative
Merchant
yeah
okay take your hand down thank you
representative Folsom you got your hand
up
um yes I would love to work with
representative cannon on a new bill
despite
look go for it like despite how
enthusiastic about it I don't care about
this bill it's the idea of protecting
those people that I've now work my buns
off make sure this happens so now maybe
I'm a little too enthusiastic you may be
right
but I can temper myself down if I think
there's something that's going to go
somewhere and I think that may be the
best of solution uh but
but I'm still
without a pessimistic only because of
the huge volume 12 with a four or 500
emails so you all have got up this
matter and uh you're absolutely right no
matter what we did I think it's doomed
at this point so starting it all over
having a different title doing something
else we may have to do something about
creating some more organized
organization somewhere like dcyf has now
so that there's actually a plan for how
they'll carry this out without leaving
it it's not a willy-nilly with an expat
a hearing in front of a judge only to
carry it out it's got to be a better way
to do it and I hope we can succeed in
doing it thank you it's come to my
attention that representative kanurk has
enthusiasm to spare should yours yours
ever Wayne
representative King
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
maintain the motion that's out there and
also
um throw my hat in the ring I would I
would love to work on this as I started
out I think this is really a
well-intended bill and uh I'd like to
see it work
with the prime the Mover of the build
not re we're calling it then the motion
on the floor is the motion we are to
consider but we're seeing a growing
group of people across not only our
Spectrum but the Spectrum who could uh
start to work this summer does anybody
have anything else to say or do we now
uh move on this motion of Ito
representative Cushman has a index
finger up
Mr chairman
um I would just urge the members of the
committee to um since this bill seems to
need to start from scratch and not you
know it's going to need yeah it it
should be itl today and you guys can
bring a new version of what you want to
do uh next session and my fellow
scotsman's correct this bill's going to
die somewhere if it doesn't die here
it's going to die in the floor or it's
going to die in the senate or it's going
to die in the governor's desk
representative Nelson
I think this committee this year I
honestly believe they're all committed
to fix this we know there's a problem we
know there's two vert things out there
but I can't believe with all the talent
we have we can't fix this so I'd rather
see us do it next year and get it right
and we're all committed in various ways
whether we actually serve on that
subcommittee or speak to it we're all
committed to make this happen folks this
isn't a political lie we don't like
those here this is a promise to one
another
yeah
representative canarick
I would just like to point out that as
Charlie McMahon says let's get this done
while we're still young because a lot of
us are getting old enough we may need
the statute someday
well you know that is that is one reason
why I'm concerned about your loaning not
loaning excess enthusiasm that's not
good when you get to our age
he's not old to Mr chairman he's
aggressively mature thank you I was
waiting for that all right the question
is itl 246
moved by King seconded by gay the clerk
may call the roll and Jeff needs to show
himself and and let me just say that uh
if if you want to itl the bill your vote
is yes if you don't want to itl to bill
the vote is no
get everybody ready
um representative Marsh
but yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes
representative gay yes representative
Cushman yes representative Folsom yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King yes
representative kufault yes
representative Weber
representative Weber oh sorry
my apologies that was a no
okay representative McKay no
representative snow
yes
representative knurk
no usually I'm prepared sorry
I'm sorry was it no no okay
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro
no but if perchance my side loses I'd be
glad to work on another bill
representative Woods no
representative Merchant yes
representative Pearson did my side win I
will also want to help on another bill
yes
and there will be a Minority Report Mr
chairman when do you need it by
oh probably by tomorrow
uh and uh the motion carries 15 to six
thank you and um we would I would ask
for the majority report to come from
representative King if I could have it
by tomorrow morning early and the reason
for that is I want to get it to the
clerk they may decide to put it on our
calendar for voting next week or not but
at least we need to do it
so if I could have that we will again
temporarily suspend you do not leave the
room until I get the report
um
for next week because it's an early bill
um in
um
Mr chair yes yes that's an early Bill
okay may I request maybe this is
impossible to do may I request the
opportunity to change my vote from yes
to know I had no I thought I was the
only one that was going to vote no
and so I voted yes could I could we it's
still Fair it still fails but it would
just be I believe that's in order short
of me looking it up in in Mason's uh or
looking it up in Weber
I I think we can have an informal we
have often had informal revisions to
that and there isn't a lot in Masons
about committee work so what would that
both be now if I changed it
um it would be 14 to 7.
okay that's still it okay does anybody
have any objection to that the results
ultimately will be the same and I didn't
drop the hammer so this hearing still is
not I mean this exact session is not
over on this bill
and I think that means it's okay but if
it isn't let's all pretend it is
representative Pearson I have checked
with the clerk and he said it is not an
order
what quirk
oh Paul
to change your changes since Mason isn't
around
reconsider in order
I wouldn't believe it yes that would be
an order it is an emotion to reconsider
would have to come from somebody voting
on the prison prevailing side so if
somebody on the prevailing side is
willing to
um is willing to move to reconsider than
we can I'll make a motion to reconsider
you're on The Winning Side yes
okay I just since I know where the
procedures limitations reconsider a
second
um
no we don't debate it again we could
debate it again if we debate it again
you don't you really don't want to I was
just kidding I know that
yeah so the motion to reconsider is
coming from king and the second is
Merchant now motion is coming from
Merchant the second I'm not sure I think
it was coming from I'm sorry
okay
sorry about that thank you
all right hold on one second I believe
everybody but I just want to see it
because this cost a hundred dollars to
buy and it was a present from my
favorite daughter uh reconsider oh Jesus
uh three
reconsider you're not supposed to claim
which is your favorite that's not nice
well it's easy it only has one thank you
oh that makes it easier yeah it seems to
be okay from what I was able to skim so
uh reconsider
uh the clerk may call the roll please on
reconsidered
of the motion to itl
um
reconsider Mark uh representative Marsh
yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson no
representative Acton yes
representative gay yes
representative Cushman wow
no represent
sorry I didn't think he made a mistake
um do we need to clarify what the vote
is
we have if go back to the last person
whose vote you weren't sure of and say
what did you say
uh
representative guy can you I guess I'm
really lost now I gotta say yes or no
I don't know what I'm voting on
reconsidering the vote because one
remember
let me explain it to you uh one member
wished to change his vote in the best
way that can be done is for us to
reconsider the original vote
whereby he will be voting in a different
way and that will be a courtesy and so
this is just about as to whether we
should are you on that uh representative
salt thank you
um so this is the reconsideration of the
vote so a member may change his vote
okay but I still need to understand if
we vote for reconsideration then we vote
again we vote the bill again okay if we
approve reconsideration okay thank you
oh oh my vote's supposed to be yes okay
representative Cushman
oh
representative Folsom yes representative
Kelsey yes
representative King yes representative
kofault no
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative
snow
yes
representative knurk yes
representative soloway yes
representative Cannon
you need to unmute Brian I'm trying but
yeah
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant
yes representative Pearson yes the
motion carries
now the motion before us is
um the itl motion on House Bill 246 as
made by uh moved by representative King
and seconded by representative gay
you may discuss this but I really hope
you don't want to and I'll give you a
minute
the chair calls whoever just said she
has her other index finger up now
um I I just want to say I didn't vote no
to not be courteous
um to representative snow I voted no
because as far as I knew and I did
mention it and tried to ask Christina to
ask the clerk
um that before covid you had to wait
until the next committee meeting for a
reconsideration motion
is that right I don't think so no no
well then I was wrong but not right
that's okay
it doesn't matter
yeah no offense taken I can assure you
well you know what if we later found out
this was a very very sincere error uh
the original vote stance but in case it
doesn't let's do it again okay
this is the vote on itl of House Bill
representative Marsh
that's yes representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative Cushman yes
representative full sun yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King yes representative kofault yes
representative Weber
no representative McKay no
representative snow no all right thank
you representative
no
representative Solway yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Woods no representative
Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes okay that one
is
yeah
one two three we're at fourteen to seven
I think
oh geez three four five six seven yes
thank you very much
now I I do want to have a moment of
personal privilege if I may
okay
you know what kind of a nightmare this
report is gonna be for me to put
together
I have to get this all on paper
representative Nelson and I feel your
pain
a number of us have gone through this a
number of times it's been fun and we
appreciate the effort that it took it
and there's only one more and I hope
this is very brief
[Laughter]
you may have just
killed our chances by saying that but
yeah
okay so I don't know whether I'm
supposed to bang the hammer or not but I
just did to close the last one open the
next one this opens the exact session on
244 relative to the membership and
duties of the joint health care reform
oversight committee uh you may remember
the uh Chief and only sponsor
representative Abramson came our way to
explain why he thought this ought to
happen and he you may remember
um uh said what this committee shall
study including some very very specific
items and uh I'll just leave it at that
would anybody like
to make
the right motion on this I'll make a
motion to itl thank you my friend
second and who is that Weber
Weber Weber
okay so that is snow and Weber thank you
all right any discussion on this
told you'd be quick
they'll jinx it we all feel the same on
this don't we
yes get your vote right we're not
considered reconsidering this one
oh God
[Laughter]
I worked for him so when the clerk is
ready
okay sorry okay
um the vote to itl on House Bill 244.
representative Marsh
yes representative McMahon
yes representative Nelson yes
representative Acton yes representative
gay
did we lose representative gay she has
to unmute oh I'm so sorry yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Olson yes representative
Kelsey yes representative King yes
representative co-fault yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative snow yes
representative Kirk yes
representative soloway yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter upon yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes
representative Pearson yes
21-0 the motion passes
uh Mr chairman yes in the middle before
you possess this committee I'm not
recessing this committee yet I I got
your text we
thank you consent for this bill before
we go on to anything else we absolutely
can move consent on this and who made
the motion you did didn't you
representative
pepper
representative snow moved I seconded itl
and I moved consent
I was there representative snow would
you write the blurb and get it to me by
tomorrow morning
all right thank you now it seems that in
my beautiful wonderful there has to be a
problem here somewhere but I haven't
found it I've just been pointed out that
there is an early bill that we have to
look at to get out the door I'm sorry
that was it you were all heading for
your early dinner but representative
Marsh would you please introduce it
while I find it uh yes House Bill 314 is
also an early Bill uh my opinion on
House Bill 314 is it's problematic it's
drafted we also received an amendment uh
I think it's still problematic one of
the reasons it's problematic is that it
includes food and drink and what it
would allow and I believe that would
include alcoholic beverages uh and
probably that would be a violation of a
number of laws so I think this bill is
not ready for prime time uh whether we
want the itl or or retain it it's a
matter for the committee to consider
is this the
uh yes I don't believe we exactly
Homestead Homestead
Homestead food operating advice here
on my colorful notes I have that we
retained it on February 8th yes
I have this report with the HTS that
says
if you'd like us to vote again no oh
please God no no I have the yeah that's
what I got it must be that the
documentation we got from upstairs is
incorrect and I apologize for that I was
just trying to look out for my chairman
okay I just checked uh the form was sent
in
yeah and the um it was uh moved by
representative Marsh and seconded by
representative Weber and the voter there
we go one to zero well we've been way
too busy
we all we all get a mistake each week
and Bill this is yours so
um there's a few of you who have yet to
do one and that's that's okay the week
is your turn is coming it is and what do
you mean it's coming it's been coming
all day all right so with that I
adjourned that exact session and with
that our meeting here today
we did it thank you all
happy morning hi there oh yeah hi
everyone oh that's right tomorrow's
island or if you're Irish it's pancake
night
right
yes my little friend here is fasting
from everything for Lent oh yeah that's
what he wants to look like
he belongs to my Skeleton Crew no all
right
[Music]
good night everybody good night
everybody
representative you did not cite the
reference for your comment about bowls
of porridge when you were discussing
your amendments
I think it is in the public domain
um representative Nelson
do you can you unmute and talk to me oh
yeah can you do you have the ability to
just scan your notes from earlier today
and email them to me after I rewrite
them so I can read them okay
thanks everybody oh look look look look
look look at the Weber dogs
wanted to apologize uh as do I for
inserting himself uh at one point when I
forgot momentarily where I was and that
we were all on cameras
and I will apologize word I said into an
open mic when I realized that he was
now
you probably heard representative hunt
wasn't very happy with cats uh in
Commerce and Anita Burroughs is one that
had the cats she she her viral tweet her
very tweet went viral and she's been in
all in People magazine and all kinds of
stuff with the picture of the cat
because of the controversy about this we
made the news again yeah
I suggest and representative I've got to
be on this committee with his dog
shortly thereafter that's perfect
repentance means change of behavior not
just remorse and I would suggest that at
a future date we all have a pet of our
choice in our lap just so we can make
Newsweek yeah we ain't got one you can
rent one
good night everybody bye everyone
I wonder if if
Brad Pitt's available to sit on my lap
would work okay he's not a pet
I can mess my household pet don't say
that in the committee with therapist and
clergy please
recording too guys my husband isn't real
pleased either he's starting to voice
his opinion in the other room good
please tell me if this is legal can I
send an email to everybody if it's not
about a bill
yes
yes like thousands of people we won
money or something
so you're inviting us to a party
I'd love to do that but no it's uh uh
there's a movement afoot to ask for the
wend him voting
Escapade whatever you want to call it to
be studied
and it's going to take a lot of support
to make that happen okay I'm very
concerned because my town uses the same
software well it's not about a bill it's
anybody's facing I I don't see it why
not we will do it or not no problem I
will say there have been other things
that people have found to be tacky there
was a member at one point who was
sending out
um uh advertisements for his business
probably not a good thing but if if you
just have a petition of some kind I I
don't see that there's any problem with
that
thank you
good night could I ask a quick question
I could not find a paper copy of the of
a bill I think it was 617 oh is it 607
that we itl'd I want to look it up and
but I don't want to be looking for
numbers which one was that
617-617 because the sponsor uh withdrew
it and she said it was no longer
necessary yeah the one that she said
could it could be done without any
statutory requirements well it's
redundant wasn't it there was already it
just could have been taken care of under
existing statute she just didn't get to
the right place it's going to be done
through rules she'd talk HHS and and
yeah that's right the rules yeah are
we're going to accommodate a real good
night everybody that's what number five
are you still young representative
McMahon
yes
yes I am at this point
I'm glad you are
well it's the result of Cooperative
collaboration to achieve consensus like
we did today
good
I write all my own material so hopefully
I know you do that's your charm
no that was really sweet today when we
went to all extra bother so that all the
votes could be honest